Caption test.  This is a caption
test.  Caption test.   test.
Android with the Android Testing
Support Library
One two, one, two, three,
four.   Yeah.
Android with the Android Testing
Support Library
Welcome.  Thank you for
joining.  Our session will be
starting
soon.
Welcome.  Thank you for
joining.  Our session will
begin soon.
At this time, please find your
seat.  Our session will
begin soon.
Hello, everyone.  Welcome to
this morning's session on
Test-Driven Development on
Android with the Android Testing
Support Library.  My name is
Jonathan Gerrish.  I'm part of
the mobile ninjas.
show of hands for those of you
writing test as part of your
normal software development
practice? FANTS.  If you have
written tests for Android
before, you have probably used
some of our tools.  We have the
J unit, the Espresso testing
framework and active
contributors to Robolectric, the
Android source testing
framework.  Everyone is telling
you to write tests.  should you
do it?  It is true that tests
take time to write.  They're
adding code to your code base
and perhaps you have been in a
situation where the manager or
client has been telling you it
is slowing you down.  There are
so many compelling reasons to
write tests.  They give you
rapid feedback on failures.
Ones that are spotted earlier
are far easier to fix than once
you have gone live.  Tests give
you a safety net.  You can
cleanup code and safe in the
knowledge you will not break
existing behavior.  TestTests
are the backbone of software
development.  You can maintain
the stable velocity throughout
the lifetime of your project.
You will avoid the boom-bust
cycles of crunch feature and
aggregation of technical  In
software testing, there exists
the concept of the testing
pyramid.  This is made up of a
number of layers. layer brings
with it the tradeoffs that you
have to
weigh.  Smallest layers of the
small unit tests.  These should
be fast and focused.  are known
as local unit tests, run on your
local desktop machine.  The
tradeoff you are making with
these tests is infidelity,
because you are not running on a
realistic environment and
probably substituting in a bunch
of mocks and fakes.  As we move
up the pyramid now into the
realms of end-to-end and
testing.  We suggest you run
these tests on a real device or
emulator.  These are the kinds
of tests that will tell you your
software actually works.
However, they are less focused,
so a failure in one of these
kinds of tests might take longer
to track down than it would in
the unit test.  One of the big
tradeoffs you are making is in
test execution speed.  Because
you are assembling multiple
components, they have to be
built, package shipped to a
device where the tests are run
and results reflected back.
will take extra time.  So there
is no language layer in this
testing pyramid that can
suffice.  You need to blend in
tests of each different tier,
leveraging the strengths of one
category to weigh off the
tradeoffs in another.  There is
no real hard and fast rule here.
But Google's own internal
experts recommend the 70/20/10
rule of thumb as the ratio
between small, medium and large
tests.  Let's look at work flow.
with test driven development,
the idea is you start by writing
tests, implement the codes to
make the test passes, when the
tests are green, you can submit.
Again, a quick show of hands,
who out there has test-driven
their code, tried test driven
development in the past?  Okay
cool.  We like test driven
development.  It makes you think
about the design of your
application up-front.  It gives
consideration to the API and
structure of your code.  With
test driven development you
write less code because you only
write the code necessary to
satisfy your tests.  This will
enable you to release early and
often as you are constantly
green, you will deploy an early
application at a moment's
notice.  If we are following the
test pyramid, the work flow
will look something like this.
First of all, we have a larger
out duration, with the feature
development.  Here it is driven
by a UI test.  The mantra with
test driven development is red,
green, refactor.  We start off
with the test, implement code to
make the test pass and then we
refactor.  Inside the larger
iteration are a series of
smaller iterations and these are
concerned with the unit tests.
Here you're building the units
required to make the feature
pass.  And again, you use the
same mantra here, red green,
refactor.  Red, green, refactor.
Let's take a look at a sample
application.  The feature we
will implement today is the add
note flow.  is an add note
feature.  start on the list
screen full of existing notes.
action at the bottom. user will
click this, taking them on to
the new add note screen.  They
can enter a title and
description for the note before
clicking save.  note will be
persisted and returned back to
the notes list screen where they
can see the newly added note
and any other notes that
previously existed.  So coming
back to our work flow for a
moment.   we start with a
failing UI test.  Take a look at
how this test would look like
using Espresso, the UI testing
framework.  The first step is to
click on the add note button.
Then we enter the title and
description and click save
before returning to the notes
list screen.  Here, we're going
to verify that the note we just
added actually shows up.  Now,
remember, with test-driven
development, we're not
implementing code yet.  we have
to do is implement enough of the
application to satisfy the
specification of our test.  An
empty activity and just
resources we need will suffice.
Once we have that, we can run
our test and we will see it will
fail.  Now we have to implement
this feature.  So applications
are built up of many small
units.  are small, highly
focused, specialized components
that do one thing and do it
well.  Collection of the small
units are then assembled
together so their collaborations
will satisfy our feature.
Let's take a moment to summarize
the key characteristic
characteristics that make up a
good unit  As well as the normal
conditions, you want to test
your failure conditions, invalid
inputs, boundary conditions.
You can end up writing a lot of
unit tests.  tests must always
give you the same result every
time.  Avoid depending on things
that might change.  For
example, an external server or
the current time of date,
because this is going to bring
flakiness into your unit tests.
Unit tests should exercise one
specific aspect of your code at
a time.  You are wanting to see
that a failure in a unit test
will lead you quickly to an
actual bug in your code.  When
you write unit tests, avoid
making too many assumptions on
the actual implementation of
your code.  You want your unit
test to avoid behavior and avoid
rewriting tests when the
implementation is changing.   of
the most important aspects of
unit tests is they've got to be
fast, especially because you are
writing so many of them and you
are in TDD work flow write --
running them rapidly. would be
unfortunate if you are
discouraged because of the
tests, because of the pain in
the execution time of the
Finally, unit tests are an
excellent source of
documentation.  The way that is
constantly evolving with the
code as it changes unlike static
documents that will stagnate
over time.  Let's write a unit
test for the add notes activity.
will take in user input and
persist it to local storage on
the device.   so we will create
the add note activity class, and
this will extend activity which
is an Android framework class.
It has a view which will be
inflated with the layout.  The
user will enter the data.  We
will persist that note into
Android shared preferences
mechanism.  So it is conceivable
as our application evolves, so
does our requirement and perhaps
storage requirements evolve to
persist the notes on to Cloud
storage and we have to build a
synchronization method for the
storage of the offload case.
these, we see opportunity for
abstraction.  We might see that
we can extract notes for
repository.  However, one of the
key aspects of test-driven
development is we only start by
writing the simplest case first
and then iterate.  We will
resist the temptation to do this
early.  Let's take a look at a
sample of what an idealized unit
test would look like.
Generally built up in three
stages.  So the first stage is
you're setting the conditions
for the test.  And this includes
preparing the environment,
setting up your dependencies
with the required state and
preparing any input data.  Next,
we'll exercise the code and the
test before finally making
assertions on the results or the
state.  So I like to clearly
separate each of the three
stages of the test and bring the
pertinent aspects of each test
front and center to make for a
really readable test.  up until
now, with the Android platform,
you're writing your unit tests
using the mocking jarring jargon
such as mockito.  Let's look at
a test written with mockito.
Wow, that's a lot of code.
Okay.  So because of so many
interactions with the Android
framework, we need stubbing just
to satisfy the execution paths
of our test.  furthermore,
because Android uses a lot of
static methods, we're forced to
introduce a second mocking
library, a power mock to handle
this special case for us.  There
are also some pretty bad codes
here.  Take a look.  You see we
are forced to spy on the
activity on the test.  And we're
needing to do this to modify
its behavior and stubbing it out
and providing no-ops.  We're
moving to the realms of black
box testing.  Finally, at the
end, we're making assertions
about the implementation
details.  If these change, our
test will need to change, too.
So remembering the
characteristics of a good unit
test, let's take a moment to
score this particular test.   it
is very focused.  just testing
the happy path of our add notes.
And it is certainly fast
because it is running on the
local JVF.   we were making a
rather lot of assumptions about
the implementation in that test
and with this, if any of our
implementation changes, it is
likely we'll need to rewrite
that test substantially.  And
finally, all that excess boiler
plate stubbing is distracting.
It is distracting from the key
conditions of the test that
you're trying to document.
Well, luckily, there is a tool
that helps address some of these
issues.  So
introducingintroducing
Robolectric.   is an Android
unit testing tool that is open
source that we're actively
contributing to.  And to tell
you more about how to write
great tests with Robolectric.
will hand you over to Christian
Williams, the original author of
Robolectric.  (Applause)
CHRISTIAN WILLIAMS: Thanks,
Jonathan.  It is awesome to see
so many people that are into
Android testing and TDD.  is
this scrappy little open source
project that I started hacking
on back in the early days of
Android testing, because I was
super annoyed at how long it
took to deploy and run tests on
an emulator.  And it has been a
side project of a bunch of
different people until last year
when I had the privilege of
joining my friend Jonathan at
Google where he was already
working to improve Robolectric
for the internal test  then we
have been beefing up Robolectric
and contributing back to the
open source project. Today,
Robolectric isn't an officially
supported part of the Android
testing platform, but we found
that when it is used correctly,
it can be a useful part of the
testing strategy.  I will show
you a little bit about how to do
that too.  Let's go back to the
notes unit test and see how to
approach it with Robolectric.
Since Robolectric runs as a
local unit test, it will still
be running on the workstation
not an emulator.  Robolectric
provides an Android Sandbox next
to your test, where the actual
SDK code is running.  will have
access to activities, layouts,
resources.  And you can call
most Android methods and they
work as you would expect.  are
parts of the Android framework
that rely on native code or call
out to hardware or interact
with external system services.
For that, Robolectric provides a
test double that we call
shadows.  provide alternative
limitations of the code that is
appropriate for unit  So
remember that test that we just
saw that had like 20 lines of
like mock setup code?  Let's see
how it looks in Robolectric.
So that is a lot less.  You have
gotten rid of the boiler plate.
The test is about half the
size.  Much more concise.  Not
forced to think about
deimplementation details as
we're writing the test, which is
nice.  will set up the
application according to
manifest.  Here we ask it to set
up the activity.  It goes
through the appropriate life
cycle to get in the right state.
Views, all that, that we
expect from the can interact
with it as if you are on the
device.  You add texts, fields,
click on it.  Assert the note in
the repository.  We are not
going as far as the UI test we
wrote at the beginning.  We're
not asserting that the new note
appears on the view screen.  be
the job of another unit test.
Now, I mentioned Robolectric
shadows. actually give extended
testing API to Android classes
that let us query internal state
and sometimes change a
behavior.  this example, we're
asking the application if any of
our activityes requested that
an intent be launched during the
test.  We can use that to
assert after saving the note to
the repository, we are going to
go to the view notes activity.
Similar testing APIs exist for
simulating hardware responses or
external services, things like
that.  So at this point, we have
a failing unit test.   we get
to -- we're ready for the easy
part.  the production code.  the
spirit of TDB, we're only go to
write exactly as much as is
needed to make the test pass.
No more, no speculative coding.
We inflate a layout, attach a
click handler.  When the click
happens we create a note and
add it to the repository.  We
can write a note, watch it pass.
We can refactor.  Then repeat.
This is where you get the
thoroughness.  Robolectric is
handy for this because you have
nice fast test runs.  You can
get into a comfy cycle.  we want
to not just test the happy path
here.   to test all the
different cases that our code is
likely to encounter.  For
example, input validation,
external conditions like the
network being down, stuff like
that.  can help with simulating
device conditions that you'll
encounter.  For example, you can
specify qualifiers that the
note -- the test should run
with.  Here is a certain screen
size, orientation, which might
change the layout a bit.  You
can ask Robolectric to run the
test under a specific SDK.
We'll say jelly bean.  It uses
the SDK code from that version.
you can also tell Robolectric,
I want to run this test under
every SDK that you support or
some range of them that you are
interested in.  We support jelly
bean through -- right now.  At
Google we rely heavily on
Robolectric and investing in
making it better. have dozens of
apps, including these that have
hundreds of thousands of unit
tests running internally, it is
well battle tested.  We started
running the Android CTS, the
official Android test suite.
Against Robolectric.   getting
better with every release.  If
you used Robolectric in the past
and found it had come up short
or if you are stuck in an old
version.  I definitely recommend
that you get up to the latest
because it has come a long way.
We've been working on reducing
friction and integrating
Robolectric with the Android
tool chain.  It works well with
Android Studio, with cradle, we
have support for bezel, the open
source gold system coming soon.
So Robolectric isn't a
one-size-fits-all testing tool.
It is fast, but not 100%
identical to Android in every
way.  You want to use it
judiciously.  As we said before,
avoid writing unit tests that
link multiple activities
together.  That is not so much a
unit test, that is more
Espresso.  Multiple threads,
synchronization issues, that is
probably not a unit test.  Not
good for Robolectric.
Particularly avoid using
Robolectric to test integration
with Android APIs and things
like Google Play services.  You
really need higher level tests
to give you confidence that that
is  Now that we have passing
unit tests, I will hand you over
to my colleague Stephan to talk
about higher level testing.
STEPHAN LINZNER: Thank you,
Christian.  So let's go back to
our developer work flow diagram.
And so at this point, we
hopefully have a ton of unit
tests and they thoroughly test
all our business logic.  But
let's switch gears and see how
we can write integration tests
to see how the units integrate
and how they integrate with
Android and how they run in a
real environment.  So on
Android, these tests are usually
referred to as instrumentation
tests.  And I'm pretty sure most
of you have written an
instrumentation test before.
they look super simple on the
surface, there is actually a lot
going on under the hood, if you
think about it.  You have to
compile the code.  You have to
process your resources.  You
have to bring up a full system
image and then run your test.
There is a lot of things that go
on, on various levels of the
Android stack.  So these tests
give you high fidelity, but
as Jon was mentioning, they
come at a test.  But they're
slower and more flaky than a
unit  Let's see how it works in
the day-to-day development flow.
Say you are in Android Studio,
you have written the espresso
test and hit the run button to
run the test.  The first thing
Android will do is instuthe APK,
and the test, and APK.  It
contains the test runner and the
test manifest.  calls ADB shell
A.  Android change runner will
use instrumentation to control
your app on the test.  So what
is instrumentation?  I think you
guys may have noticed this.  a
top-level tag in the manifest.
Why is that?   something used
deeply inside the Android
framework and used to control
the life cycle of your
activities, for instance. if you
think about it, it is the
perfect interception point that
we can use to inject the test
runner.  That is why Android
runner is nothing more or less
than an instrumentation.  So
let's go a little bit deeper and
see what happens when Android
Studio actually runs your test.
It runs ADB shell instrument,
which will call out to activity
manager.  manager will then call
at one point on create on your
instrumentation.  So now that we
know that Android runner is the
instrumentation, at this point,
it will call on create on the
runner.  Then the runner is
going to do a few things for
you.  It will collect all your
tests, then it will run all the
tests sequentially.  And then it
is reporting back to results.
thing to note here is Android
runner -- and you may have
noticed this, runs in the same
process than your application.
And more importantly, if you
usually use Android runner, it
runs all the tests in one single
instrumentation invocation.
runner is heavily used inside
Google.  We run billions of
tests each month using Android
runner.  While doing so, we saw
some challenges that we faced
and we had to solve.  One thing
that we see a lot is shared
state.  And I'm not talking
about the kind of like shared
state that you control and that
you code in your app.  I'm
talking about the shared state
that builds up on memory.
Builds up on disk and makes your
test fail for, you know, no
reason or unpredictable
conditions.  And this, among
other things will at one point
lead to crashes.  in the
previous model that I just
showed you, if one of the tests
crashes the instrumentation, it
will take the whole app process
with it. the subsequent tests
will not run any more.  This is
obviously a problem worry  --
large test suites.  if you think
about debugging, if you run
several tests, think about what
the loghead will look like and
what to go through for  Inside
of Google, we have taken a
different approach.  Inside of
Google, every test method runs
in its own instrumentation
invocation.  So now, you can do
this today, right?  You can, you
know, make multiple ADP calls,
use a runner arc and create a
custom script.  problem is it
may not develop well with the
development environment.   I'm
happy to announce the Android
test orchestrator. Android test
orchestrator is a way to run
tests like we do at Google.  It
is an APK that runs in the
background and each test in the
single instrumentation
invocation.  it obviously has
benefits, right?  There is no
short state.  In fact, the
Android test orchestrator runs.
clear before it runs each test.
More so, crashes are now
completely isolated because we
have single instrumentation
invocations if a crash happens
or the subsequent tests will
still run.  Similarly for
debugging. the debugging
information you pull off the
device is scoped to a particular
test.  is great -- this is
great and we benefit a lot from
it, inside of  Let's see how it
works.  top of installing the
top we install a third ABK.  It
is running in the background,
containing the orchestrator.  of
multiple ADB, we run a single
ADB, we instrument the
orchestrator directly.  The
orchestrator will do all the
work on the device.  It is going
to use Android change runner to
collect your test but then it
will run each of the tests in
its own invocation.  This is
amazing.  I'm pretty sure you
will like this a lot.  It will
be available in the next Android
testing support
library release.  We will have
integration with Android Studio,
available in Gradle and have
intGRAGD with fire base Test Lab
later this year. we know how to
run our test let's look at how
to write the int-Greg
g test -- test.  There is a
nice, simple API.  It works
simple.  What it does is you
give us a view matcher and we
find a view that matches the
matcher and we perform a view
action, a check of the
assertion.  of this API is so
simple, it is the perfect tool,
too, for fast TDD prototyping of
the eye test.  In order to
provide you such a simple API,
there are a lot of things that
need to go on under the hood.
Let's look at how Espresso
works.  When you call on view
and give us your matcher.  The
first thing we will do is create
a view interaction for you.
And then the next thing is we
make sure that your app is in an
idle and safe state before we
interact with it.  This is the
core of Espresso.  It is well
known for the synchronization
guaranties.  The way we do it is
we loop the message queue until
there are no messages for a
reasonable amount of time.  We
look at all the idoling
resources and make sure they're
idle and make sure the async
task.  Only when we continue is
in a sane and stable state, then
we will move on.  We will go to
the hierarchy and find the view
that matches your matcher.
have the view, we will perform
the view action or view
assertion.  is great.  So now
let's circle back to the test
that we showed you in the
beginning and have a closer look
now that we know how Espresso
works.  In the first line, as
you may remember, we tried to
click on the add note button.
Here we will use with I.D.
matcher.  That is a simple
matcher, matching the view in
the view hierarchy.  next thing
we want to do is click on the
view.  We use the click view
action for this.  So now, where
it gets interesting is the next
line.  on this line, we want to
type the title and description
and we want to use a type text
action for that.   the Espresso
synchronization guaranties will
kick in, but only if we know you
are ready to interact with your
application, we're going to
invoke the you type test act.
This is great.  it frees you
from adding additional boiler
plate code and additional
sleeping code to your task.
Similarly, we are going to save
the note and then we will verify
that it is displayed on screen.
is great. we know how Espresso
works and we know how it is a
great tool to do test-driven
development.  And now I will
hand over to Nick to talk more
about how to improve your UI
test and large and medium
testing strategy.     NICK
KOROSTELEV: Thank you, Stephan.
One good attribute of a UI test
is a test that never sleeps.
Let's go back to our example to
illustrate this point further.
In the example, as you remember,
we have a note we save into
memory, which is fast and
reliable.  However in reality,
as your app grows you probably
want to extend this
functionality and save your note
to the Cloud or
Google Drive, for example. the
large end-to-end test we want a
real environment and real
server.  And depending on the
network connection, this may
take a long time.  You probably
want to do it in the background.
The problem is Espresso
synchronization is not aware of
the long-running task.  This is
somewhere where developers would
probably do something as ugly
as putting a thread sleep in
their code.  Espresso it is not
required because you can write
an idling resource.  That is a
simple interface to teach
Espresso synchronization of the
custom, long-running tasks of
your app.  So with this idling
resource, we made the large
end-to-end test more reliable.
Let's see how to add more
medium-sized tests to the suite.
We want to keep them small and
focused.  There may be a
specific view fragment or
activity.  Let's go back to the
example to see how to isolate
the large end-to-end test to
more isolated components.  Here
in the example, you may have
noticed that there are two
activities.  The list activity
on the left and the add note
activity on the right.  Until
now we have a large end-to-end
test that gives confidence
because it touches upon code in
your app, which is great for
large end-to-end but not great
for iterative test development
Let's see how to isolate these
and have isolated tests for each
activity in isolation.  To
isolate the left-hand side, the
list activity.  We can use
Espresso intent.  Espresso
intent is a simple PIP
Punxsutawney Phil that will
allow you to share and verify
contest and  look at the result.
Let's see what the API looks
like.  have an intent matcher
that will match your intent and
you can provide a version of the
activity result back to the
caller.  Let's use the API to
write the first isolated test.
In this test, you can see on the
first line, we do exactly that.
We intercept our intent and we
provide a stub version of the
activity result.  Now, on the
second line, when we perform
click, instead of setting up a
new activity, Espresso will
intercept this intent and
provide a result that we can
then use on the last line to
verify that our UI was updated
accordingly.  Now, we have an
isolated test.  Okay.  So let's
go back to example and see how
we can isolate the second part.
So when you usually write
tests, you end up in a position
where you may have some external
dependencies in place that are
outside of your control.  So in
our example, right, as I showed
before, we have a note we saved
and it hits the real server.
Now, even though we have another
resource that makes it more
reliable, your test can still
fail because your server may
crash for some reason, so your
test will fail.  So wouldn't it
be better if you completely
isolate ourselves from these
conditions and run our tests in
a hermetic environment?  will
make your tests run faster but
also eliminate any flakiness.
And beyond the specific example,
you further want to isolate
yourself from any external
dependency.  So for example, you
don't want to test any Android
system UI or any other UI
components you don't own because
they probably already tested
and can also change without your
knowing so your test will
actually fail.  So let's see how
our second isolated test will
look like in code.  So here, we
see the main point here is we're
no longer using the real server
and instead, you know, we set
up a hermetic repository.  There
are many different ways to do
this.  is just one way.  So then
you can use this hermetic
repository to verify that the
note is saved without ever
leaving the context of the app
or hitting the network.  So at
this point, if you think about
it, you have two smaller tests
that are run much more -- that
are way more reliable and run
much at the same time, you
maintain the same amount of test
coverage as the same end-to-end
test.  This is why we want more
of the smaller isolated tests
compared to the large end-to-end
tests we showed before.  Okay.
So at this point, we iterated
through our developer cycle a
few times.  And we should see
all of our tests start turning
green and we should be confident
to release our feature.
However, before we conclude,
let's jump into the future for a
second.  As your app grows and
your team grows, you continue
adding more and more features to
your app.  may find yourself in
the position where you may have
UI running in multiple
processes, which is exactly what
happened at Google.  So if you
go to the add notes example,
this may look something like
this.  have the first activity
that runs in the main process on
the left-hand side.  Now, the
second activity will run in a
process and in this case we will
call it add note.  How do we
test that?  Before Android O, it
was impossible to test.  With
Android O, there is a new
instrumentation attribute that
we can use in order to define
which process you want to
instrument.  While instrumenting
and running tests, I guess each
process in isolation is a great
idea, you should do it.  You
may find yourself in a position
where you want to cross process
boundaries within one test.
will probably want to write an
Espresso test that looks like
While this was not only possible
on the framework level on
Android O, it was impossible on
the Espresso level.  In this
example, Espresso is not aware
of the process and nor can it
maintain the synchronization
guaranties we know and love.
I'm proud to announce
multiprocess Espresso support.
any test code or app code, this
will allow you to seamlessly
interact with the UI test
process and maintaining the
guaranties.  And available in
the next version of the Android
test release.  Let's have a
quick overview of how it works.
as we know in your example, we
start in one process, where we
have an instance of the note
runner and
Espresso.  When the click add
note, there is a new activity
and a new process.   now is we
have two processes, two
different instances of the
Android runner and Espresso.
They're not aware of each other.
The first thing we want to do
is establish communication
between the runners.  Now that
we have the communication, we
can use it to establish the
communication to Espresso, for
instance. way we do that is by
having an ability in Android
runner to register any testing
framework with Espresso with the
Android runner and the runner
will facilitiate the
communication required in
between the two Espresso
instances.  Now that the two
Espresso instances can talk to
each other, it can use it for
cross process testing and
maintaining the synchronization
guaranties we had  So with that,
we are reaching the end of the
developer work flow and showed
you all the tools to use across
each step of the way to make TDD
happen on Android.  that said,
if any of you don't follow this
flow exactly.  Hopefully you
know how to use every single
tool and write good tests to
bring your app quality to the
next level.  So if you like to
write tests and you want to
write and run tests like we do
at Google, here's resources to
get you started.  I want to
thank you, and I think we have
some time for questions.  And if
not, we have office hours at
3:30 today.  So hopefully we'll
see you there.  Thank you.
(Applause)
Thank you for joining this
session.  Brand ambassadors will
assist with directing you true
the exits.  We'll make room for
the next session.  If you
registered for the next session
in this room, we ask that you
please clear the room and return
via the registration line
Google Assistant to any device
Welcome.  Thank you for
joining.  Our session will begin
soon.
Welcome.  Please fill in the
seats near the front of the
room.  Thank you.
Welcome.  Thank you for
joining.  Our session will
begin soon.
Hello, welcome to Google io17.
I hope everybody had a great
first day and people got to
checkout the sessions, Sandboxes
and labs.
I'm Chris Ramsdale and I'm Glen
Shires.  We want to talk to you
about the one ubiquitous
experience that impact your
everyday life.
made the debut with Allo.  Much
of what was made up for years,
like voice search, automated
speech recognition, energy
language understanding.  They
were in the works for years, it
was the first time they made
their public debut in the form
of the assistant.  Since then,
the teams have been hard at work
to flesh out the story that
Google wants to tell, in terms
of launching new devices like
Google home, pixel and other
Android platforms.  We have also
brought third party services
into the fold, like via actions
in Google, in terms of home
graph and smart home agents I
will talk about in a bit.  And
while this was great, when we
took a step back, we realized
something was missing.  Within
Google, one of the
missions is to help you with
what you want, whatever you
want, wherever you are.  of
these things were only available
from devices Google provided.
Let's be honest, we don't expect
a Google home in every governor
corner of our house or have an
appliance in every area of your
house.  We needed to empower the
diverse ecosystem that could
embed the Google Assistant in
the devices they were building.
actions enable to extend the
assistant to third party
services.  We needed an
analogous device.  We needed to
embed the assistant.  Enter the
Google Assistant SDK.  It is a
kit that allowed third party
manufacturers to embed the
assistant in the device.   core
is the
third part gRPC API that allows
the implementation into the
devices.  The API is an audio
in, audio out API.  Users can
interact with the assistant, in
a general form, hey Google how
big is Mount Everest, to a
personal form, what is on my
calendar today.  To extend to
the actions on Google.  The API
is built on the gRPC protocol,
you can be sure your audio
flowing smoothly and processed
While it was only announced
three weeks ago, we have seen a
lot of cool innovation
happening.  For starters, there
is a mocktails mixer.  I
encourage you to come out and
see it.  It is a collaboration
between the STK team and deep
local.  It has the Google
Assistant building in and it
will make you the drink of your
choice.  We have the
auto Pi
.IO and a smart rabbit Wi-Fi, if
you have a smart rabbit rather
than a Google home, you have
options.  We are working with
commercial OEM to include it in
their devices.  We will have
branding and UX guidelines
coming.  Speaking of spurring
innovation, another program was
AIY, similar to DIY, it is to
bringartrtificial intelligence
to the maker tool kit.  At the
core of the program is a set of
kits to build.  The first kit
was a voice kit with the Google
Assistant SDK.  A box and
instructions to make your own
Google home to help you extend
in ways we never dreamed of.  is
one up here, and glen will do
demos on it shortly.
As of yesterday we added a
thick client library to the SDK
to automate level plumbing and
support and timers and alarms.
With the addition of the
library, developers have o
ptions.  If you want more
automation or hotword support or
timers aligns, we think the
thick client library is a good
fit.  You need to be familiar
with the Linux and other
platforms that it is tied  On
the other hand, if you need
platform independence with the
gRPC API is a great right.  It
accessible from any platform,
hardware or language, with the
caveat of not having hotwords,
timers, alarms, but that is just
for  I want to take a moment to
actually preview some of the
tools that we're building to
make voice controlled devices
much easier.  Glen will have a
demo and we have demos in
Sandbox B of this, but I wanted
to take a moment to provide a
higher level view to understand
broadly what we wanted to
achieve with more devices in
your life with the assistant on
them.  It is important to know
what devices you have access to
in your house.  Be it the TV,
speaker, oven, or the Wi-Fi
enabled rabbit we talked about.
By knowing what you have access
to in your house, we can enable
and create more natural
conversations with the devices.
We think that is important.
Because if we don't get this
right, this whole voice-enabled
thing we're trying to do and
make happen, right, it will be
very hard for the masses to
adopt it.  You want to have
normal conversations with the
things in your life, like with
the people in your life.  By
knowing what devices you have
access to, we can make the
conversation more natural.  of
saying, for example, if you had
a smart-enabled oven and in the
living room talking to Google
home, instead of saying hey
Google, let me talk to my
company.  My company, set the
oven to bake and set the oven to
425.  What you can say is okay,
Google, set the oven to bake at
425.  Just as you would talk to
your child or wife or somebody
else in the kitchen.  It is more
Now I moved from the living
room to the kitchen, say,
preparing dinner.  I am talking
to the device itself.  you talk
to the device and say hey
Google, let me talk to my
company, set the oven to back
and set the oven to 425.  you
want to do while chopping, say
Ok Google, set to back at 425.
It is more energy if you are
talking to the Google home
device or the device itself.
That is the beginning of the
end-user experience we are
trying to achieve.  Let's go
deeper and talk about how that
would actually  Take the case
where you have got -- you're
actually doing remote
invocation, talking to the
Google home, setting up the
oven.  In that case, you say set
the oven to bake at 425.  So
that query goes from me to
Google home, then to the
assistant service running.  The
assistant service is made up of
speech recognition, natural
language understanding, the
smart home. technology called
the home graph.  So what it can
do is take that query, what I
said, and start to parse it
apart.  When it parses it apart
the speech recognition speaks to
the home graph and says do you
recognize any of the pieces in
the phrase.  The home photograph
says I do.  I recognize the
oven as being a device
registered with the home graph.
The way it is registered is
when you go to your home device,
on the assist app you say I
want to add that to the home
graph.  home graph says I
understand that is the oven.
speech recognition says that is
great, I have the oven, the
noun, the thing I'm operating
on.  And other things that look
like verbs and nouns as well.
It passes it to the natural
language understanding, that
serve, it takes that and said to
the home graph, do you
understand what it means to set
this program, which is bake.
And set this temperature.  Home
graph says yes.  The oven is
capable of these certain traits,
programs that are like bake,
warm, broil and temperatures.
That's a number.  At that point
in time the natural language
understanding says cool, I
understand what they said and
what they intended.  But it says
I have no idea what to do with
it.  I have an intent, but I
don't know what to do with it.
It sends it to the smart home.
It says cool, I know what to do
with this intent.  I know this
oven is of this type, tied to
this manufacturer and this
manufacturer has a third-party
Cloud that knows how to get the
intent down to the device. is a
very analogous -- to give a
concrete example, this is
analogous to the nest
thermostat.  You talk to the
Google home, at the end, the
smart home component hands it
off to the nest Cloud and the
Cloud says I know how to query
for the device of the
temperature or set the device on
the device.  This says local
execution, this is the remote
invocation path.  This is when I
talk to the
device.  Let's talk about the
local invocation path.  This is
in the oven talking to the
device.  That query comes back
in the same path.  I didn't say
the oven.  The speech
recognition, it gets the query,
missing the oven piece, but it
gets metadata, the device I.D.
From the assistant being
embedded on the oven, picking up
the query, figuring out the
device and passing it up to the
Cloud.  The speech recognition
says I got this set to back at
425.  But I also have this
divide I.D. graph, do you know
what to do with this.  In a
similar fashion, the graph says
it is this device I.D., and it
is tied to this manufacturer and
this is an oven.  It has the
same building blocks from remote
and local invocation.  will
pass on to the natural language
understanding.  And the NLU can
do the same thing it did before
and pass it to the smart home.
This point in time, things  The
smart home said I understand the
intent of the user, but that
came from an interaction of the
device.  smart home gets the
device I.D. as well.  When it
talks to the home graph, the
home graph says you can send
that back down to the device,
you don't have to go through a
third party Cloud.  The smart
home sends back to the device,
so setting oven to 425 and the
structured response in terms of
the Jason payload to the device
to say, cool, when it sends to
the device, it is sending to the
assist embedded on the device.
The assistant says I don't know
what to do with this, but let
me see if I have a module to
register this response.
Do-do-do.  I do.  it on the
device and that sets the oven to
bake at 425.  Now, to the end
user, this is great, because
again, it creates a natural
conversation no matter where you
are in your home, right?  while
I gave an example of just one
device, fast forward two to five
years.  Imagine a bunch of
devices in your home that are
listening and interacting.  If
you have odd conversations, that
will not work out in your
favor.  That is good from the
user experience  From the device
manufacturer perspective, you
get code readings.  The same
code from my home device to my
oven is the same as the device.
With a developer you get code
reuse.  That is good. a device
manufacturer, it is a shorter
path to getting to market.  You
don't have to have a Cloud
presence to have the assist
running on a device.  If your
goal is to make the devices
smarter by embedding the assist
on them.  can go the local
colocation route you can get the
speech smart home and home
graph handle all this on the
Cloud.  You notice on the screen
no Cloud presence.  We dropped
the yellow bit on the path.  You
get code use and device
manufacturer, a shorter time to
market.  Enough with the
high-level  I will turn it over
to Glen to do demo and talk
about code.  Thank you, Chris.
I appreciate that.
so as Chris mentioned,
yesterday, we announced the
hotword library that is
available for download.  So you
can start experimenting with it
and start building it into your
project and products.  What I'd
like to do is demonstrate that.
Jump right into a
demo.  And um, Ok Google, what
sound does a whale make?   whale
sound.   sounds)
GLEN SHIRES: Ok Google, what
is 18% of $57?  The answer is
$10.26. Okay, Google, add peanut
butter to your shopping  Okay,
I added peanut butter to your
shopping list.  you go.  we have
done is downloaded a library to
make it easy to incorporate
okay going -- Ok Google into
your projects and include
timers, alarms, other things.
I'm sorry.  I should have --
could we show this one more
time?  sorry.  Let's go back to
that.  What I want to do is show
you exactly what I had here.
This is a Raspberry pie.  I have
a microphone, single microphone
and speaker plugged into a
Raspberry pie.  Ethernet,
because Wi-Fi in here is tricky.
We have a speaker, microphone
and Internet connection, that is
all we need to implement the
capability of far field,
activation of the hotword and to
implement Google
Assistant. Let me show you
exactly what is in the library.
What is really cool is it is
extremely simply to use.  You
need a few method calls to make
it work.  Actually, you can only
call one method if you want to.
You just call start.  It will
just run autonomously waiting
locally to listen for the
hotword "okayGoogleGoogle".  It
will hear that, send it
up for processing.   start and
then be done.  You might want
a microphonemicrophone button
to mute it.  you might want a
button or remote control to push
it instead of Ok Google.  So
you can call start i have a
number of events that come out
as it is processing so you can
watch the status and perhaps
have lights that indicate the
current status.  For example,
conversation term started, means
somebody said Ok Google and you
begin the conversation.  End of
utterance means the person has
finished talking and recognizing
speech finish means the server
has finished recognizing the
speech and responding started.
It is talking back to you,
responding finished.  You can
set up light bulbs that indicate
the status as it is going on.
Alert started, finished.  For
timers aand alarms.  The number
of events handled or not,
depending on what you want to do
with your  Let me show you
another option.  This is an
option if you want to do
something very minimal or if you
want more flexibility and you
don't need a hotword, we have
other options as well, which is
in this case, a way that you can
make -- excuse me.  A way that
you can make remote procedure
calls directly against the
server.  So minimal processing
on the board.  In this case, I
actually have a Raspberry pie
zero.  5 or $10 retail product,
which is really all you need to
do this.  All it is doing is
sending audio to the Cloud and
getting audio back.  Not doing
any processing here.  This is
also very portable to most
platforms, most operating
systems and most of the
programming languages and
completely open source.
So what we have with this is a
way to talk to the Cloud, the
Google Cloud called GRPC or
remote procedure calls.  These
run on any platform.  You can --
these are already on Linux,
Mac, windows, Android, iPhone,
supporting languages of Python,
PHP, ruby.  There is an open
pool chain to import these into
any other platform. thing about
it is a nice robust protocol,
air handling, that allows
bidirectional streaming.  What
that means is you could send
audio to the server, while it is
sending back.  When the server
is responding you can continue
to send things out.  It is a
bidirectional protocol and
available for any platform.  So
what I would like to do is
demonstrate
this.  And in this case, I
actually have the voice
kit that -- the voice kit that
Chris was talking about.  I'm
sorry.  is all the pieces you
need to build this.  Of course,
if you want to have a speaker
and microphone, you can do it
that way.  Let me show you how
it works.  In this case, I use
push to talk. a simpler protocol
without the hotword library.
we get this on the screen?
we get the device up there?
Thank you very much.    ... how
do you say "nice to meet you" in
Korean.  (Speaking Korean)
GLEN SHIRES: What time is it
in Berlin?  The time in Berlin
Germany is 6:50 p.m.
Set the light to green.  Okay.
Doesn't show up as well there,
but maybe
you can see live that the light
turned green.  Make it red.
Oops, got to press the button.
Make it red.  It's not raining
there, it is mostly sunny.
Ha-ha.  Make it yellow.  Okay.
There we go.  is demonstrating
the device actions which we're
previewing right now, which
allows you to directly talk to
the device.  So rather than,
let's say if I'm using my Google
Assistant on my phone, I might
have to say tell my oven to set
the temperature to 425.  If I go
over to the oven and press the
button, I don't want to say tell
my oven, I want to say set the
temperature to 425.  What we
have done is when the device
with the microphone is
listening, it takes precedence
over all other actions.  You can
program actions to do your own
custom actions and on your
device, you would take
precedence.  You don't have to
preference it with tell me oven
to set the temperature.   say
set the temperature to 425.  Let
me show one more that's kind of
fun.  Play trivia game.  You
said the magic words!  to game
show mode, my friend.
GLEN SHIRES: You can see we
play all sorts of audio through
it.  Not just our favorite lady
assistant, but whatever you want
to do when you are making your
own actions.  You can create
actions that have all sorts of
sound effects.  Mix and match
those.  I'm the host of this
silly  I'll stop that.
Yeah, so, you know what, I keep
going back and forth.  I
apologize.  is one more thing I
wanted to point out on this.
Let's play five rounds.  hear
from you now.  I have important
questions to ask.  Contestant 1,
can you say smarty  I wanted to
point out is there are two
microphones here.  I will not
play the trivia game.  I wanted
to point out the fact that we
work well with one
or two microphones.  I'll get
to that in a  So the gRPC API is
a very flexible API that lets
you have a lot more control.
wanted to run through how the
API worked.  First of all, if
you wanted to connect to the
API, it basically -- you just
create a connection with a
couple simple commands, make a
channel, gives you a stub, you
can call a service.  We have a
service called converse so we
can converse back and forth with
the server.  Once you set up a
connection with the server, you
want to configure how you want
to send audio to the server and
how you want to receive it.
We're sending audio as linear
16, which is plain old PCM,
doesn't have to be compressed.We
do allow flack compression, a
lockless compression.  It cuts
down the bandwidth.   it with
16,000
Hertz and tell the server what
we want back.  We will get an
open sinologue, which is a nice
tight compression engine and
have a sample rate of 22K. gives
us some better quality audio.
So we basically set up a
configuration, and then we start
sending things to the server.
The first thing we send is the
configuration followed by audio.
We send audio in chunks.
We're streaming audio to the
server. then the server will
tell us when it has enough
audio, when it has heard theend
of the query -- the end of the
query.  And then we can be
receiving the audio and process.
So when we receive end of
utterance, we will actually stop
sending  we're going to gather
the audio coming back from the
server and play that back.  It
also has a microphone mode that
allows us to continue to talk.
So in other words, as you're
having something like trivia
game as you're playing, you
don't have to keep pressing the
button each time.  When it asks
you a question, it keeps the
microphone open so you can
continue.  Finally, I wanted to
talk about the two microphones
and the neural beam forming.
thing that we do to keep costs
down in the client is make it
work well with one or two
microphones.  With two
microphones we do neural beam
forming in the Cloud.  So the
Cloud is optimized for far
afield recognition.  In other
words, it can be far away.  It
is noise robust.  We use machine
learning to work with that.  It
is common that you may be
speaking, other kids, dogs,
dishwashers running at the same
time.  A lot of noise.  On the
server, we do all the processing
to filter that out.  You don't
need any additional client
processing, send the two
channels up to the server and we
do the neural beam forming for
you.  keeps the cost of the
client to a
minimum.  One thing I like about
this voice kit and just the
fact that we have the SDK and
made it so available is a lot of
people have started using it in
just the three weeks itself
been available.  A friend of
mine actually told me that his
daughter came to him and said
she wanted to be an engineer and
make a kitty she can talk to.
And the amazing thing is, she
was able to do that.  They
actually got together one
evening, built a voice kit
together.  Put together the
Google Assistant and now she's
actually got a kitty that she
can talk to.  I think back when
I was a kid, there was no way.
It was just a dream that I could
build a robot I could talk to
and it would understand what I
am saying and talk back and be
intelligent, let alone the fact
I could ask it virtually any
question in the world and
actually get a response because
it would know the answers.
it's really inspiring to me that
we can inspire young engineers.
I hope we're also inspiring
you to create wonderful new
devices.  Let me turn it back
over to Chris
Thanks.
e) Thanks, Glen.  Awesome demos
and words of inspiration at at
the end.  We wanted to create
one ubiquitous experience for
you to get the Google Assistant
when you need it and wherever
you need it.  We have the
whatever covered.  With the
assistant SDK we can handle the
whenever, wherever because we
extend out from the Google home
device or pixel or Android phone
to other devices you have in
your life.  And technologies
like the home graph and smart
home agent tie it together to
have a natural conversation with
the devices in your life and
feel very comfortable.  So I
wanted to SKAI thanks for oo say
thanks for coming out and
listen to our talk.  We have
actions on developer Google  you
sign up at
G.CO/actions challenge.  You
could win tickets to next year's
show and other items.  Beyond
that, we have demos in Sandbox
B.  I will be there, Glen will
be there, other engineers and
developer folks.  We have a code
lab for hands-on hacking.
enabled mocktails mixer which I
will demo throughout the
afternoon.  And home automation
system that goes in deeper with
the agents with our colleagues
mark and David.  And we have
documentation, getting started
and developer downloads.  So
cool, thank you so much.  take
questions, because I think we
have 10 minutes left, if you
want to come up and ask.
Thanks,
(end of
session)   Thank you for
joining this session.  We will
be making room for those who
registered for the next session.
If you registered for the next
session in this room, we ask
that you please clear the room
and return via the registration
line
of session (person
(End of
session)
.
Thank you for joining this
session.  Brand ambassadors will
assist in directing you to the
designated exits.  If you are
registered for the next session
in this room, we ask that you
clear the room and return via
the registration lines outside.
at Google.  But it is not just
because VR is fun or makes you
feel like it is somewhere else
it is an obvious fit for
learning, because with our team,
it powerfully supports what our
values are as people who are
trying to enable better learning
with technology.  are the
values?  For us, we think good
learning experiences should
be fundamentally immersive,
interactive and social.  No
surprise, we believe those same
things are what characterize
good VR experiences.   We think
they should be immersive because
being engaged, emotionally
invested these are important
contexts to learn.  When things
are immersive, less abstract,
less cognitive load to process.
we think they need to be
interactive, because it is
empowering to have agency as a
user, not feel constrained, to
have a thought, see a result, to
dig in deeper when you see
something that piques your
interest.  And social, because
when people come together as a
group, diverse viewpoints that
they discuss, synthesize, then
we learn from one another.  We
end up with a sum that is
greater than the parts.  This is
important to us at Google
because we're not interested in
just creating future graduates.
We want to create future
inventors, creators, problem
solvers, dreamers.  why we
started Expeditions.  We wanted
to give them tool to use VR in
the classroom and create those
experiences on a more readily
available basis.  Here to talk
more is Jen.
Thanks, Ben.  Expeditions was
the first large scale way to get
VR in the classroom.  Schools
needed a smartphone, tablet or
VR viewer, and they could be
teleported all over the world,
underwater and even to Mars.  On
our team, many of the people
that built classroom and G suite
for education is the same
people that built Expeditions.
We relied heavily on the
insights we acquired.  One of
the important things we learned
is to embrace the key functions
of a classroom.  Students
engaging, interacting, engaging
with each other and their peers.
There are things that are
critical.  One, it needs to be
so easy to use.  can't rely on
teachers to go to professional
development training to get
trained on your tool.  Two, you
need to really make that
immersion, that social
connection between teachers and
students and students and
students.  And making sure that
it is engaging and interacting.
And you need to make sure your
product works on multiple
devices and platforms.  That is
really important.  Because
schools have a variety of
devices and they have a variety
of platforms, and they're not
just going to pick You can't
expect teachers to replace their
materials overnight.  So you
need to make sure that your tool
or your product can easily fit
into the existing curriculum.
That's what we did with
Expeditions.  Just like with
Chrome books, we imagined the
kits would be a shared resource
between classes and schools.
And one of the most -- the
biggest things we realized is
that most teachers weren't
actually aware of VR when we
first started this.   we decided
to do was bring Expeditions to
schools through the Expeditions
pioneer program.  And you know,
what we saw is that once
teachers got a chance to see VR
in action and see how
Expeditions could transform
their classroom, they were
immediately hooked.  So the
first year, we took Expeditions
to over a million students in 11
countries.  We got incredible
feedback, particularly from
teachers in the U.K.  This past
year, we went back to the U.K.
and we just wrapped up our
program there, and we took
another million students in the
U.K. an Expeditions.  That is
one in about every eight primary
and secondary students in all
of the U.K.   that brings our
total number of students that
have gone on and used
Expeditions to over 2 million in
the last two years.  And even
after Expeditions has been used
for weeks or months or years, we
still get the same teacher
feedback like this each and
every day.  And so it is not
just the novelty of VR.
something is working in the
classroom.  And even more
importantly, we have heard from
thousands of students from
around the world who have sent
us personal letters and
actually, these are just the
ones we got last week.  So you
can see.  I want to share one of
them with you. it's really too
precious not to share.  This is
from Lozen, a student in the
U.K.  He sent us this letter.
He said the whole experience has
made me even more keen to
become a doctor and study the
human body thoroughly.  The
technology I used helped me
understand such complex subjects
easily.  The solar system trip
was incredibly fascinating.  I
did not feel myself sitting in
class.  Instead I felt like Tim
Peek orbiting the solar system.
Now, I'm not sure whether I
should be a doctor or an
astronaut.  I'm quite confused
at this moment.  My mum says I
should watch more of the Google
Expeditionses before I make up
my mind, and for once, I think I
will listen to her.
Yes,
Lozen with agree with your mum
and think you should use
Expeditions more before making
up your mind.  There are
traditional and nontraditional
partners.  with museum and
cultural institutions to create
the expeditions.  We have a
growing library of 600 tours and
work with many hardware
partners to create certified
Expeditions kits.  the hardware
a class of third would need to
take an expedition.  Best buy
education was one of the first
partners we used to launch the
Expeditions kit.  We worked with
several other partners to make
sure schools actually have
certified kits to use.  We have
worked closely with teachers to
create supporting lesson plans,
which is really important.  As I
mentioned earlier, the lessons
need to be incorporated into the
actual curriculum so teachers
can use it seamlessly.  We
partnered with tez to upload the
lessons.   over 8 million
teachers sharing and learning
with each other and their lesson
materials.  And what's really
cool is that we're also seeing
Expeditions used outside of the
class room.  something we didn't
initially anticipate.  We're
seeing government organizations,
nonprofits and seeing
businesses start to use
ExpeditionsExpeditions.  let's
take a look at one example.  And
what you see on the screen is
actually our coral bleaching
expedition.  highlighting the
Coraal  -- corel breaching event
in -- bleaching
event teacher used this to
explain the impact that happened
to the students.  went
underwater and explored the
coral bleaching event.  He said
that continues to add another
layer of authenticity to the
classroom, by using it
effectively and seamlessly and
integrating it into the
curriculum.  What amazed me
about this expedition in
particular, it was used at cop
21, which happened in Paris, the
U.N. change conference.  I was
fortunate enough to attend.  It
was a presentation with about
150 different scientists.  A big
panel.  You know, what was
a one-way dialogue and
panelists became lively when
they started passing out the
Expeditions kits to the
audience.  was observing the big
coral bleaching event that
happened in Hawaii whole room
was transformed instantly.
We're seeing some of the
examples occur rather
frequently.  It is really
exciting for us to see not only
how Expeditionses is used in the
classroom but also outside of
the classroom the past two
years.  What is next? One of the
most important things we value
as an education product team is
listening to teachers and
students.  We take feedback
really seriously.  We actually
read every single piece of
feedback that we receive.  I kid
you not, because my team is the
one that does it.   to address
some of the top future questions
from teachers and students.
take a sneak peek.  With over
600 tours available, we know it
can be a bit challenging for
teachers to actually find the
Expeditions that we're looking
for.  So rolling out soon,
you'll see a new UI in the
Expeditions app to allow you to
see a set of featured
Expeditions.  You can search by
a specific category.  And we've
also improved the search.  It
will make browsing easier to
find the Expeditions you want.
The other important thing is
that the
UI is responsive.  It works in
tablet or phone.  If you are in
magic window mode or the phone
or tablet, or mobile, it will
work fine.  Now, I will turn it
over to Ben.   have heard that
teachers want more tools to
highlight the scenes and
environments.  So we'll be
bringing this new sort of
annotations tool that lets you
draw on top of Expeditions.
think it will be really, really
useful.  If you think sort of
the number of times when you
watch a sports commentator to
use a telestrator to illustrate
a particularly interesting play
in a game.  That is the same
thing here.  The way this works,
the guide can draw something on
the scene with their finger or
stylus.  Like here, pointing out
where a new set of solar panels
might go.  of the connected
explorers, they see the same
thing reflected on theirs as
well.  There you go.  It's
really cool. Okay.  And now for
the number one most requested
feature of all.  The ability to
explore on your own.  Now, we
see firsthand each day how
powerful a teaching tool
Expeditions can be when used in
a classroom of
30 opportunities.  We
acknowledge as much learning
happening outside of the class
room as within it.  You don't
always find yourself with a
willing and able teacher in the
room with you.  We'll make
Expeditions available in a solo
made that lets you experience
without a live guide present.
We built out a full VR UI.  When
you found the Expeditions you
like, you can dive in, step
through the scenes and sites
within the Expeditions at your
own pace.  can learn more with
the info panel with relevant
facts and details.  So you don't
feel like you're alone.  We
added narrations to accompany
you as  View of the spot where
HamiltonHamilton fell.  This
shows memorial to Hamilton in
the background.  After being
shot, Hamilton was rode back
across the river to Manhattan by
That gives you a taste.  We
had amazing folks to provide
narrations.  I will pass it back
to Jen to tell you about that.
Anyone recognize the voice?  It
was Lynn Manuel Miranda the
American act or and playwright,
wrote and starred in Hamilton.
Some of the new tours that will
be coming out as part of the
solo mode will be -- a couple of
Hamilton tours and about
Hamilton's life and the place
where he duelled with
B
urr.  These won't save you any
money on a Broadway ticket.
Ha-ha.  With baseball, we have
five narrated tours with them.
You can step up to home plate at
Camden Yards or city fields and
learn about the stat cast and
learn about the career of a
baseball beat reporter.  All of
the new Expeditions will also be
available to schools through
the live guided mode.  we had
several teachers that already
created lessons to correspond
with these specific Expeditions
which makes it easy to
incorporate and those are also
on tez.  So solo mode will work
on cardboard, Android and iOS
and we're really excited that
Expeditions will come soon to
Daydream devices so you can
explore on your own or with a
live
guide.  We're doing demos in the
Daydream tent next-door.  Check
it out in the Sandbox.  VR is
amazing at making you feel like
you are somewhere else,
transported to a new place.  We
heard from many students and
teachers they want to interact
more with things or objects you
might find in the places.  one
of the first things that struck
us when watching Expeditions VR
in
the classroom.  Things in VR
scenes had a physical placement.
Like a student that would see
an Expeditions about a shark,
they would point to the place in
the scene where they saw the
shark.  It was fixed in their
spatial memory, not like a
textbook on the desk.  There may
well be something else going on
here.  There is an idea popular
in popular science, embodied
cognition.  bodies play a bigger
role in how we think, learn,
remember than we generally
thought in the past.  So the
theory is that when we move
around, look around, see things
presented in AR or VR, that can
tap into powerful capabilities
of our bodies, plus our minds.
So Tango is the technology that
allows us to do that with AR.
combined the live, social sort
of teacher curated capables of
Google Expeditions with the
power of Tango to augment the
environment with virtual objects
and animations.  Tango uses
sophisticated computer vision
and simple sensors like the
smartphones you have in your
pocket now to sense the depth
and dimensions of the
environment that you hold that
phone up to.  So like what does
this mean in practice in terms
of how a teacher would do it?
It makes it possible for the
teacher to place objects in the
classroom and tag them as if
they're there for real. These
are persistent, and allow
students and teachers to share a
common view of that.  one of
the key things that makes Tango
a unique and powerful thing in
the classroom.  AR is not new.
are lots of learning
applications that use device
cameras, pass through to show
digital objects.  The cameras.
the world as a flat 2D
environment and can't create the
shared social experience where
a classroom can stand in front
of an object and talk about it
like it was in front of the
room.  We have given teachers
similar controls to what we have
in the Expeditions VR to point
things out, change the object
and control the pace of the
class. It has been really fun to
grant teachers this new super
power to magically go deeper
into any subject in the
classroom.  Instead of, or more
important in addition to the
traditional content used in
schools.  AR can place
inaccessible things in front of
the student.  We have seen it
encourage more curiosity,
engender more questions,
conversation among teachers and
students.  We think it can serve
as a powerful complement to VR
experience as well.  VR takes
you anywhere in the world and AR
brings anything in the world to
you.  Let's take a look at how
AR is being used in the
classroom.  Let's watch this
video.  Same one we saw at the
keynote, but we love  Who wants
to see a volcano?
Look at the lava, the smoke
coming out of that.  Pretend
your an airplane and fly  That
is theAsteroids, meteoroids.
about D.N.A., genes, things we
can't see.   exciting thing for
me with the AR technology is I
could see kids get an ah-hah
moment that I couldn't get by
just telling them about it.
minute I saw it pop up on the
screen, it made me want to get
up and walk to  You can turn
around, look at things from all
angles.  It give us a nice
perspective.  you can figure out
what that might  I saw where
the alveoli branched off, I
being look inside them and see
how everything worked, which I
never saw before.  It was
really, really cool.
JENNIFER HOLLAND: So that
video is actually from a couple
of our pilot schools that have
been using AR in their classroom
and we've been piloting with a
number of schools all over the
world.   has been incredibly
positive.  We have learned a
great deal and really seen some
amazing, creative ways that
teachers have incorporated AR
into the classroom.  Similarly,
how we saw Expeditions VR
incorporated into the classroom.
And so, here's just one
example from our pilot, which I
just love.  How many of you
remember taking a math field
trip?  Oh, we have one -- two,
you took -- most of us don't get
to go to field trips in math
class, right?  about math in the
context of the actual real
world is really powerful.  what
we saw with a middle school
class in New York who used
Expeditions AR and the teacher,
we worked with the teacher to
create this mini golf lesson to
calculate ow golf -- how golf
balls form different angles as
they hit the obstacle.  the room
was this amazing mini golf
course throughout the classroom.
The students could see the
different holes and angles how
it changed when the bill hit
different obstacles.  Like we
did with Expeditions VR, we will
bring Expeditions AR to the
schools this fall through the
pioneer program.  We want
teachers to have the ability to
see how the technology can be
interactive, engaging, fun with
their students.  So if any
teachers are interested, they
can sign up on our forum, and
we'll be in touch with more
information soon.  And you can
also checkout the demos in our
Sandbox as well.  if you are a
developer who is really excited
about AR and wants to work with
us to build AR lessons, please
express interest on our partner
page.  have worked with so many
different partners to build
Expeditions VR and we want to do
the same with Expeditions AR.
So definitely sign up.  I would
like to turn things over to
Brandon who will talk to you
about building your own VR and
AR experiences.   BRANDON WUEST:
Thanks, Jen.  Ben and Jen
highlighted we have seen huge
success with Expeditions as an
educational product through the
use of VR to enable immersive
learning.  the early efforts to
bring AR to the classroom have
shown a lot of pro  promise.  It
is not enough to build these
alone at Google.  need
developers to focus on education
as well to grow the ecosystem.
Why do I want the ecosystem to
grow?  It is the right thing to
do for kids.  As a father of
three young children, I want to
see education transform, become
richer, more engaging for future
generations.  I notice with my
own children, I notice they can
learn better if they interact
with something, whether it is my
son building a lap
leprechaun trap or my youngest
playing with a sock.  Maybe not
so much with the sock.  But it
is a note.  The AR and VR
experience aren't just relevant
inside the classroom. is an
enormous potential per the use
in professional education as
well.  This
story is a good example.  A
utility company is using an
immerseve group experience for
exposure of what it might be
like to work in a local sewer
system.  this, I am glad that we
have not cracked virtual
smells,  So what I want to do
now is give you a quick overview
of the tools available to allow
you to build your own AR and VR
experiences.  First off, I want
to talk about Expeditions and
the two fundamental features.
First Expeditions is immersive.
We use
360 imagery to surround the
students.  It provides a
co-located guided experience
that allows teachers to control
and augment the experiences they
deem appropriate.  So first,
let's talk about the easiest way
to get 360 imagery into your
own application that is
available in cardboard, Daydream
or outside of a VR viewer.
First start with a Rico theta
camera or a cardboard camera to
capture imagery.  Once you have
the 360 content available, one
of the easiest ways to make this
viewable in the application is
to use something called VR view.
VR view is a drop-in component
for video.  This is available
on Android and also available on
iOS and the web as well.
Step one is build the
dependency to the Gradle file.
you are using Gradle.  Next
step, add the Panorama view to
the layout.  Finally, you take
the Panorama view and use that
to load and display your image.
Almost like magic, it is now
viewable in your application.
Is not only viewable in the
application in VR, but you can
view is in magic window move.
You can view it outside of the
viewer and move your phone
around.  going through this
quickly, but I want to give
everyone a quick overview of the
Next step.  Now how can you
enable a colocated guided
experience?  This is
straightforward with the nearby
API.  Let me walk you through
how to do it on Android.  It is
available on iOS as well.  First
up, for adding the nearby API
as with VR view is you add the
dependency to your Gradle build
file.  Then what you want to do
is create a message listener.
The
message
listener you use to receive and
create the process.  You have
the listener, once you have the
listener and you subscribe that
against the nearby API.  Pretty
simple.  you have the
application that can listen to,
receive, process messages, then
you can have your application
publish these messages out to
clients. again, I went over this
pretty quickly.  If you want to
learn more about VR view or
nearby API, here are a couple
resources to checkout.  360
photos are great. simple, easy
to add to your app but limiting
because they restrict you to a
certain kind of content.  As you
start to prepare experiences,
say for upcoming stand alone
headset we announced yesterday,
you want something near flexible
and powerful.  is the options
for more advanced experiences
without getting your hands dirty
with open GL or similar?  Enter
web VR.  Google has been a
strong force behind the web VR
standard and today it is
supported in Chrome for Android,
Firefox, oculus, Samsung
browsers.  That is great, what
about building your own
experiences that use web
technologies?   want to talk
about A frame.  This is a
framework -- isn't a Google
product.  I want to talk about
it because it is one of the
easiest ways I have found to
build VR experiences that target
the web.  For instance, look at
the 360 photo I showed you
earlier in the VR view example.
Say we wanted to add a 2D image
over the top.  This is
nontrivial with VR view.  can
see here in the sample.  This is
a complete sample on how to do
this, it is easy to add our 360
photo, and our 2D image overlay
and a very concise amount of
HTML.  should look very
syntactically familiar for those
of you with web development
experience.  This is the example
running in Chrome for Android.
Now I will try to talk about a
slightly more complex example.
Now, when I was in school, I
struggled a lot with the concept
of imaginary numbers.  I mean,
for one, the name is ridiculous.
They're imaginary numbers, not
even real.  But besides the
fact of I think the name choice
of imaginary numbers being poor,
I remember the concept to be
intimidating because it wasn't
grounded in anything tangible.
illustrate what I mean.  look at
the parrab  --  The
theorem
says there should be a value
for X that causes the parabola
to cross the X axis, but it
requires us to use imagery
numbers.  -- imaginary numbers.
One reason this seems so
inaccessible, because educators
have been largely limited to
conveying this on something like
a piece of paper.  As we
represent positive numbers on
the number line in one direction
and negative numbers in the
other direction, we can actually
think of imaginary numbers as
just another dimension.  When we
represent our parabola in 3D
space, the applied use of
imaginary numbers is more
obvious.  You can see it
intersect.  It is obvious.  It
is probably not obvious to you.
If you are feeling completely
lost.  Great, that's my point.
I'm trying to explain this using
traditional 2D presentation
tools.  Now, imagine if you
could enable students to explore
concepts like imaginary numbers
in VR.  What is amazing here is
someone has already built a
graphing calculator application
called math world VR using A
frame.  only is this tool
available today, but it is
completely open source.  If you
want to look at a more advanced
example of using A frame or
targets web VR, this is a great
place to start.  If you want to
learn more about A frame or math
world VR, checkout these links.
Okay.  Everything I have shown
you up to this point has only
enabled VR.  I haven't talked
about AR at all.  is pushing AR
standard. of the best tools for
the experiences, such as
Expeditions AR app you can see
in the Sandbox next-door is this
system called
Unity.  could be a chance you
haven't heard of it at all.
okay.  Unity is popular for
building 3D mobile games.  The
same features that enabled
developers to create amazing
games applies well to AR and VR.
We use this because it
provides really robust support
for importing and manipulating
through the objects.  A multi
player API through peer-to-peer
connections, with the co-located
student teacher class room.
Where an Internet connection may
be unavailable. provides simple
integration with Tango.  Tango
is at the core of the tracking
capabilities.  To provide more
depth, and if you pay attention,
that is a pun, though a bad
one, let's talk about the three
key features of Tango.  First,
Tango provides the 3D space.  We
know where our device is
looking and located.  This
allows students to walk around
the room and see objects from
different perspectives and
distances.  also provides
surface detection
detection.  So we know a floor
is a floor and a desk is a desk.
This allows us to place
objects relative to our physical
space.  Our physical space and
allow teachers to place objects
on tables as they would
traditional classroom materials.
Finally, Tango does all of
this while giving us a global
understanding of our position in
space.  So when we leave the
classroom and come back, the
objects remain.  If you want to
learn more about Unity for
Daydream or cardboard or more.
Checkout this presentation.  I
realize I went over this fast.
it give a broad understanding of
some of the tools available to
experience the VR and AR
applications.  me hand it back
to  Thank you, Brandon.  Why do
we feel like this is an urgent
thing?  It is perfectly
incorporated from a hero.
Seymour pappert.  We should try
to learn more like children.
That is the point here.  Pappert
was an influence.  He was the
first to see computers not as
things that have generally
characterized people's
understanding, but good
information storers for the
repetitive task.  Like the
logical extension of
encyclopedia, he saw them as
this thing to be harnessed by
people that create things,
learning, doing, making new
things, actively try fail, and
try again.  The great irony.
pappert compelled us to support
human learning with technology.
We have made more progress
teaching computers how to learn
than people.  I will give an
example.  remember Deep Blue?
remember Joel Benjamin? was the
chest grand master that the deep
blue team worked with at IBM to
get his game strategies.  They
extracted as many if-then
statements to create what Joel
Benjamin would do, but faster.
It was an amazing achievement.
Just 22 years later, there was
Alpha Go, the computer that
defeated one of the world's
great Go players.  This wasn't
about integrating the computer
with the strategies.  It was
programming a program how to
learn what a good strategy would
be.  You have an ignorant crowd
of really good learners who
play go all the time.  To put
that in context. difference
between the number of moves in
chess and go is the difference
between the number of atoms in
your body and the number of
atoms in the universe.  That is
in like 20 years.  So what
happened?  For such dramatic
progress in such short time.
How is that milestone of
artificial intelligence achieved
just 20 years ago cute in
comparison to what we can do
today?  It turns out programming
a computer to be smart is
actually programming it to learn
to be smart.  Put another way.
Artificial intelligence grew
into machine learning.  Instead
of jamming computers full of
if-then statements, we give it
progress, and try and fail.
gave them the same gift of
learning that we are born with
as children.  Like the same gift
that leads Brandon's kid to eat
his sock.  So much of that old
notion artificial intelligence.
Think about the facts you were
asked to memorize.  The
standardized bubble tests you
took.  All the times the
solution was presented to you as
choosing the right if-then
statement.  if it took giving
computers the technology to
experiencely learn at scale and
make them capable of tackling
problems like Go, it should make
us realize the technology to
give humans to learn is to help
them learn by experiencing,
giving them agency, not just by
giving a bunch of  That is
exactly why the emergence of
widely able, immersive
computering like AR and VR is an
exciting opportunity.  It can
enable the right learning
moments at scale.  Provide
people trying to learn something
with experiences, with
curiosity, with wonder, trial
and error that can be arrived at
quickly and safely.  They can
inspire kids.  That's a much
more powerful force than any
educational technology we could
actually create.  So if we --
that includes all of you -- if
we get this right, we have the
chance to give the same gift we
spent the last 20 years giving
to rack-mounted servers to our
own  that's why we're really
excited to see what we all
thanks very much!
Thank you for joining this
session.  Brand ambassadors will
assist with directing you
through the designated exits.
be making room for those who
registered for the next session.
If you have registered for the
next session in this room, we
ask that you please clear the
room and return via the
registration line outside. you.
of
session)
Welcome.  Thank you for
joining.  Our session will begin
soon.
Welcome.  Thank you for
joining.  Our session will
begin soon.
Good morning, everyone.  How
are -- Good morning, everyone.
How are you feeling?  This
sweatshirt is made out of 20
Daydream views.  No, it is not,
let's get started.  Mohs is
breeze breeze.  I'm a project
major to the Daydream  -- my
name is
BRAHIM.  We think it is
important that as the market is
starting we share as much as we
can with the broader community.
The second call is to walk you
through how we're talking the
insights and applying it to the
data platform itself to make it
better for developers and users.
Let's get started.  are
updates, recaps you have
probably heard  First, we have
eight Daydream-ready phones.  If
you recall, last year, November
we launched with support pixel
and pixel XL.  The goal has to
bring high quality mobile to
everyone.  We have been hard at
work to bring in more devices
that support Daydream. Samsung
S8 will be Daydream in the
coming week.   flagship device
available later this summer will
also be Daydream ready.  And
finally, our existing partners
Asus and Motorola will bring
more Daydream-ready devices to m
arket.  Putting it together, as
Mike summarized in the morning,
we'll have tens of millions of
Daydream-ready devices on the
market.  Those paired with the
headset will allow you to
experience Daydream.  That is a
great user base for you to
target with content.  The other
big news, the
I/O headset.  Darren will tell
you more about the headset s and
how they work.  highlight
, the satellite headphones are
the same as the smartphone.
high quality mobile VR to
everyone.  If you don't own an
Android device, this may be an
option.  Another option is a
different user journey, you have
a shared device at home, that
is connected to power and Wi-Fi
and you can jump into VR at any
time.  Darren will get into more
details, but we're excited
about this development,
obviously. Finally, user
purchase the headsets to develop
content that users create.
excited since January we're more
than triple the number of apps
available on Daydream to 150.
It is exciting.  We expect to
see an increase in momentum over
the coming months as we roll
out more of the experiences
being developed at the moment.
So that is great news.  All
right.  So we'll share
five insights.  These are data
driven insights we hope you will
find useful as you create our
content.  First, Daydream home
in its current form.  will get
you on stage and tell you about
how it will change in the
future.  The three panels on the
top.  We call them discovery
windows.  are deep links to
videos, to apps, specific
experiences in an app.  We use
them to feature content for
users.  So keep that in mind as
I share the data
First, 25% of sessions on
Daydream begin with no specific
intent.  If you think about
that, if you think about your
smartphone, how often do you
turn on your smartphone with
absolutely no intent?  to check
time, not to check e-mail, not
to play a game, not to do other
things.  smartphones it is
task-centric, a specific thing
you are doing with the phone and
you will go there to do that.
This is quite different.  Lots
of users are coming with no
intent.  next data point is 40%
of all sessions include at least
one click on a discovery
window.  Which benchmarking
against traditional
merchandising experience is
quite good.  Finally, 35% of all
sessions include a visit to
play store VR.  So if you put
these three data points
together, our take away is that
on VR, in VR, users are in
discovery mode.  They're
open-minded.  They're coming and
saying what's awesome in VR?
What can I do today?  can I
experience today in Daydream?
And that's great news because it
creates an opportunity for
developers to fill that need.
To create great content people
love, use and purchase, which is
obviously essential.  You know,
I was on Android market in
2011, and at the time, high
qualitiance -- quality apps got
a lot of use and attention.  We
see the similar point in VR.
The insight we are trying to
share today as a developer, this
may be the time to get
involved, start experimenting,
start iterating so they can
build the Angry Birds of VR.
Angry Birds is standing in for
the breakout hit.  You remember
when Angry Birds in 2009 came
out.  It was one of the titles
where everything came together
perfectly.  The game mechanic
used the screen in a unique way.
The characters were great, the
branding.  The monetization
worked.  worked well.  It wasn't
an overnight  took a lot of
iteration and work to get there.
So we firmly believe that
developers on Daydream today are
converging on the breakout hit.
Learning, iterating, and
getting closer to creating this
breakout hit.  So if you have
been as a developer, think about
VR, considering whether to get
involved or not, I urge you to
look closer and consider
actually doing that.  So next I
will show you a video from a
title that just became available
on Daydream called Lola and the
giant, built by climax studios.
The environment is immersive,
it is great.  There are two
characters.  It is the giant,
you can take the perspective of
the giant in the game.  You can
have different skill sets,
literally like a giant.  Or be a
third-person follower along
with Lola as she conquers
challenges and does all sorts of
fun stuff.  Interesting, also,
a companion experience where
outside of VR -- there you go,
the video is playing.  outside
of VR, a user can also interact
in the game. can have an
asymmetric game experience.  One
person is in 2D and another in
VR and they can collaborate
together. think that is fun.  We
think the title that is getting
at the breakout hit.   this
title is getting at trying
different things, innovating in
the space, and getting at
something awesome.  haven't
tried it, it just came out.
Super awesome, please  Now,
let's talk about monetization.
That is a big part of this.  A
big part of making you --
helping you earn a living on
Daydream.  So a couple of data
points to share with you is that
on Daydream, we have seen three
times as many buyers as you
would on traditional mobile on
Google Play.  And those buyers
are spending 32% more than they
would on traditional mobile.  is
good news, right?  creating VR
content is expensive, it is
hard, it takes a lot of time.
The fact that users are
responding well, they're willing
to purchase the content and
actually spending more on it,
that is really good news for our
developer community and for our
platform.  However, we talk to
our users a lot.  We do a lot of
user studies.  We talk with
them a lot.  Almost every single
one we have heard feedback that
if we had a way -- if users had
a way to try an experience
before buying it, they would
help them make that purchase
decision more frequently.  And
so the insight here is actually
more of an ask, more of a
request.  If you have an
experience on Daydream today, if
it is premium, IE, like you
have to pay up-front, look at
ways, consider ways to introduce
a trial to it.  It is not easy.
There is no single way to do
this.  Right? depends by title,
it depends by user.  It depends
on the development and goals for
your title.  This is easy.
believe this isn't something
that will go away.   for trying
an experience is fundamental to
VR.  Because it is an immersive
technology.  I have to be in it
to know what it is about.  There
are physiological differences
that one title that is
comfortable for one user may not
be as comfortable for someone
else.  need makes sense.  We're
doing our best to figure this
out.  As soon as we do, we will
communicate our finders.
developers iterate and
experiment in this direction.
do you get users to experiment
and try your content first is
key to getting into the
successful monetization and
successful breakout  Now, let's
talk about usage patterns.  What
we have seen on Daydream is
users are spending average 40
minutes a week in VR.  What is
unique is that this is spent in
a couple of sessions only.  In
the evenings, at home, or on the
weekends.  If today you are a
developer of a 2D game or app,
it is quite different from what
you are seeing.  What you are
seeing today is a lot of
interactions, microsessions, 30
seconds a minute, couple
minutes.  People are coming
back, collecting energy, points
and going back out.   than VR.
So the way we have been
summarizing this now for a while
is that as you build content
for VR, think of a sit-down meal
experience.  Not a snack.  It
is not something people are
doing throughout the day.  It is
fewer, longer sessions.  Next I
want to show you a view from
the gorillas latest album.  This
was created in collaboration
with Google spotlight stories.
is awesome about this, you are
on a train track.  super fast.
You feel like you are there.
You can look around, different
characters.  The gorilla is
behind you.  You are listening
to the music.  There is a tablet
showing you what would look
like a traditional music video.
What is awesome about this
medium of VR video is that not
only are you listening to the
artist's creation as a song, you
are also experiencing the
environment they wanted you to
be in when you listened to it.
just works really well.  If you
haven't tried this, this
actually got three million views
in 48 hours, making it the b
iggest debut of a VR video on
YouTube ever.  It was
super-awesome.  Give it a try,
if you haven't  So the take away
here and the fact, actually is
that nearly 50% of all time in
Daydream is spent in video
experiences.  This is split
across flat content.  This is
traditional 2D content as
projected in a personal cinema,
we like to call it, from
Netflix, hulu, play HBO.  the
immersy
-- immersive VR and others that
create truly awesome videos.  A
lot of documentaries that
allows you to be immersed in the
story and feel, probably to be
honest, as much about how that
person in the documentary is
feeling more than ever before in
The insight here is video is a
core use case of mobile VR.  It
is a core use case.  And so as
a developer, as a creator, think
about ways to use it to augment
your experience.  To create an
experience that is great.  For
example, as we talk about
trials, maybe VR video is a way
to offer that trial.  And
finally, I want to share another
data point with you about
quality.  This chart shows a
correlation between time in an
app and the app's rating.  Of
course, it is a positive
correlation.  The significance
is actually quite high.  But
what's important here is that we
purposely chose time in app,
not installs, which is how you
traditionally look at app
ratings.  You say if I have a
high rating, I get more
installs.  Here, we wanted to
show engagement, and use and
impact of having a great quality
app.  Keep in mind, Daydream
has a fairly stringent quality
review process.  So the apps
aren't like crashing or have low
frames per second or other
things.  The difference here is
almost from good to great, not
so much very por por -- poor.
you build content for VR, think
about quality, but not only in
terms of technical quality.
Also in the depth of the
experience.  Just how awesome it
is.  So to summarize, now is
the time for you as a developer
to jump in and potentially
create VR's Angry Birds.  It
will take time and those
developers creating today are
iterating an and approaching
that milestone.   fundamental
parts of VR content creation.
And they will help unlock the
full potential of monetization,
you need to think about those
from day one.  In terms of
content duration and length,
think about a sit-down
experience.   how you can use
video to augment your
experience, and finally, quality
in VR goes beyond the technical
aspects, and into depth of the
content, and how immersive the
experience is.  all.  I will
turn it over to Darren now who
will show you how we're taking
these insights and more and
improving the datum experience
for you and our users.  Thanks,
Brahim.
I am Darren Delaye and I lead
the experience team for the
Daydream plat  form.  platform.
I will tell you about what we
have seen, in the experience and
improvements we're making for
Daydream platform 2.0
Euphrates, releasing later this
year.  We have world sense
contracting a new factor for VR.
I will break this down into
pieces.  First, let's talk about
what it means to have a stand
alone headset. stand alone
headset purpose built for VR
brings a new level of
convenience to how you access
VR.  When it is on your counter
or coffee table and you can pick
it up and in just a few seconds
be in VR, I think you will find
that you and the other members
of your household will end up
going into VR a lot more often.
the friction to go into VR
makes a big
difference.  From a developer
perspective, you use the same
exact developer tools and SDKs
as in smartphone VR.  You will
use the same as smartphone VR
and headsets.  This is
compatible with the headsets.
interacting, you will use the
Daydream motion controller to
point, swing, play.  Now, since
there isn't a phone mode, set
up and settings are all done
from inside the headset.  These
will be some of the very first
VR systems where there isn't a
phone or a PC as the primary
setup device.  What I want to
mention here is the same goes
for app developers.  There are
great examples of what we call
hybrid 2D and 3D apps for
Daydream.  For example, the app
named "within" has a great phone
mode to look at a preview of
the videos released.  If you
want to check one out, click on
it, and hop into VR.  Since the
stand alone headset users only
have VR, you need important
features like account sign in or
settings are accessible from
the game engine VR All right.
Let's talk about world sense
positional tracking.  We have
full six degrees of senses
tracking, fixed off tracking.
Works with no external wires,
sensors or setup.  It just
works.  It is based on
technology from the Tango team
that tracks objects in real-time
as they move about in 3D space.
In stead of being able to know
the orientation of the headset,
where you are looking.  Now we
can track the movement of your
head as well in any direction.
the world sense headsets are
optimized for seated and
standing virtual reality.  It
allows you to naturally move,
lean, shift your weight and body
position however you want.
Positional tracking creates a
much more immersive VR
experience.  Everything feels
more real.  In turn, that makes
the experience more comfortable.
The realism comes in large
part, from your natural
perception of all the tiny
movements your head is making
all the time, that create
parallel acts between foreground
and background elements.  The
same thing happens in the real
world when you perceive the
world all day every
day.  Here's a quick example of
the dodgeball demo.  I can duck
and dodge.  I lean out of the
way every time I watch this
video.  Ha-ha, sorry.  you want
to create a world that has
ducking and dodging you can use
the world sense headsets.  want
people to be safe in their
space.  Most people don't have a
lot of space.  If you clear an
area in the room, we want people
to avoid bumping into furniture
and walls.  We have a system
that encourages people to say in
roughly one spot and not walk
around or wander too far from
where they set as the center of
their experience.  This is
mobile VR.  You can start your
experience anywhere in the room.
Really, anywhere.  And we have
a sensor that actually detects
when you put the headset on,
where you are, which lets us set
that as the default VR starting
position with the VR world
centered around you.   I will
give you a couple of quick
things to think about if you are
creating apps and games for the
Daydream world sense headsets.
Here's one thing that works
really well.  The scenes with
relatively small items that are
pretty close-up.  When you move
back and forth, from side to
side.  you don't want anything
closer than about half a meter
from your face for too long.  If
you think about something like
a board game on the table or a
game where you feel really big
because all the characters are
really small.  Those will feel
good when you shift your weight
and get a large amount of
parallax from small movements.
You need about one character to
see the character behind.  From
this game, the user is peeking
from side to side to plan out
how to solve the puzzle.  But
here's an example where you may
have to design around the
parallax.  In this pointer-based
interface, something we use
frequently in Daydream.  When a
user hovers the cursor over the
item, we bring it towards them a
bit.  this, you highlight the
item in the upper left.  what it
might look like if this UI is
close-up to the user and moved
or leaned over to the right.  It
is not pointing at them any
more.   at aicide angle.  -- a
side angle.  You might want to
turn it.  One thing to mention,
is you can make everything look
roughly the same and move the UI
farther back from the user.
scale up the cards and text to
compensate to make it still
legible.  If you move the UI
farther away, when the user
makes the same amount of
movement to the right, they will
see a smaller amount of
parallax and it will look
similar to how it does from
straight on.  So if you want to
learn more about how my team
specifies designs like this, how
we create legible and useable
UIs we have a great talk
tomorrow about screen developing
VR that you should  If you want
your users to move over greater
distances in VR, our favorite
method is to have people
teleport from spot to spot.
This is a pattern a lot of apps
have adopted already.  We found
this most effective in all types
of VR, from smartphone to
positionally tracked systems.
We notice once you give people
the ability to teleport, they
stop their urge to walk around
and just teleport all around.
They start intuitively using it
and end up staying safer and not
need as big of a physical
space.  We're big fans of
teleporting around in VR.
releasing a new set of sample
code as something we called
Daydream elements which has the
implementation of teleporting
you can use to get you started.
This recording is from the
Daydream element sample app.
Okay.  Now we're going to switch
over and talk about features in
the Daydream
2.0 Euphrates release coming
out later this year.  This is
coming to smartphone and stand
alone VR.  Here's a preview of
the updated Daydream home.  We
had user tell us the Daydream
home is simple, approachable and
we plan to keep it that way.
We'll swipe through these.
Okay.  The changes we made are
mostly related to the discovery
windows that you see in the
middle.  Now, there are more of
them and they're organized into
collections.  are for new users
with the all-time best content,
nobody should miss.  Other
collections are for people
watching the space frequently,
newly released content and new
releases.  And other collections
are on a trend or theme that
people are gravitating to when
they come to Daydream.  All of
these discovery windows feature
all kinds of content, apps,
games, individual experiences,
videos.  They're actually under
the hood of Android intense that
we deep link to.  you are
creating an app with individual
experiences, be sure to plan for
the incoming links.  Our goal
with Daydream home is that
people will come to VR
frequently and never run out of
things to
experience.   next feature is
what we call the system
dashboard.  motivation for this
is that sometimes you are in the
middle of a VR experience and
you wonder if there is something
that needs your attention or
you just need to check the time.
We want to enable things
without a jarring interruption
to your experience.  When the
user presses the system button,
the system dashboard will pop
up.  they press the system
button again, it will disappear
and return them back to what
they are doing.  Users can check
on status like time, battery
life, activate system features
like do not disturb mode or
casting, which I will talk about
more in a moment or quickly
launch the next app they want to
open.  They can check
notifications which can give
them peace of mind about whether
they have more time to stay in
VR.  Okay.  In Daydream 1.0,
there were a couple of scenarios
when you may have had to take
your phone out of the headset
and complete a task in phone
mode before you could continue.
That would be like if you two
in this example needed to have
access to the microphone and
needed to ask permission, so you
could do a voice search or
update the credit card
expiration date to make a
purchase of the game.  We're
incorporating these into VR to
do the required tasks and get
back to what we had to do.  We
had to do it for the stand alone
headsets and a nice improvement
for mobile VR as well.
Stepping back, one of the most
important things is making sure
VR fits into your life, not just
something you do by yourself.
My favorite feature we're giving
today is casting.  I'm sure
many of you have given demos to
your friends and great to see
reacts to new VR experiences.
great if they get stuck or ask
you to click on but you can't
see what's happening or
sometimes there is one person in
VR and other people just
waiting their turn.  So with
casting, we can bridge the gap.
You can share the experience
with the whole group.  Here's
our animation of how it works.
the system dashboard, choose the
cast receiver, it starts
playing on your TV right away.
And they work --  work across
apps.   a session and pass the
headset to multiple people,
checkout multiple apps with the
cast running the whole time.  We
think this will make mobile VR
that much more fun in the living
Okay.  For developers, if you
want to get a little fancy,
there are interesting game plan
mechanics you can consider
implementing using casting.  In
this example, prototypers from
our Daydream labs team have
created essentially acting out a
puppet show where the person in
the headset is giving a tour of
the spaceship.  The people
watching on the TV have a fixed
camera position.  You have to
have enough performance overhead
available for the app to render
the extra camera.  It is
challenging.  There are
interesting things.  You can
play a guessing game, a party
game, there is something the
person in the headset is
supposed to know, but not the
room.  Or opposite, the people
in the room should see it, but
the people in the headset
shouldn't. Okay.  For times
where you are not in the same
room with your friends, we are
announcing support for VR
captures, screen shots and video
recordings, that will sync to
your device and you can share
however you want.   our
smartphone cameras every day,
this is the way to record the
best things you encounter in VR
as  So find at more at
developers.Google.com/VR which
we added a favorite new tool
which is instant preview, which
mates iterating -- makes
iterating in
Unity unreal.  are the upcoming
Daydream talks I encourage you
to attend.  Three more today and
one more from our design team.
So thank you very much.   Thank
you for joining this session.
Brand ambassadors will assist
with directing you through the
designated
of session)
Welcome.  Please fill in the
seats near the front of the
enterprise IoT using Android
Things and Google Cloud
Platform.
Hello, everyone.  Good
afternoon.  Hope you are all
enjoying the second day of I/O.
I'm Hanwook Kim.
I'm I am here on the Google
Cloud Platform and we have
Hanwook Kim here also.  One of
the key products that Google
offers, particularly with
enterprise, we will talk about
the key challenges in building
our I/O solution and how Google
things about addressing those
and finally, we'll have demos
for you.  get started.  Now, I
think parking is a problem that
is near and dear to everyone's
heart.  All of us.  estimated
that there are around
800 million parking Spaces in
the United States.  San
Francisco city alone has half a
million parking Spaces, but it
is still really hard to find
parking.
SF city has taken an initiative
to put a sensor in a parking
spot to check if it is open or
not in a spot.  You can check on
the Cloud to see which parking
lots are open.  You don't have
to look around for parking, you
can find it automatically on the
mobile phone and park  Imagine
if all the parking Spaces in the
U.S. are connected by a sensor.
Each sensor is sending data on
a periodic basis, but
cumulative, that is a massive
influx of data.  How do you
build applications which really
scales with all that data?  We
also have interesting partners
who build interesting
application for utilities.  We
have a number of smart meters in
the U.S. Europe.  And the
number of customers have
connected the smart data from
consumer homes and with Google
Cloud Platform and other
applications, they can provide a
real-time view of the energy
usage in different regions for
consumers.  I imagine, if all
the houses -- smart meters in
all the houses are connected,
imagine the influx of data.  of
smart meters, millions of smart
meters, sending data every hour
or 15 minutes, that is a massive
amount of data.  What about
security and how do you get
real-time insights.  That is
real questions that every
building has in operations.
There are views, we connected
from edge vac, chillers, data
centers and used that to improve
our power utilization by over
15%.  if every building,
commercial and residential
building use the same concept to
actively optimize energy
consumption.  Key use cases a
laid out in front of you.  I
think you know phones are bigger
in terms of growth, bigger than
PC, I significant growth is
expected for IoT in the coming
years.  Depending on the analyst
report you read, it is
estimated 20 to 50 billion
devices will be connected by
2020.  While each of the devices
might be sending a small amount
of bytes -- small amount of
data every couple of seconds or
minutes, cumulative, it is a
massive influx of data.  That
creates 3 challenges as we think
of and what we hear from
partners and developers.  One is
security.  How do you ensure
that all the devices are secure?
How do you ensure that all the
devices have the latest
operating system and the right
security patches?  do you ensure
that the data which you are
importing into Cloud is
protected and secured as well?
Second is scale, when you have
billions  -- millions or
billions of devices connected
how do you handle all that data
in a cost effective way and make
sure you can manage the massive
amount of devices which are
globally dispersed in a way that
you know all the devices have
the right security patches as
well.  Finally, what do you do
with all this
data?  Each of the devices may
have the -- sending massive
amount of data.  How do you
cost-effectively store the data,
analyze the data to get action
inside.  And do it not just on
the Cloud but also on the  I
will start with how we think
about these challenges on the
Cloud side.  As you know, Google
has seven products which are
serving more
than a billion users currently.
And all these users are highly
engaged.   a massive amount of
data back and forth between
these products and as well as
the Cloud infrastructure.  So as
part of our mission at Google
to organize information and make
it accessible.  We're working
with data ingestion, storage
getting inside as massive scale
over a decade.  fact, we believe
in the process of serving this
billion users, billion-plus
users for the consumer products,
we have built the world's best
computer infrastructure, across
hardware, software, networking
operations as well.  We build
our infrastructure for
developers in a way where
developers think of these as not
as data centers but as one
computers.  All of the data
centers are connected via our
global network.  In fact, only
our non-ISP company who has
under-ocean fiber connection
between data centers.  As a
developer, as you access the
data -- it is not a collection,
it is just one computer, you
just write an application and
Cloud takes care of running them
at scale. In addition to our
data center infrastructure, we
have also been working hard in
building up our data management
and analytics stack as well.
You know, we build an open
source map reduce, developel,
-- DREMel, and big table.  We
have started to externalize this
as serves on the
Google Cloud Platform for
customers, developers and
partners.  For example, think
about BigQuery, that is the
analyzing Cloud service.  If you
run on BigQuery Cloud platform,
your query is running on DREMel
that we use for all
applications.  When you put data
on that table, you are using
that which is powering surge,
ads, Gmail and
Google Maps.  There are many,
and some you are aware  When it
comes to IoT, we believe we have
the industry leading dat and
analytics on Cloud developing
platform.   are using to build
applications.  And one thing
they've asked us many times,
this is great that you have all
the services like Pub/Sub,
BigQuery, data table, but how do
I connect and manage my devices
so I can start leveraging the
Cloud services that you have.
this week, we announced Cloud
IoT Core, with a goal to make it
easy for developers to build
enterprise IoT applications.
What is Cloud IoT Core?  is a
fully managed service.  100%
managed, running on Google Cloud
Platform.  Let's talk about
security.  As part of Cloud IoT
Core we're built from ground up
N
TTPP so you can bring an
existing or new device to
establish a secure connection
with Cloud IoT Core over TLS and
send and receive telemetry over
NTTP protocol.  of our
customers have devices that
support standard NTTP protocol.
We have built a bridge so you
can connect your existing device
to Cloud and start leveraging
data analytics services.  As
part of Cloud IoT Core, if you
are connecting one device or
millions of devices, it scales
internally. don't have to worry
about provisions in node.  You
don't have to worry about
redundancy or shorting.  We
scale internally.  That makes
it, for a developer, to build an
application about worries about
how do you scale from 10
devices to millions of devices
as you graduate from prototype
to full-scale deployment.  And
also the Cloud -- the foundation
of data routing.  to Cloud
Pub/Sub, you can access the data
from the diverse connection of
devices, from a single center
point so you can view -- you can
have a global view of all your
data points across the different
devices.  We have also added
some key functionality for
device management.  With Cloud
IoT Core you can individually
configure and manage devices.
will go more into the details.
You can also now update your --
update and control the remote
devices using Cloud IoT Core.
We have built a set of API which
you can use on your
applications and we also have a
console so you can try to use
that to run and manage your
device as well.  In addition
with Cloud IoT Core, you can
provide granule level access to
a group of devices and using
Cloud IM.  We're exciting with
this.  We think it will help
developers, you guys, to start
building using your existing
device or new devices running
things to connect to Cloud and
start using data analytics.   we
understand developers and
partners, as you think about
building enterprise IoT
applications you want to build
prototypes to get your feet wet
to see if there is a UI before
you start developing.  part of
the Cloud IoT Core offering, we
have a UI, which will be
available on Cloud console.
Before I get into the UI, let me
tell you about some of the key
concepts for Cloud IoT Core.
Especially as it pertains to
device management and
monitoring.  We have a notion of
device registry.  So if you are
a device manufacturer and have
10 categories of products, you
can create 10 registry and you
can register all the devices for
each of the categories under
the registry.  You can also
assign IM policies and rules to
control access to users on those
specific registries.  So if I
am a device manufacturer and I
want to make sure my customer --
my user and customer A can only
have view access, you can do
that with our registry.  And you
can register one device or
millions of devices in that
registry.  So as you can see on
the screen, when you go to Cloud
console, there is a section on
the menu, there is a section
called Cloud IoT Core.  You
click on that, you will see a
list of different device
registres which you already
created.  You can create a new
registry.  Give it a name,
assign a region and a Pub/Sub
topic to give the data to.  Once
you select a registry, there is
a list of devices which is
preregistered.  And you can see
whether it is enabled or
disabled.  With Cloud IoT Core
we allow you to disable a
device, if you think it has
become a rogue device or for
testing purposes you want to
turn off the devices and have
one device on to start testing
the connectivity to the device.
For the purpose of
sure as a developer, you can
individually authenticate a
device or group of devices.  has
support for public key based
authentication.  Public keys for
authentication.  The work it
works you can register your
device with the Cloud IoT Core.
It will create an adjacent web
token.  That is the I.D. given
to the device.  will make sure
that the device is a real,
registered
device.  As part of our launch,
we have also been working very
hard with a number of device p
artners.  So we are very excited
that with the launch of Cloud
IoT Core we have announced
partnership with a couple of key
leading device manufacturers,
such as Intel, microchip, NXP,
Sierra wireless, marvel and
others.  are working closely
with partners to make it easy
for developers to connect to
Cloud IoT Core right out of the
gate.  For example, you can --
is a really tiny
microcontroller,
ESP8226.  to our partner, you
can connect a tiny MCU like this
to Cloud IoT Core and start
using services on the Cloud.
excited about what we're
building and how we're working
with the partner ecosystem to
help developers building
application.  In addition to
hardware partners we're working
with application partners as
well.  We have announced
agreements with NUBO, helium, a
bunch of others which are coming
along. very excited with the
announcement of Cloud IoT Core
and how we're building partner
ecosystem so developers can
start building application using
Google Cloud Platform.  I want
to spend a couple of minutes on
some of the other services which
really adds value.  As we think
about the overall IoT platform,
some of the services which are
already existing today in Cloud
really helps you to build
company application.
Google Cloud Pub/Sub.  For the
Cloud IoT Core it sends the
devices registry is published to
the Cloud Pub/Sub topic.  What
you can do is collect data to
one topic and analyze it using
downstream services.  Pub/Sub
has durable message persistence.
What this means is you can
wait for seven days to send a
response back or you can even
send it within a minute.  It
also allows you to access data
globally as I mentioned.  What
is great with Pub/Sub is the
Cloud IoT Core integrates with
Pub/Sub, it separates the
application development from
your upstream device former
changes.  You can constantly
update your application, build
your applications without
needing to change your format.
also allows you to build and use
powerful services for building
applications such as Cloud
functions, data flow, or even
you can use your existing ETL
pipeline or third-party services
to consume the data from the
disclosed data devices and start
building interesting
applications.   you've ingested
the data in a secure way, using
Cloud IoT Core and once you
routed the data using Google
Cloud Pub/Sub, it gives a view
that you can use the Google
Cloud services for analysis,
storage and insights.  This is
where we want to have humans and
machines learn from the data.
You can use BigQuery, the data
warehousing analytics platform
to analyze hundreds of billions
of rows of data in a couple of
seconds and use that data to
train a machine-learning model.
You can use data lab to analyze
the data from BigQuery, connect
it to Cloud ML, train machine
learning models and use the
models to predict power failure,
demand usage or maintenance and
then send it to Cloud IoT Core
and then from there send it as
an alert or downstream, or
upstream to devices as well.  So
this is how we think about our
overall platform and how we
think about the Cloud portion as
well as its connection to
devices.  Here, you will see, we
have -- you can use an Android
Things device, which
Hanwook will go into more
detail.  You can connect to
Cloud IoT Core to send telemetry
data.  All of that data is
loaded on to Pub/Sub from there,
you can route it to a Cloud
function to build a simple rule
and act on  complex event
processing using data flow.  can
use BigQuery or big data to
store cost-effectively, using it
for time analysis, feed it to
Cloud machine learning, Cloud
ML, the managed service for
TensorFlow for continuing
machine models or use the same
Cloud ML for prediction and send
the data back to Cloud IoT Core
for any actions you want to
take on the devices.  Then we're
very excited with the upcoming
launch announcement with Cloud
IoT Core, more will come.  We'll
get more details.  I want to
hand it to Hanwook who will
cover Android Things for
enterprise.     HANWOOK KIM:
Hello, everyone.  I will talk
about the other side of the IoT
solutions, devices.  Devices in
the field, also known as edge
Android devices.  you know what
you are looking for.  Maybe you
are looking for something with
high fidelity, more actress,
sampling rates maybe a new
sensor that came out that you
want to apply to your enterprise
solution.  Maybe a cheaper
option or maybe you have a
hypothesis to try and test
before you deploy and identify
new signals to try better
outcomes for the operations.
You need the devices to control
the operations.  Some of the
devices are the same as the
collecting devices, some are
not.  They could be simple
things like relays, hundreds of
relays or maybe a single device
as purposeful in terms of the
controller.  These devices are
typically powered by MCU class
devices, simple things like
measuring temperature.  To SOC
devices, which is typically more
powerful than an MCU and much
more flexible.  Those are the
devices in which you want to
have some device intelligence or
complex operations and types of
devices could be cameras,
gateways, point of sales
machines,
hubs.  We want to help our
developers build the devices to
help control your operations
much more easily and faster.
There is already a bunch of
sessions on Android Things.  I
encourage you to look at
sessions.  I will provide you
the basic understanding of
Android Things.   is essentially
essentiallyessentially Android
that we optimized for IoT.  For
example, user application or
system UI or notification.  We
added things needed for the IoT
device.  Like
peripheral I/O to add what you
need to.  enterprise, I think
the importance of Android Things
comes down to three points.
scale.  If you are a developer
for Android
enterprise, it uses the same
development kits and Android
Studio.  If you are not
familiar, there is a vibrant
ecosystem to start developing
devices relatively quickly.
OS is scaling to tablets, TVs,
watches, cars and many are in
enterprise situations as well
and now adding IoT to the mix.
The second is security.  A
session earlier today in the
morning that did dive on
security.  If you are interested
in security, I encourage you to
watch that video.  I will give
you a high-level view of how we
think about it with Android
Things.  Security in the OS and
app update.  We want to make
sure the device running Android
Things has the latest version
and you have the ability to
update your application that is
running the specific software.
We support signed
images, asset decisions.  We
know end-to-end security from
device to Cloud is very  The
last piece is I kind of
mentioned it before which is
peripheral IO and user drivers.
This allows you to connect
components, sensors, varying
input devices, displays into
Android Things and allow you to
use those and build applications
across those things.  Android
Things is currently in
development preview.  We're in
development preview four.  We
want to do releases every four
to six weeks.  We encourage you
to come and check it out.  We
will do updates in six to eight
weeks.  Long-term support
targeted for end of this year
and based on O.  is the software
layer of Android  The next
layer I will talk about is the
hardware.  we know hardware, new
hardware is hard and complex.
approach we're taking with
siliconsilicon partners is the
system
module.  That comes with
components, CPU, memory storage,
connectivity, essentially the
pieces you need to run it on.
From there, you go ahead, build
out the base board, which has
the
-- components.  Because it is
certified, Android Things works.
There is no additional
certification to do.  It helps
you speed up the development
cycle rapidly.  Obviously, we
work with a lot of silicon
partners and they're trusted in
the enterprise space.  For
enterprise this means fastest
speed to  have certified the
things and proven to work on
Android Things and you can
iterate on the designs.  Most of
the silicon partners have
developer kits as well that are
available.  In the demo booth,
that is one of the first booths
as you come in.  have a dev kit
from Raspberry pie, and a bread
board and wired it up.  It is a
device connecting, working,
sending information back to
Cloud  -- Cloud IoT Core.  We
soldered components on this one.
You can go from wires to
solder and in production,
because it is the same SOM, you
can scale these throughout the
enterprise.  We realize the
benefit of the IoT  The last
layer I'll talk about on Android
Things is services.  We want to
make it easy to use Google
services.   Google services can
help you with the things we
talked about.  If you use
TensorFlow to have Android
Things running locally on the
device.  We use local based
services, and I left some in
there.  We're working on
supporting Cassie's example.
the case of the enterprise
developer, you may be developing
for
both sides.  For enterprise the
most obvious service that makes
sense is Cloud IoT Core. have
dat on to Android Things to
Cloud IoT Core to provide data
analytics machine learning,
remote manage and control the
devices.  You might have a
sensor hub in the manufacturing
line or commercial building HVAC
system, you want to send that
information to the Cloud,
analyze real-time usage and to
take the insight and control the
devices back to able to
optimize the yield or reduce
How do you connect Android
Things to Cloud?  I have a
sample that we created. code
sample is an end-to-end code
sample with a couple of sensors
connected to Android Things,
defined the payload in terms of
what data we want to connect.
Send that information to Cloud
IoT Core. show the full thing.
At the end of the day, it is
down to a couple of core steps.
a project I.D., industry and
region I.D. you go to Android
Things and pull that off.  It
creates a public-private key, to
pull out the public key.  The
private key is stored in key
store.  It is secure.  The
second step is register the
device to Cloud IoT Core.  I
have shown you a command line
method, obviously, this doesn't
work.  It works really well for
prototyping, but for when you
want to go into production,
there are rest API that we can
use.  We will showcase a demo
about registration and how
important it is to onboard the
devices.  last step is it to
configure the Cloud things, and
use Android Things and connect
to the Cloud IoT Core to use the
power of Cloud.  sample GitHub
Android Things sends a hub Cloud
Let's take a real example or
an example.  Let's say you're
building a camera.  this camera
is a quality control camera.
You have the specifications of
what you want to achieve, you
evaluate the different SOMs you
want to provide.  You build your
product around those things.
comes with Android Things, so
you build it to do the camera
roles, the video, dapt data
capture, streaming.  And then
what becomes more interesting is
the on-device intelligence, the
TensorFlow piece.  In the cases
of quality control where
they're abstracts and maybe
pattern based where you can't
define rules.  I can imagine a
person at the end of the line
looking at widgets, they are
smarting in detecting what is a
defect and not a defect.  That
is for machine learning.  Maybe
you are trying to define a
quality of wood grain.  When you
see a particular grain you know
what that looks like.  Maybe
marbling on a piece of beat
beef.  That is subjective.   a
pizza lean, hands toed.  You
expect variation on a pizza, you
don't expect everything in the
same place, you see it and know
what good versus bad looks like.
Those are the examples of
machine learning.  You don't
want to stream it back to the
Cloud.  lot of information.
TensorFlow on device with the
models to do it locally.  only
stream the information back to
the Cloud to enhance models in
the Cloud.  As you make
umprovements to the Cloud, send
the models back to the device to
update the model.  have the
constant iteration of increasing
and making models better over
time.  Then you can use Android
Things to make sure the iOS is
updated to the latest patch.
Using the latest application.
You can also use Cloud to do
remote management to identify
and alert yourself if a camera
is down.  Maybe you are
collecting quality information
and you want to compare across
five lines to see which I should
do better.  The scale is if you
have one camera or hundreds or
maybe you want to take one
camera and retrofit a line with
a bunch of sensors.  get a sense
of what the line is doing.  You
think of correlations of what
is the difference in the line
and finding defects.  Maybe
analyses of forecasting issues
before they come along.  That is
the beauty of Cloud IoT Core
and Android Things.  As you add
more use cases you add on more
sensors and devices you stream
that to the  To wrap it up,
we're trying to make it easier
for partners and developers to
build solutions from edge to
Cloud.  Android Things is
beating out local controls,
local or notification, data
preprocessing.  Applied
analytics and machine learning.
This will allow you to design a
system that will improve
performance.  Here's where you
don't want to send data to the
Cloud and back, you can make
those decisions locally on the
device.  Build for bandwidth
requirements.  want to use
processing on the device and
send information you need to the
Cloud.  Be tolerant to off-line
use cases if intended or
nonintended.  You need
redundancy on the device and
same decisions on the Cloud as
well.  Working on solving the
key challenges through better
managed scaleability insights.
are excites about what you
think, I encourage you to invite
you to test it out and give us
feedback.  So thank you.
HANWOOK KIM: We will now go
through some demos.  On the demo
board we will have three demos
I will run you through.  demos I
will run through is around
registration.  in an enterprise
is challenging.  Registration is
difficult.  It is about tens
and hundreds of thousands of
devices, how do you register
these to Cloud IoT CoreCore?  We
will show two possibilities.
We will focus on the right set
of the devices, you can see the
QR code.  We have built a mobile
app for the demo.  What the app
will do is number one, I'll
send in by myself, as myself.
It will collect whether I am
authorized by Cloud IoT to see
if I am an authorized user.
This app is simple.  Basically
just two buttons.  Capture the
QR code and that gave me the
information I need to register
my device to Cloud IoT.  On the
device, you register, and
basically it will show the
device manager.  That device
will now show up on the device
manager.  And if you noticed,
you will see the device actually
turned on.  The device did, as
soon as it talked to the Cloud,
it lit up, and then we showed
the temperature of that device.
that information is actually
streaming every second to Cloud
IoT Core.  will go now and say I
put that on machine location
number one.  Now the second
device, I will do the same
thing.  Capture the QR code.
add device.  The same thing you
will see it show up on device
manager and soon the device will
light up as soon as it
connections, sending data.
Sending every second, so forth.
Now I will continue to go down
the line.  Capture the QR code,
add device.  Go to the next one.
Capture the QR code, add
device.  I will go and capture
the QR code.  device.  The last
one, again, maybe a different
location, I will capture the QR
code and add device.  Every time
I did that, you can see how
quickly I was able to get six
devices, see the visibility on
device manager and sending data
that are actually connected to
Cloud IoT Core every second I
send information back to that.
one example of how to register a
bunch of devices.  second
method is pre
keys are created in the
factory.  provided to enterprise
and enterprise sets it up in
the back office.  We'll show you
devices that are registered,
but disabled because they're en
route.  So I have on my app, I
will query the device register
where I said these are pre
registered.  install them where
I want.  Maybe I'm ready, maybe
I'm doing a test or in
production.  I will enable the
devices.  I have an app, one to
disable and one to enable.  will
hit the enable button.  will
see the devices enable.  As
they're connected, they will
light up.  Bulk, enable devices
right now.  So you can see some
of the devices are starting to
light up.  And they're all lit
up right now.  So now those are
12 Raspberry pies running.  we
have Mongo iOS, and we have the
same thing, the same process.
The registry process is the same
across OSs, we want to make it
simple to register them on Cloud
IoT Core and manage in one
place.  we will transfer it back
to Indranil now.
INDRANIL CHAKRABORTY: Thank
you, Hanwook.  He showed you to
do batch registration.  And we
can do enable and disable.  will
show you how to access data
from the global deployment of
the devices and how to create
simple rules as well to take
some action.  So we have a
dashboard here.  we have done is
we have
taken these devices, deployed
them in mountain view and other
areas as well.  In Raspberry
devices, connected to Cloud IoT
Core and sending data about
temperature, humidity, pressure
other factors as well.  And what
I can show you is these are all
the location of the devices,
you can monitor, you can do
real-time monitoring of all the
devices in terms of the
temperature.  So the last chart
shows you the local temperature
for all the bunch of devices,
humidity and pressure.  What we
also have is a more detailed
view.  So I can click on a
device, and I can see real-time
what is the temperature of that
device, whether it is outside or
inside, humidity, light,
pressure.  And also you can see
that chart, it is moving, every
second as it collected data from
every source.  In interest of
time, I will move to another
demo where we're going to show
how we can switch to the switch
So we have here, Raspberry pie
running Android Things on this
device measuring temperature and
light.  We have this running
Android Things in a relay.  I
will do is I will put my finger
here, which increases the
temperature and also blocks the
light.  It would see that the
fan turns on on.  What is
happening here.  We have build
the Raspberry pie is sending
data to Cloud IoT Core.  Cloud
IoT Core publishes it to Pub/Sub
and from there a Cloud function
with a simple rule that if a
temperature is above 90
Fahrenheit, it will turn on the
fan through that session.  I can
do is turn it off through my UI
as well.  All I have to do is
-- okay.  Just say fan -- it
will create adjacent on.  Fan on
equals to false.  I will send a
command. the fan is turned off.
So you can use the system to
create rules either using Cloud
function or data flow to act on
the device and command or do it
from UI as well.  As a quick
demo of batch registration and
how to use connected devices,
send to Cloud to act on it and
send messages back to devices as
Let's switch to the main deck
so we can wrap it up.
So we went through
this.  In the summary, you saw
we have Android Things which
takes security of the edge,
managing devices at scale at the
edge and also running
actionable insights at the edge
using TensorFlow.  We have Cloud
IoT Core to connect your
existing and new devices,
securing it to Cloud, and
leverage other things, such as
Pub/Sub and other items.  It is
building scaleable information
and get actionable insight.
Next step, helpful links, if you
are interested in more Android
Things, go to this website.  is
currently on private beta.  Go
to this link and request access.
And we're reviewing access and
provide access over the next
couple of weeks.  In summary,
we're very excited with what you
can do.  love to hear your
feedback on Android Things and
Cloud IoT Core.  Thank  Thank
you for joining this session,
brand ambassadors will assist
you in getting to the exits.  We
will ask that you please clear
the room and return via the
registration line outside.
Thank you.
of
session)
Thank you for joining this
session, brand ambassadors will
assist in getting you to the
designated exits.  We will make
room for the next session.  If
you are registered for the next
session in this room, we ask
that you clear the room and
please return via the
registration
Welcome.  Please fill in the
seats near the front of the
room.  Thank you.
Welcome.  Our session will
begin soon.
Welcome, please fill in the
seats near the front of the
room.  Thank you.
Wilkinson, I work in develop
relations with games and
Daydream.  One thing I remember
as a child is going to Aaron
space museum and they just
opened up a movie theater and
they eached up mood to fly.  It
was a small theater, deep.  When
they opened
up, they started with this clip
and the whole screen opened up
into imax.  I was blown away.  I
can take these experiences in
Daydream and bring them to other
people.  I want to help you
make your own Daydream
applications for video.  A few
things, design considerations
for Daydream.  It will be
different than a mobile app.
second is video quality.  makes
video good and bad. finally,
Unity which is a great deal for
Daydream apps and also
components we've made to
jump-start your application
development.  So VR is a little
different.  You probably heard
some of these things before.
to bring a new reality to people
to give them a new experience.
These sessions are a little bit
longer, you have 40 minutes,
maybe longer of sitting in a
relaxed spot, not walking
around, you're not sitting in a
conference.  You're really
focused on the application so
you have to take that into
account.  And if you think about
the range of motion, you have
about 70 to work with.   30
from either side, comfortable.
If you want the user, they can
stretch, maybe rotate their
shoulders, they can see 80
either side, pretty comfortably,
but it is still a stretch.  We
want to keep the main focus on
the application really there in
the front, in that
70.  In terms of distance, you
really want to be somewhere
between half a meter and 20
meters away.  That is kind of
the virtual distance you want to
work with.  that is up close,
you really end up straining your
eyes, maybe crossing your eyes
trying to focus on that.  Far
away, it turns into something
flat and there is not a lot of
depth perception.  Speaking of
depth perception, you really
want to have some texture and
shadow in your environment.  you
can see here, before the
texture was added to the
squares, they just looked like
BLOPs.  Now that we added
texture and shadows, you can see
there are three boxes and
circles moving around them.  So
all the mechanics are good, but
you really need to think about
the environment that you're in.
So you want to convey some
presence.  You want to take them
somewhere.   look at this
screen, it would be a great
screen for a weapon  -- web page
or something.  It is a little
plain, but it doesn't convey
anything.  Something I see a lot
of and I do a lot in my
prototypes, we're all guilty of
it, kind of the void Spaces.
You make the space, infinite
plane, and you put your content
in it, throw it there.  It is
fast, it renders quickly.  It
gives you the sense of VR-ness,
but it really doesn't take you
anywhere.  It is not very
memorable.  You really miss this
opportunity to make something
memorable in your application.
So if you look at the Daydream
home screen, it does a good job
of this.  It has some
environment to look at, things
to focus on.  You kind of follow
the water into the center of
the screen and then you add your
content.  This is really to
focus your attention on the
content.  And you can do
something even crazy, like this
example here, where we've taken
the same content, but kind of
integrated it into the
environment.  So you've got the
rock there, that is framing the
menu at the bottom.  And you've
got the sunlight coming through
the trees, that's kind of a
spotlight on your content, to
really focus the eyes there.
here, though, is this really is
hard to do if you will move the
content at all.  You don't want
to move the menu back, for
example, into the rock.  Or you
have to move the rock.  It gets
complex.  This is kind of the
very extreme case, if you can do
this, fantastic.  But you
normally end up with
compromises.
So you can make a great
environment, great presence of
your app, but you really need to
have great video to have a
great video app.  The first
thing when we talk about quality
of video is resolution.  This
is the number of Pixels or the
number of samples in the frame
that we're looking at.  And as
you can see, there is a wide
range from the very low
definition, so maybe these are
things that show up on
television or on little game
devices.  All the way up to 4K,
which is kind much the
cutting-edge of what you can
find, both on mobile devices and
televisions today. are the kind
of proportional relationship
that is not to scale, but
relative to each other, they're
scale.  is a lot more bits to
move as you get into the higher
resolutions.  You have to think
about that.  It will take more
CPU, more time, more bandwidth
if you're streaming. want to be
aware of that.  want to balance
your resolution to the quality
of the content that you're
sending.  Now, when we talk
about resolution you usually
hear numbers like 1080P or 720I.
And this is what those Ps and
Is mean.  So you have
progressive.  means that every
single line is shown.  you get a
complete picture.  Where
interlaced is every other line.
This allowed a trick that, in a
movie where half the lines are
sent the first frame and
subsequent the other half is
cent.  You can have a large
resolution and only send half
the bits per frame.  This is the
bitrate, the price of it is the
quality of the video.  can be a
little softer.  motion is
blurry.  You want to be aware if
you use an interlace video, you
have a slow motion and soft
picture.
Also with the capturing of the
video, you have aspect ratio.
It is that, the ratio of the
width to the height of the
screen.  When you present it
back to the user, you are aware
of what it is captured with.  We
have 4:3, standard definition
ratio shown on HD screen so it
stretches it out and it looks
kind of weird.  Also in VR, we
have the opportunity to do 360.
So this is fantastic.  You can
take a picture, I have seen
some of the people holding them
up in the cameras, walking
around outside also.  get the
spherical views of the world.
Here's one I took on top of our
San Francisco office one day.
And you can kind of see the
middle part of it looks pretty
normal.  But as you get to the
top and bottom of the image, it
gets really stretched out.  So
you have to be aware of what
projection was used by the
camera so that you can show the
same projection when you render
it.  The most common one is
called the ekquiekquirectangular
projection.  is where it
unfolds the sphere into a
rectangle and stretching the top
of the sphere along the top of
the rectangle and bottom.  The
poles get distorted and the
middle part is clear.  You can
see once a put it back on the
sphere, the distortion goes away
and you can see the bay bridge
clearly.  You can also do stereo
vision.  So we have all been to
3D movies where they do
polarized views.  You can also
do stereo projections in VR
where you have got two separate
images for each eye.  the left
eye is on top of the right eye,
like in this example.  Here,
each of them are slightly
different.  offset.  So when you
show them side-by-side your
eyes see the difference in depth
perception.  It looks
stereoscopic.  So all of this
was about the dimensions and the
resolution, aspect ratios of a
single frame.  But when you look
at a movie, it is made up of
lots of frames.  And that's
called the frame rate of course.
So here are all the frame
rates that you will probably
ever encounter.  And as you can
see, it is a long list.  And
there is no right or wrong frame
rate.  It mostly has to do with
the capturing.  So at the
bottom, it is typically like a
standard movie would be, 24
frames per second.  And camera
is 29.7 or 30 in Europe.  And
specialized cameras are higher
frame rates.  This is important
to play it back.  If you
captured a fast frame rate, and
you are playing it slowly, it
might look jerky because you are
skipping frames.
Alternatively, if you have a low
capture, you will never speed
it up faster than the capture
rate and have any appreciable
improvement in quality.  that we
have multiple frames coming at
us, different resolutions, we
want to be able to do things
with that.  We need to read it,
process it, decode it, put it on
a screen, maybe we're
downloading it from a server.
bitrate.  This is where they
call the encoders, the codex
come into play.  A common one is
the H.264 encoder.  And that is
found on almost every device
now.  And they're usually
implemented in hardware.  The
H.265 encoder is coming and will
be on more modern devices.  It
is much more efficient at this
compression. can see these are
the recommended data rates for
H.264.  For the different
resolutions.  And so you can
imagine trying to push 40
megabits a second over a crowded
Wi-Fi connection might be a
little challenging.  You may
have to scale it down, if that
is your environment.  Or you may
need to be aware of that and
not do a lot of processing
around the video, if you have
special effects and things like
that.  So let's talk about
Daydream.  If you look at the
Android standard specification,
we say to vendors, if you want
to be Daydream ready, these are
what you need to support in your
device.  So
264, H.264 of course is at 4K,
the maximum resolution we really
can get is 4K.  At 30 frames
per second, with 40 megabits per
second transfer.  So this
allows them to measure how much
CPU is needed to actually get
the
video decoded and on the
screen.  And then we also ask
for 265.  So it is so much more
efficient that you should be
able to get the 1080P at the
same frame rate, but a quarter
of the data rate, because 265 is
that much more efficient.  So
equivalently we're saying, here,
you can run
four 1080P video streams on the
same device, if you are using
H265 encoding.  You can see the
minimum resolution we want is
the 1080P.  But ideally, you
have got a higher resolution so
you can get a much nicer and
richer
So when we talk about VR, it
is a little different than just
watching a movie or a YouTube
stream on your device in your
hand.  Since you are holding it
up, and in the viewer, and you
are looking at it with
essentially magnifying glasses,
you want to have a really high
quality image, so you're not
distracted by little
imperfections in the video,
things like that.  The minimum
we recommend for a monoscopic
video, where both eyes see the
same image, it is there, 1080P,
30 frames per second and 16
megabits per second.
comfortable, and gives a nice
image.  If you are doing 360 or
stereoscopic, there is really
double the amount of information
you need.  360 with the
aqua rectangular projection.
It is seen or off to the side.
We want to double the resolution
and really get up there to the
four K size so that way half of
it is shown in the eyes and it
looks very good.  You can see
the difference, really, of
bitrate, so it only went to 24.
Not to 32.  If there is any
math whizzes out there.  that's
because of this compression.  So
the encoder, as it is
compressing will find repeating
sections of the frame as you get
larger so it can compress more
effectively. now, we've got a
bitrate, we have a file, like
an MPEG4 file or something.  We
need to do something with it to
get it on the device so we can
actually show it.  There is a
couple of different ways to do
that.  The first way is to
download it, package it up in an
auxiliary file, OBB file, off
the play store or in your own
server or download it there.
Maybe you have sports highlights
every week or current events in
the news.  it gets downloaded.
Then they can play it offline.
is great, because if you don't
have connectivity all the time,
your user doesn't, they can
download it, play it back
whenever they want to.  don't
need to be connected to the
Internet.  are also easy to
encode these, because you don't
have to worry about multiple
resolutions and multiple data
arrays, like if you were
streaming.  You can have really
easy delivery, like I said.  The
downside is you've got to
figure out what to send.  So you
need to do catalog management
and curate your list more
closely.  And you need a way to
delete files that you are not
using any more.  After a year,
you don't want to fill up the
user's device.  On the streaming
side, we're all pretty familiar
with this.  You know, YouTube
streams, there is a couple of
other companies out there that
stream.  And the great thing
about it is there is tons of
content.  You can have an
Internet full of content, select
it, and play it back.   is not
expected to download anything
they're not using.  They like
it.  It is an eat the bandwidth
as you use it model, which is
great.  knows how to use it.
know how to get on, log on,
start streaming video easily.
The downside is this encoding
problem.  As you saw, especially
with larger, high quality
videos upon the speed creates a
bitrate problem.  To be
guaranteed a high bandwidth
connection on Wi-Fi sometimes
can be challenging.  So what you
want to do is encode at
multiple bitrates.  So usually
do that by different resolution.
You start with a 4K stream for
the best quality.  You go down
to
2K and maybe 1080P and you use
something like the dash or HLS
protocol to switch between the
streamsstreams effortlessly.
There may be degrading of the
quality, it is fuzzy for a
second and will jump back up as
network conditions improve.
So now we have all this video,
figured out how to get it there
and all that.  We'll go ahead
and look a little bit at Unity.
Not everyone has seen Unity.
The first thing I wanted to do
was give a quick tour of the
Unity editor.  As we talk about
things, you will kind of
understand.  You layout a 3D
scene here with the hierarchy on
the left, for example, here's a
camera, you can see what the
camera sees.  is a property
inspector over here on the
right.  In order to make it
Daydream capable, you have to
turn on the VR support.  So you
do that here on the Android side
by just checking this box.
selecting Daydream out of this.
One of the important things to
remember is when you are
watching videos, it will be a
long time.  It will not be just
30 or 40 minutes, it might be an
hour or two hours. want to make
sure the sustained performance
mode is
checked.  Now you have a scene.
You can add simple models,
built into Unity, you can
adplanes, trains -- add planes,
trains, cylinders.  them around.
More complex things you build
in a modeling tool and you can
import them.  And we can also
change behaviors of the cube.
we can add physical things to
it.  We can call a component a
rigid body which adds mass and
interplaces with the physics
system.  We can turn off the
gravity in VR mode, of course.
And we can add custom scripts,
this is where the application
building comes in that will add
custom behaviors that you script
in C sharp.  Here is one called
spin that will spin the cube.
just -- here when the
application starts, you would
just grab that rigid body and
call adds work to this.  And it
will start spinning the object
here.  That is pretty exciting.
Tow make it more exciting, we
take a 3D model we have built.
An environment for example, and
here is --
many clicks.
add prefabricated components.
This particular one was a room
we made and modeled shapes on it
to give it a different feel.
It gives it a completely
different feel and the exact
same program we just ran.  You
can see the real power of
getting that environment
set.  So here's kind of a block
diagram of everything that is
involved in that Unity app.  You
have Unity itself there, which
contains the scene, the 3D
models, C sharp script that you
would write.  You add to it
also, the Google GVRSGK which
you can download from Google
Developers.com or Github.  Part
of this is a video plug-in that
connects the XO player plug-in,
which there was a talk yesterday
about it, which you can see on
YouTube if you are interested.
CodeLabs about it.  This wraps
the media service in Android
into something that is
customizable, and simple to work
with.  It also handles
communicating with the VR
services that are part of
Android operating
system.  The systems that are
part of Android handle these
things for you so you don't have
to handle them in your
application code or as you draw
in Unity, the async projection
is the concept of turning your
head fast, instead of draw a
stream as you turn your head.
Async can detect your motion and
draw the existing image in the
right place.  As you turn your
head to the right, it moves to
the left.  You don't get the
nauseous feeling like nothing is
moving.  It handles lens
distortion.  Again, the lenses
in Daydream are essentially
spherical magnifying glasses.
want to present to that a
distorted image.  So when it
goes through the lens, it will
be corrected.  And this handles
handleshandles adding that
distortion automatically, so you
don't have to do it every time.
is also support for spatial
audio.  This will allow the
soundses,t will emanate from
behind you.  You will want to
turn around.  ears and eyes will
be in sync and build the
allusion of being in a different
place.   course the mechanics
of head tracking and the
controller.
XO player, this is a
super-simple model.  If you need
to know more about it, I would
definitely point you back to
YouTube for yesterday's talk.
And the code lab that you can do
in the code lab area for today
and tomorrow.
this does is it gives you the
capability to customize each
step in the process of playing
the video.  If you think about
the video as an MPEG4 or stream
on the server, there is a data
source.  That data source can be
in a variety of different
formats and that needs to be
extracted into the decoder.  The
decoder will take the bits that
you got off the file or off the
Internet and it is going to
decompress them into a video
stream, audio stream, maybe
closed captioning.  And then
feed that into the XO player
class itself.  In the class
itself, it is going to handle
buffering, because it is not
going to be able to decode as
fast as it is playing back.
usually do a little bit ahead of
time and that way there is
plenty of data to consume as
we're  And then under
application control, there is
the track selector.  The track
selector says you want to show
this video and this audio, maybe
you have multiple audio streams
for different languages or
maybe you have a stereo in mono
and you want to have different
selections for those or
different resolutions.  And you
can select the tracks and show
those through the renderers.
renderers are the things that
actually draw or renders sound.
So there is a lot of moving
parts to this.  And it can be
kind of overwhelming, as we
found, as we started building
some of these samples for
Daydream.  So we decided to
funnel them together into a
media app template.  This
template will be available to
Github shortly.  I don't think
it is there today, but it should
be soon.  This gives the Unity
building blocks, the prefabbed
models and scripts to allow you
to jump-start your application.
You can focus on delivering a
great experience to the user,
rather than having to decode
video.  So the first thing we
added to it is the selection
system.  And with bread crumb
navigation.  A series of
folders.  You can make your own
categories.  And put videos in
them.  And then you can navigate
up and down the
hierarchy.  Another thing we did
was add this capability of not
only showing the video, but
sampling it and creating a light
source in Unity that is
representative of the video
frame being shown at that time.
So you get this nice emissive
effect from the video, like a
glow from the screen or
television or whatever it is.
And it adds really a sense of
warmth and being to the screen.
It feels like it is really
there.  We also found that not
everyone likes to sit in the
front row at a movie theater or
in the back row.  So we allow
zooming of it.  You can see this
also in the YouTube Daydream
app where it allows you to move
the screen in and out to where
it is at a comfortable position
for you to view.  It makes a big
difference when you are trying
to sit there and watch a movie
for an hour.  You want to be
comfortable and relaxed.  Being
comfortable and relax doesn't
mean being level.  Daydream
wants the horizon to be level
and straight ahead.  This allows
you to tilt the screen.  So if
you are leaning back in your
chair, lying on your bed, you
can move the screen up and don't
have to crane your neck to look
down at the screen.  is another
comfort thing.
360 repositions, I don't know
how many of you tried to look at
the 360 image or video in
Daydream, it seems like for me,
always, I pick it up and the
main thing I'm supposed to be
looking at is over there.  end
up looking around oh, there it
is, now I can look at it.  This
allows you to pick it up, move
it back into your center to be
comfortably seated again and the
subject is right in front of
you.  Of course playback
controls.  You can spend a lot
of time making playback
controls.  We decided just to
make some for you and save you
the headache.
We do a good job of looking at
the stream when we're playing it
back and trying to determine
what format it is in.  We get
the
projection right, is it
stereoscopic, side-by-side eyes,
top and bottom eyes.  we don't
choose right, maybe you want to
explore and try different
things.  You can do that by
changing the projection manually
as well.
in the media app template is
all the prefabs that you can
pull into your project,
customize and integrate into
your application.  We have the
bread crumb, title, tilt, zoom
the screen, which is great, the
playback controls and of course
the emissive lighting which is
tricky to get
sometimes.  To kind of wrap
everything up, I know we covered
everything!  And just want to
have one checklist to cover
these things.  And you really
want to keep the user comfort
first at hand.  Having them sit
in a comfortable place and not
having to move their shoulders
around or look up and down will
make your app that much more
enjoyable, and they will go back
and play it again and again.
You want to take the opportunity
to make a destination a place
they can go.  So when they think
about it, they'll go oh, yeah,
I want to watch this video in
this sports arena or whatever
environment you decide to make,
and it gives them something else
to remember, rather than that
empty space.  want to respond
time in your encoding as well.
Making sure you are delivering
the best possible quality video
you can get, in the constraints
of the application you are
really targeting.  If you are
targeting offline people, you
want to target downloading those
things and having good
encoding.  If you are targeting
streaming people, you have to
encode in other bitrates to make
sure everything can be
switched, depending on network
quality.  And you really want to
match as best you can what
information was used when they
capture the video.  So the
aspect ratio, you don't want to
recalculate aspect ratio on the
fly.  If it is in the
rectangular projection, you want
your sphere to be close to the
sphere they used.  That way,
your images look great, just as
great as they were when they
were captured.  Finally, delight
your users.  That's why we're
here. love to make great apps.
make whatever you do really
enjoyable.  And think about how
they're going to use it.  you
use it over and over again?  If
it is a one-time deal, that's
great, that's fine, but you
really want to create something
they will use over and over
again.  Here's some links to get
things.  Definitely the
Daydream overview site is a good
starting point where there are
many more links to different
samples and these Github repos.
And again XO player is very
configureable, very powerful, I
suggest checking out their site
and CodeLabs and maybe their
talk. thanks for your attention
today.
Thank you for joining this
session.  Brand ambassadors will
assist with directing you
through the designated exits.
be making room for those
who have registered for the
next session.  If you have
registered for the next session
in this room, we ask that you
exit the room and return via the
registration line outside.
Thank you.
of
session)
session.  Brand ambassadors
(End of session)
.
Welcome.  Thank you for
joining.  Our
session will begin soon.
Welcome.  Please fill in the
seats near the front of the
room.  Thank you.
Hello everyone.  Let's see.  is
my slides?  Welcome to the
afternoon, the second day of
I/O.  I hope everyone is
enjoying their time here.   Lee.
I'm here to give you more
information about where we are
with Tango.  If you see the
keynote, which probably most of
you did, you get to see a little
bit.  In this session, we will
see a lot more and go into a lot
more depth, than we could
otherwise.  So I wanted to start
with this quote from Beau
Lotto.  A neuroscientist from
the university College London.
He said the best technologies
are the ones that make the in
visible visible.   of that is a
microscope.  It is something --
it is a tool that allowed us to
see more things about our
environment, things that may
have always been
there, but let us see things in
a new way and gives us a better
understanding about how the
world works and also changes the
way about how we view ourselves
as well.  And most of our
devices today -- can play the
video.  Yeah.   our devices
today view the world as a flat
screen.  we're physical beings
in a physical world and we
wanted to add the capabilities
of 3D with Tango, adding motion
and sense of depth for objects
and services.  If I place this
bottle here -- if it stays.  it
doesn't have a flat surface.
Well, if I place the bottle
here.  It is a mere physical
presence that is meaningful to
all of us.  I can refer to it
and talk about it in a way that
we all understand because of the
physical presence.  It is
because of the way our minds
evolve.  If our tools understood
the fact this bottle was here
before, we would have a shared
understooding with the people in
this room and also with our
tools.  As a quick refresher,
Tango has three new capabilities
for mobile devices.  Motion
tracking, depth perception and
area learning.  You will learn
more about the large-scale area
turning from Justin that we call
the visual positioning  First,
let's take a quick recap of the
hardware.   you may know, the
first device that came out with
Tango enabled device, Lenovo
Phab 2 Pro.  It came out last
fall with all the capabilities
capabilities.  And the next was
the Asus Zenfone.  It is Tango
enabled and Daydream ready with
the quad HD display and sleek,
thin design.    We're pleased to
mention that in later this
summer, Verizon stores across
the country, customers can play
with the Zenfone across the
United States, with other
international countries coming
this summer as well.  In
addition to the phones, as you
see in the keynote, we support
stand alone headsets for VR.
working on a specialized version
of Tango that does tracking in
3D.  We use two fish eye cameras
built into Tango to allow six
position freedom and movement in
the VR headset.  Now, we all
know that hardware is merely the
vehicle that carries new
experience to users.  It is a
software that brings the
experiences and value to the
users.  Let me show you a short
video showing some of the great
work running on the platform
today.
(music)
JOHNNY LEE: So that's just a
really short glimpse into some
of the hundred apps that are now
available on the Play Store
since those phones came out a
few months ago.  I would like to
highlight a few of these in
three different categories.
Games, shopping and tools.  In
games, electronic arts recently
released an update for their
Sims free play which allowed you
to use Tango to walk through
the environment of the houses
your Sims live in,
Brick Headz builder is a tool
building game where you see your
characters come to life in
front of you.  You can build
your custom models or work with
the free models provided in the
game.
monster battle is a turn grid
class game where you use
combinations of monsters to
defeat your  One area we see a
lot of value for 3D visual
ization is shopping.  Pottery
barn placed products in your
living room to see how it fits
with the existing furniture.  Or
clear out the room and start
from scratch.  BMW lets you
verify if you are interested in
the BMWI3.  And you can checkout
the higher end I8 if you are
curious.  Look at the interior
interiors, configure it.  The
dashboard and chair details by
moving around.  One of the areas
particularly hard is shopping
for clothing online and having a
good fit.  Gap has been working
with a company called Ava
metric which does physically
accurate simulation.  You pick
the mannequin that best fits
your body type, you will see how
different clothes will fit and
stretch when you wear them.  to
these partners we have several
other partners interested in
making applications to help you
make better decisions when
shopping online with your phone
or helping you shop in the  Now,
tools is also a really
interesting category.  helps
create a new class that gives
you the ability to make
measurements about your
environment.  It is great for
people that are trying to get
work done.  To give you a few
examples of these, we have a
clip of what partners are doing
in this
area.     Our goal was to
develop an app that allowed you
to do that.  Before Tango we
were using the RGP camera and
noise URI to capture room.  We
had to prevent the user from
moving during the capture
process.  The Odom tree sensing
and RGP camera allows us to
classify everything you see
through the device and all of
that in the matter of  Trimble
has combined the mixed reality
system, using paper plans
on-site to provide a real world
understanding, future space
relative to today's space.  is a
stage of the service of
investigation and installation
stage in the pavement  Recently,
we were in the middle of
mechanical coordination at the
General Motors technical center
REEFRP and science building.  We
had modeling of the facility,
but gaps that needed to be
filled to ensure the compressor
would work.  We used the Tango
enabled device to capture
information, verify clearances
and keep it  Cat live share
gives us live audio, live video
and introduces augmented reality
annotation.  It is mapping the
world real-time.  We can
annotate this side of the
machine, spin around, annotate
behind us, spin around and the
other annotations are still
there.  It is the history of
where you have been around a  I
am a supervisor in Toronto
Canada.  I use Google Tango for
onsite data information.  You
get back texture information,
and volume information and get
it at world scale.  Your actor
is 5'4", you have that on
record. get the wrinkles in the
costume, how they stand.  How
big is the doorway or prop.
that data acquisition easy,
quick, and efficient.
So there's --  Thanks.  That
will give you a glimpse into the
kind of things that generally
save people time or money to get
their jobs done.  We see the
value of Tango providing more of
that to more people.  In terms
of demos, one thing I wanted to
highlight is a Sandbox demo.
How many of you have been to the
Tango Sandbox?  Oh, okay.
About a third to half of you.
One of the demos there I like
that is great is this one called
somewhere or welcome to oz.
you walk into the space you see
the empty floor and two walls.
With the work of a team up in
San Francisco trying to better
estimate lighting, shadows,
reflections to make AR content
blend better to the environment
when you look through the
Zenfone AR -- is there a video?
Back
one more.  That one.  Yes.
(No
dialogue)
JOHNNY LEE: That's a really
fun experience.  If you go to
Sandbox, you can get a selfie
taken with one of the
characters, just like this.
with the right work and focus on
lighting, shadows and
reflections in the floor, the
compositing of the characters
can look very realistic.  So let
me give you a demo of some of
these live.  Switch to the
phone.  The first one I will
show you is an app called HOLO.
It is out of Los Angeles.  In
addition to animated characters
we can actually do real world
characters.  Or real life
people.  What they have is a
capture system with a large
array of cameras that allow you
to do live performances of
people and capture them in full
3D.  Let's add someone you may
be familiar with.  Hey, it is
great to be here.  Sorry I
couldn't be here in person.  But
I did the next best thing,
which was sending my hologram,
because you know, holograms are
cool.  hey -- I can walk around,
look at him from a bunch of
different actors.   capture them
in 3D, place them in a space
like this.  Because they're
virtual in 3D, we can do
something a little more fun,
like
this.  Hey, it is great to be --
We'll do this
one.  And we'll shrink him.
this.  Whoa!  Okay.  Now, that,
that is a big water bottle.   So
it is a lot of fun.  It shows
you what's possible when there
is more and more content out
there and people building these
type of 3D experiences.
also have made a bunch of SDK
improvements.  One of the ones I
want to show you is something
we are calling cominternally,
but it is in-line on online
drift building.  The
measurements are only useful if
they stay attached to the world.
Drift correction is something
that we have been wanting -- had
turned on as an experimental
mode for a while.  We have been
making optimizations in the
performance to run it real-time
all the time, without minimal
impact with the application.  If
I shake the phone and lose
tracking, it locks back on,
brings back the measurements to
the same space.  If you update
the SDK -- (applause) Yeah, I
think that's a cool one.  This
keeps content registered to the
environment even if the user
walks away, puts it in their
pocket, brings it back out, as
long as it is in the same
session.  If you update the app
and work in one of the current
SDK you will have the online
drift correction for you
automatically.  So can we go
back to the slides?
We also have a few other SDK
improvements I would like to
share.  One big request --  this
one is the constructor
developer tool, which is also
being demoed in the Sandbox
area.  It is the first party 3D
scanning app.  wanted to show
you a video showing should of
the updated results.  This is
all data that has been captured
with the Lenovo Phab 2 Pro and
professed on the Phab 2 Pro.
quality of the reconstruction is
actually pretty good.  It is
not fully photo realistic, but
you get a good sense of the
environment and walking around
and details and a sense of the
space.  One of the cool things
is with the Asus phone, it is
Tango enabled and Daydream
ready.  can scan a room in full
3D and get these kind of
captures, but we added a VR
viewing mode so with the press
of a button, you can put it in
the headset and move through the
apartment you scanned using the
Daydream controller to teleport
through this apartment.  It is
amazing that you can do all of
this with a phone that fits in
your pocket.
We've talked to some
developers, not everyone knows
what to
want a floor plan.  We took
algorithms and export a 2D floor
plan to walk around, get an
estimate of the doors, walls
around furniture.  One
interesting thing, the developer
that did this, realized his
apartment is 50 square feet
smaller than it was supposed to
be.  You could literally use
this to renegotiate your rent if
you felt like you were charged
too. got feedback that better
occulusion tools is desired.
have coming soon examples of
real-time shaders that combine
the data from the RGP and depth
camera to do effects like this
really easily, and without a lot
of hassle, writing your code to
figure out how to do this well.
some sample code on using
data from the RGB camera to
improve environmental
illustration.  The shadows add a
lot to whether it is really
there.  You can see the
reflection of the notebook and
the mug in the pool  is ways to
go before it is Hollywood
special effects, this isn't bad
for real-time capability on
phones.  We're also happy to say
that if you're one of the
developers that worked on one of
the 40 thousand uforia apps
currently in the Play Store,
Vuforia has Tango integration.
Vuforia apps will work on a
broad range of phones, but on
Tango phones it will benefit
from the smart terrain system
that processes the point Cloud
and better tracking from the
fish eye camera.  We're really
happy to welcome this augmented
reality community that's been
around for a few years.  Another
exciting thing that we wanted
to share, give a little detail
on is web AR and chromium.
Today, if you want to take
advantage of the benefits of AR
and place objects in a person's
room, you have to convince the
user, to find your application,
download it and install the app.
Like with web VR, wouldn't it
be great to go to a URL and
suddenly, you can download and
pull the assets right away.  If
we can view AR content as we can
view video on the web, that
would be great.  So this is
actually an early prototype of
chromium web browser at a
warfare website.  You can see
the motion tracking, depth data
are piped into the web page.
person has drawn out a box in
the living room and said what
tables will fit in this space.
And wayfair responds with the
tables that will fit the
constraints and render that
obvious inside the web browser.
As you think about content
being able to discover content
easily, we view this as a really
interesting way to make it much
easier for people who own
3D assets and want the assets
to users much more quickly
without having to preinstall a
specific app.  Now, to tell you
a little bit more about location
and AR and our visual
positioning service, let me hand
it off to Justin.
JUSTIN QUIMBY: Thanks,
Johnny, my name is Justin
Quimby, we made a lot of
progress on the location-based
AR.  I'm thrilled at the chance
to show off what the team has
been working on.  So clay
mentioned the visual positioning
service at the keynote.  I'm
proud to say the service has
apps running on it today.  The
first app, which launched on VPS
was an app entitled lumen,
built by good to go and running
at the Detroit museum of arts.
It navigates you to the exhibits
and visual content when you
arrive at the exhibits.  Here
you can see a visitor getting
navigation to a specific
exhibit.  This is using no
Bluetooth beacons.  No Wi-Fi
maps or GPS.  This is entirely
visual navigation.  Then once it
is  -- once the user gets to
the exhibit -- I'll skip to the
next slide.  Once you get to the
exhibit, you can then see
digital content overlaid on top
of the real world.  you see a
CAT scan of at mummy in the real
allows visitors through the
Phab 2 Pro to see through the
outer wrapping and revealing the
skeleton underneath.  As a
result of the overlay of digital
information in the real world,
visitors can see the really
large crack on the skull of the
mummy.  This blending of the
real and digital means that
visitors are actively engaging
with and learning from the
mummy, rather than walking in
the room and saying hey it's a
mummy and leaving.  In part,
because of this, lumen won the
American alliance of museums
annual competition for the games
in augmented reality app
category because the app
delivers meaningful visitor
outcomes.  we've also launched
an AR experience at the art
science museum in Singapore,
which you saw at Johnny's
keynote this morning.  This app
transforms a thousand square
meters of the museums into a
virtual rain for est, which you
can explore.  It is made by
several organizations in
associate with Panasonic, and
others including an art rift in
Singapore, Brian Tan.
Singapore National Museum
launched a VPS.  This lets
visitors explore the museum and
see how it evolved over the last
130 years.  This floating whale
skeleton used to be in the
museum, but was transferred to
Malaysia in the 1970s.  You have
parents taking their kids and
explaining to them what they
used to see when they were kids
visiting the museum.  it a
digital object placed in the
world, it can show not just the
skeleton, but a full whale, not
just a static whale, but a whale
and how it eats.  It is not
just museum that launched apps
using VPS.  We launched the
treasure hunt experience in
connection to the MGM Grand in
Las Vegas.  This app allows
players to go on a digital
treasure hunt for coins within
the casino.  They can use those
to win real world prizes.
succeeds when our partners
succeed.  We're fortunate to
have a partner here with us,
Kyle from Lowe's to talk about
how they built on top of the
platform to solve real problems
for users. Thanks, thanks
Justin.  So when you think of
Lowe's you don't necessarily
think of emerging tech like
Tango.  You know, every
organization on the planet said
they want to create the new
disruptive tools, but that is
harder than it seems.  There are
two things to figure out.  What
you want to work on and what
you don't want to work on.  So
to figure that out, we get
people together inside and
outside of the company to work
on those things.  You need an
intuitive way to help people
understand the future.  That's a
hard thing.  We do that through
story.  We create actual
narratives about the future we
want to build and we work
backwards to bring it to life.
This is a scene from our first
story that we turned into a
comic book.  It turned out to be
the most disruptive tool we
ever built.  One of the hardest
things about home improvement is
it is really hard to envision
how the project is going to turn
out.  even harder to
communicate that to the person
you have to convince to
communicate that to somebody
else.  So it is estimated that
$70 billion in projects every
year go ununfulfilled just
because of the visualization
problem.  We knew we could use
visualization tech to build new
tools to help solve this
problem.  We use our comic book
to show the executive team what
the future would look like and
all about bringing the intuitive
solutions to life in order to
influence human behavior.  It is
not about building tech for
tech's sake.  The executive's
reaction after seeing the comic
book was to go build it. did it.
Four years ago we brought the
first iteration of the augmented
reality design solution that we
call the Holoroom into two of
the Canadian stores.  Four years
ago, it was really early, the
tech was rough, we used our
stores as living labs that would
show us so we could get real
feedback from actual customers
and
employees, to create solutions
that work for our real people
and real customers.  We talked
about what we were doing loudly.
attention of that is to
attract more uncommon partners.
You know, the kinds of people
and organizations that you
wouldn't expect Lowe's to work
with.  To help us achieve this
narrative.   one of the earliest
partners to respond to the
call.  In the earliest days of
AR and VR we worked with Google
to push the future further,
faster.  In the second
generation, you can see in the
Holoroom, the Google cardboard
vending machine, that I love, to
give customers, the take away
VR experience.  It is not just
about creating stuff, but
creating stuff that works.
Really, it is not about VR and
AR.  This kitchen vignette is
what you typically see when you
come into one of the stores.
The benchmark is not what is the
best AR or VR experience.  It
is the way customers visualize
today that is decidedly low
tech.  When we build experiences
that are so far from today this
kitchen vignette, how do we
know it is working?  We quickly
found the right tools didn't
exist if people like something
they didn't experience  truly
new like Tango.  My background
is in behavioral science I
teamed up with partners from
academia to take the research
and turn it into an applied
neural science tool.  This
turned into neurons, Inc. can't
trust peoples stated reaction to
tech that is so new.  They say
I love it, take it off, never
put it on again. science allows
us to tap into the unstated
reactions through different
measures.  We use AR and VR
technologies and our studies
show the busy kitchen vignettes
were causing cognitive overload.
And as you can see here in
this bar.  low emotional
engagement and motivation.
Next, we tested all other VR and
AR tools.  They did better, but
still overwhelming.  When we
tested Tango early on for
customers, we saw for the first
time the optimal level of
cognitive interest, engaged,
motivated in a positive way, all
of this meant we hit upon a
truly intuitive  Last fall we
celebrated the first ever global
launch with the Lowe's global
app, at the same time, we
launched the Lenovo Phab 2 Pro
at low Lowe's.  Introducing
digital power tools.  The phone
sold out a few days after
launch.   selling phones.  Since
the vision we have had a
positive response from customers
who said how comfortable it is
to use this platform to design
their homes.  Now we're an early
partner in the positioning of
the stores.  In-store mapping to
help customers find products
faster.  Based on the positive
response, we are excited to
announce Google will map 400
more stores.  To give an example
of what it is like to use this
app in our store, checkout this
video.
Well, here we are inside.
are anything like me, you get to
these places and you are like
oh, my God, where do I even
start!? Fortunately have a Tango
phone that will help me get
from product to product by what
I need way faster than normal.
Let's have a look here.  Okay, I
will open up the Lowe's app
here, pull up my shopping list.
Now, this stuff is all over the
store and normally you would be
like where is and any of it?
With this, I can navigate and my
phone will tell me, we're over
this
way.  outdoor extension cord.
Okay, we got that.   Okay.  And
a number 9, pretty good.
Number 9, got it.  Oh, hey
there.  What are you doing here?
Shopping.  hex bolt.  Check!
Kyle: Great.
Thank you
thank you.  Thanks, man.
Thanks, Kyle.  Partners are a
critical component of the Tango
ecosystem and we're
thrilled to be working with
Lowe's.  common thread is
they're built on top of the
indoor environments and create
location-based AR experiences.
get into the details of how it
The visual positioning service
is comprised of mapping, Cloud
processing, client localization.
Now the first step is that of
creating a map.  So in a venue
which has given us permission,
such as this Lowe's store,
collection involves walking
through the store, through the
main pathways with the Tango
device.  With the wide angle
camera, with the Tango stack, it
creates a data set of the
environment you see on the
right.  The data is uploaded
into the Cloud.  Which brings us
to the second step.  The Cloud
processing pipeline.  So here's
a visualization of an
aggregation of all the different
mapping runs of the Lowe's
store.  We're computing the
points in the scene.  The data
sets are processed aligned and
then out into the Cloud map.
This is based on purely visual
feature tracking.  Doesn't need
blew tooth or Wi-Fi or GPS to
create this map.  Every capture
and recapture is incorporated
into the map and improves it.  A
note on side.  of the larger
venues on VPS is a shopping
mall.  square feet.  We use
1.3 million ski key frames, and
provide localization from a
centimeter to five centimeters.
This is a scaleable system to
tackle your living room but
massive indoor facilities.  Once
involve  -- VPS is completed,
then we can use it on any
device.  Let's return to the
SAMS Lowe's store.  This is a
video of a device localizing in
the Lowe's store.  You can
control permissions for GPS and
so too do you have control to
apps localized.  You need to
give the app permission to use
the camera and gamer positions.
Once it granted the
permissions, it is moving
through the environment to look
for visual features and map
those against the stored Cloud
map.  This provides continuous
adjustment and alignment between
the device's position and AR
content placed in that  So ...
VPS -- yeah.  Go forward
one all right.  VPS provides
you the developer, a coordinate
system to overlay digital
content into the real world.
The CAT scan of the mummy.  All
of the products in a Lowe's
store.  The treasure hunt in the
MGM Grand all use the same back
end service.   we have 150
buildings mand and running on
VPS.  So great.  You have
a little more information on
how is works.   you build for
it?   VPS is in private are
interested in developing, go to
the link and sign up for more
information as we bring more and
more developers to the platform
over the course of the coming
months.  But what you can do
today is build an AR app based
on the core capabilities.
tracking, depth sensing, area
learning, which are foundational
for creating great aerial
experiences.  The final step is
thinking about what would you
build if you had a persistent AR
layer over the world?  As you
saw at the keynote with
Expeditions when you create
experiences that allow multiple
people to have a shared
experience across multiple
devices, not only are you adding
it digital content to the real
world, but you are also adding
shared meaning to the
interactions among people.
believe that's one of the most
powerful aspects of AR.
for consistent and transient
maps of space, on which people
can experience the same or
content together.  is a tool
we're building to enable you to
create amazing location-based AR
experiences.  We can't wait to
see what you build on top of
this service.  Let's all aim to
build experiences which bring
our users joy, like
this.  So with that, I would
like to hand it back to Johnny
to talk about the future.
JOHNNY LEE: Thanks, Justin.
really great to see the past
year of progress we've made with
content partners and location
service over the past year.  But
I'd like to leave you with a
glimpse ahead.  this sample of
what we've been working on as
research projects either
internally or externally to
paint a little bit of the road
ahead.  Some of these are done
with partners.  Important to say
these aren't necessarily things
in the roadmap or know
determinant ship date, but a
sense of where things are going
over time.  So we can
(No dialogue)
(Applause)   JOHNNY LEE:
I think that drone video is
pretty sweet!  that's some of
the work we have been doing with
partners experimental and
research work.  But overtime, we
hope to start to bring more and
more into the platform so
people like you can use them.
the next 12 months, the team is
working hard to bring Tango
capabilities to more and more
devices.  Be they phones or
stand alone headsets.  We do
expect that number to grow
rapidly.  We do believe one day
all our phones will have some
form of this capability built
in.  As you see in the video,
the ability to have indoor
precise capabilities like VPS
will allow new types of spatial
computing, and in the wearable
space and in the future, robotic
platforms.   a lot of exciting
work to come.  Working with more
of you, the developers to
create new experiences to
enhance the way we play, the way
we shop and find a way in
stores or new ways of learning.
Tango allows us to interact
with digital content in a
physical way bringing new forms
of interMERSive computing.  For
more information go to our
website or consider joining our
goinggoing -- Google +
community.  for joining us.  the
rest of  Thank you for joining
this session.  Brand ambassadors
will assist in directing you
through the designated exits .
be making room for those
registered for the next session.
If you are registered for the
next session in this room, we
ask that you clear the room and
return via the registration line
outside.  Thank you.   of
.
Test test test test test test
test test test  .
.
4:30 session, build great
monetization with all new AdMob
.
Build
Great Monetization With All new
AdMob.
.
Sgll
Zeptolab
Bb
ingo Blast
Crina
ash Arena
.
4:30 session, Build Great
Monetization with All-New AdMob.
.
Read hot labs
Rbs rbs
.
Hello, everybody.  Thank you
for coming all the wait out here
.  We're in the furthest booth
here and it's a beautiful day.
Excited to have you all here at
IO  .
It's just incredible to see how
much apps have really taken off
and the functionality you guys
are delivering in the apps.
There's no question apps have
become an essential part of
everybody's daily lives now, and
that's great to see  .
Something my team is really
really happy about is we get to
be here with you, helping you
succeed here.  And we know this
because we're excited, we see
this number, we're at a million
apps across Android and Ios S
and it's very exciting for us to
see this kind of usage  .
So here's another number, we're
we're really proud of.
We paid out over $3 enough
and a half billion to
developers in ad revenue.  Gear
We're going to keep
investing in this platform and
make this number grow and grow
and continue to grow  .
So at Google we want to help you
develop your apps, grow your
users and earn.  And today we're
going to focus here on earn
because that's where AdMob can
help make a difference in your
business.  For some of you, NF
purchasing is something that
works really well
for monetization but for most
apps most users are not paying
and most are free downloads.
That means advertising is an
essential part for a lot of you.
So it's really our mission
here so really make the best 'd
ad experiences help      ap
and help developers succeed
as much as possible by
delivering those great
experiences to your users  .
These are questions we wake up
with every day.  We're always
thinking about this.  Sometimes
these questions keep us up very
late at night.  Things like is
there a better way to match ads
to users.  Portrait we some
#340er and more
more and more, is that the new
horz willing        ant
izontal.  Or how do I manage
regional networks that are
coming up, manage all of them
when I'm a small development
shop or use less engineers this
these large developers  .
Like these questions, they are
pretty important.  They really
do keep us up at night.  9
Because the thing is,
advertising is really about more
than just making money.  Like
advertise ing, we truly believe,
is what powrs the free and open
internet.  So if we get that
right, we'll enable more and
more apps to proliferate and
help you be successful
the free and open internet.  So
if we get that right, we'll
enable more and more apps to
proliferate and help you be
successful  .
Now, we know in very, very small
, small percentage of apps when
they are downloaded are paid for
.  That means most of the apps
that you guys are building right
now are probably free or fremiu
M,  m, somewhere in that area.
As users you probably love that.
I love that.  If you pulled
out your phone right now, I bet
almost all your apps are
probably fee.        free.
That's great for you and you and
you and me because we're
getting a lot of value for free.
But here's the challenge.  If
you switch to our developer hats
, that's        that statistic
doesn't look so good.  Right?
And that's really the challenge
.
So the thing that we're thinking
about here ask how         is
how can
we help you, A, get more paid
downloads, if that is the part
you're in, and at the same time
how can we work on that other 95
percent of users who don't pay
for your apps in general, and
how can we make money after
advertising for that group.  How
can we dough       do both at
the same time.  That's something
front and center in our minds
.
Here's one solution to this that
we have been investing quite a
bit in lately.  This is a
rewarded video ad and something
we launched on our platform
about a year ago.  And we worked
with a number of other partners
.  And just in March, that GDC
we announced we're going to
start serving ads as well from
the Google ad network  .
This is Zeptolab crash arena
turbo stars.  If you haven't
played, it's fun.  You design
your car and go is to bat
go to battle and have
these constant battled    s tles
.  In the game you want to have
a great car and you need parts.
Parts come in creates     ates,
and you urn the crates am   .
But when you sh the earn them
earn them, you
see the timer.  I have to 2008
two hours                two
wait two hours.  I can open now
by using gems, and gems cost
money, so thaths the      's the
ape     IAP side  .
I can skip by watching a video.
I think I watched 20 yesterday.
It hadn't     elped me move
through the timer.  Then I can
get my parts  .
Let's go ahead and click the
skip but the be.
button.  This is what happens.
We see the video, the timer on
the upper right, usually 30-
second video, an end card we saw
at the end, a call take action
on the bottom.  We're seeing
really good user engagement with
these ads  .
Maybe I click, maybe I don't
click.  Either way I'm happy
because I took 30 minutes off
the clock.  I feel like I got
value out of this ad, so that's
good for me.  And I'm leaving
this feeling happy and more
engaged, we move on from there,
I go e me         get my 30
minutes and we go on  .
Here's the thing.  This isn't
just about ad revenue because
the developer is making money
off of this.  But every time I
watch a video, I'm getting a
little bit more invested in this
game.  And that might drive me
ultimately to be more likely to
make in-app purchases  .
Here we have done something very
interesting.  We balanced, not
even billing   ed,   ing
balance but gotten the best of
both worlds, ad revenue as well
as more engaged users  .
Zeptolab introduced this and
once they introduced Google dae
manned, they              demand
they                 demand
they saw revenue go up 3X,
that's awesome stat.  More and
more droppers
developers who were strictly
in-app purchasing are now using
these kinds of strategic form
mats because it's helping both
the engagement as well as the
in-app purchasing  .
Now the but the         bulk of
these downloads we know are free
, and like I said, it's a very
small number at the top.  Also a
group down below that are sort
of business supported apps that
don't charge, but the bulk of
doundz        down leads we're
seeing today are free or fremu i
um, and this is really about
what we're seeing, a high- ,
high focus on developer
experience  .
Advertising maybe historically
was a little less focus on the U
X, so we have to find a way to
bring those two things together.
One of the ways we are doing
that is with native ads  .
Here we're seeing perfect
corporations 's u cam perfect
app, an app with well over 15
million downloads.  Met
Pretty impressive.  The button
on the left for the camera, the
next button over, you can edit
your camera, as I make myself
look a little more beautiful,
can't get enough of that.  And
also a collage.  And the lower
lefd      left all right
larger button, they have
taken a relevant app ad and
placed it right I   inside their
experience.  So it doesn't
really destroy the experience.
A lot of these developers are
lock      looking for something
that's seamless, it just fits in
well, matches the font and the
colors, et cetera  .
So you can expect to see a lot
more of these native ads as we
continue to drive into the
better UX experience going
forward
.
We have also been working on
some very interesting interest
novations in individual
know
interest
interest investigations in
individual
huge supply of the horizontal
videos advertisers have provided
because a lot of these came
from the desktop side and those
assets are all in place  .
We said gosh, a lot of apps now
are actually portrait.  We love
to see that mode but we don't
want the small portrait, we want
it big because we know if we
put big portrait, user
engagement is higher  .
We put our machines to work and
through fancy machine learning
managed to take these horizontal
videos that automatically
convert from horizontal right
over into portrait.  And that
means better user engagement,
better CPMs, better all the way
around  .
We've also found a way to reduce
a lot of niece videos
individual
these videos from 30
second        seconds
automatically again through
machine learning down to 30-
second shorts.  That means we
can produce and show a lot of
these videos in smaller places
and other places, for example, a
third area where we have been
working has been on cellular
networks  .
A lot of your yourself
users when using your
games are on sell rar
cellular networks.  You
month it want to show video ads
because engagement is high.
Over cellular networks that has
always been pretty hard.  We
found tricky innovations are
where we can deliver the
videos while the user is on a
cellular network, and that
really improves the number of
users that are seeing these
great ads  .
So as we see smart phones
continue to proliferate and as
we see internet coverage
continue to just grow and grow
and get cheaper and cheaper, you
expect to see a lot more videos
and a lot more innovations in
this format  .
Let's not forget about staples,
banners and interissuels
stitials.  One thing we
have introduced here at
innovation announced last March
is playables.  So these are like
fun interactive ads that go
right into an innerer stitial
space                 stitial
application             space so
the developer doesn't have to
do anything          anything
but the engagement is high.
That's good for a developer
because it makes you more money
.
So if you were a developer and
you're doing pretty well, and I
have this conversation a lot.
We have done so well in these
mature markets, but what do we
do now?  We're not seeing a lot
of growth.  How do we go about
it  ?
If I told you, if you took a
look at the top 1,000 gross
ad grossing apps that use
our platform, 95 percent of of
them are live in more than 200
markets.  Okay?  That's a lot.
That's a higher number than I
had expected.  But sort of
speaks to it  .
If you go further than that, out
of all of the revenue, 85
percent a   is not from their
home country.  But if you
remember apps, early days when
we released, home country and
maybe some countries with same
language.  But now it's really
just gone global, and so there's
one simple answer I have to
these conversations, which is if
you want to increase and mass
maximize revenue, a simple
thing you can do is go gll and
ol         global and go
clickly         quickly.  The
right partner with global reach
can help you  .
Further into the not too
distance  t future, the next
billion users coming on line
with smart phones, you know
where they are coming from?
They are coming from unsaturated
emerging markets  .
So the good news in there,
neither the           knee
the cost of acquisition in
mature versus emerging, very
different.  Much lower cost of
acquisition if you partner with
the right partner.  And also
that      in a loft      lot of
these markets you probably would
expect advertising is going to
play a more important part than
in purchasing.  Not for all of
them.  We see a skew across
countries, but for most of the
markets advertising will be
increasingly important  .
What does it all mean?  It means
that if you aren't releasing
globally, you're leaving serious
money on the table.  It also
means there's a whole new level
of complexity to your
advertising strategy.  Can you
imagine having to go country by
country and finding ad networks
that fit just that country and
lining that up with not just one
p your apps             of
yours apps but all of them and
manage ing across different form
mats where some networks fit
some formats but not others.
This can get come indicated
really quick
complicated
really quickly.  There has to be
a way to handle all this
complexity.  This is what we are
working on at AdMob, trying to
solve these global developer
challenges.  Global, we really
mean global  .
Because we're a single platform,
we're live in more than 200
countries, with a single click
we can push you out to all these
countries simultaneously.  So
that's great  .
We also have some big
announcements today, or
yesterday, around huh on
how to manage complexity in a
simple way across both developer
experience as well as mediation
groups  .
So one of my favorite things
about this job is I get to go
out and talk to developers and
learn from developers all the
time.  I have probably talked to
00s and        hundreds and
hundreds over the last couple
months and my team several
thousands, actual conversations.
And this is great.  We get a
lot of feed back, all positive,
I promise.  We're listening and
listening.  What      What with
can we do better, what are
your biggest challenges, what
can we do to hen   47 you
help you earn more money  .
We bucket those things in three
main areas.  First is around
just make it dead simple to get
started, get up and running, and
to manage this across the globe
.  When I'm talking about one
button, it works globally.  Help
me on that  .
Second area is really around
scale.  So I had one app and now
I need to get more specialized,
maybe a different
in different areas.  Maybe I
have a hundred apps now or 50 or
ten that's hard to manage.  So
help me on the scale problem
that I've got  .
The third area is, hey, I have a
lot of data now and Google, you
have a lot of
data too.  So can we maybe put
these things together and help
me optimize, maybe even more
revenue because we have the data
to do it, but it's hard and
there's a lot of logistics
around that data and so forth.
So let's work on optimize ing  .
So let's walk these
through these three areas  .
First wear      area is really
monetization, and this is always
the first priority a developer
has, let's get in there, get
started, get going.  The first
priority of the lockdown  .
Okay, so good
news here, and we think about
monetize, what can we do in the
background, things you don't
have to worry about?  We have a
lot of global advertisers, and
that's good because if you want
to go to a lot of countries you
need a network that reaches a
lot of countries.  So you need
the global advertisers.  And I
already mentioned we have a
million apps, but here is why
that matters.  It's because over
on the right side you see
there's at least a billion three
unique user devices that we
know about.  We know things
about them.  So that means when
we're trying to figure out which
ad to serve to that particular
moment, we're good at it and
we're getting better and
constantly learning from that.
And that means you can get
higher CPMs, means the
advertisers are targeting
exactly the people they want to
advertise.  So that connection
there is really a win-win for
advertisers and developers, and
we're going to keep pressing
that as hard as we can  .
And that's a great baseline but
there's a lot more we can
improve on, and this is where we
really put on our listening
ears  .
These are things that we heard.
Like can we make simpler on
boarding, make      maybe
progressive sign-up.  Can you
show me where the documentation
is.  Earlier or easier in the
process.  Things are still
reason able y con indicated.
This is tech and
only
complicated.  This is tech
and fast moving  .
Format coverage, we talked about
Nate of the           native,
rewarded.  Video especially we
want to see more and more  .
Can you simplify ad integration
even more and make testing easy.
I want to see exactly what I
have got  .
The thing we heard the most was
really about faster access and
like can you quickly show me how
well I'm doing?  I want to see
how much money I'm making and if
I'm missing, if I'm not
missing, et cetera.  Really
quickly all in one place  .
These are the main things that
we heard.  So we went right to
work on this stuff  .
This is what we have been doing
the last 12 months.  Introducing
AdMob beta.  Yesterday we went
live with this in the afternoon,
we announced it.  This is an
entirely new user experience for
you.  We took a hard, hard look
at all the developer journey
and figured out through that
what can we do to make this as
easy as possible  .
Yes, you can go to AdMob right
now and sign up and go through
this experience because it is in
fact live  .
So why don't you come on up, aly
, and we're going to go to a
like demo.  That means I'm
slightly
nervous
and we're going to go to a like
demo.  That means I'm slightly
nervous.
.
Lrlt,
All right, here we are on AdMob.
com and looking
at read hot          red hot
lacks.  They are look
bs.  And they are
looking at Bingo Blast.  It has
about a million downloads,
30,000 five-star ratings,
available in the IOS store as
well as Google Play.  It uses IP
and also an interest of stitial
stitial.  First
thing you notice is the gray bar
across the top.  Now this is
the all-in-one immediately
#40u78        how am I doing,
give it to me straight.  We can
see the last 28 days, on the
right you Sue they made
see they made $   $1.
52 million, so that's
thousand         ,000,
so that's pretty good  .
How is our fill rate doing,
that's good.  I have inventory,
are you serving ads into them?
We're seeing about 99.4 percent
fill rate.  That's pretty darn
good  .   .  Definitely higher
than most of the industry.  You
also see ECPM around $   $19.33,
that's also looking pretty good
.  So we have a pretty nice
looking app here, it's going on
.
Now this is a pretty simple
account.  If you were just
getting started, this is the
kind of thing you would probably
see when you get going.  So why
don't we switch over to
something that as you're growing
, maybe a slightly more
sophisticated account  .
Here we're looking at the lab
pixies account.  They are based
in Israel, and as you can see
from the currency.  They have
dozens of apps in the Google
Play store and ap    app store.
You see the dashboard.  For
them this is a nice unified view
as well because they are able
to collect a lot of apps all in
into one space.  You're
going to see as you have more
and more apps, AdMob becomes
more and more powerful for you,
and you're going to see these
dashboard cards, these cards on
the right, as you use more
features, more of these cards
start to appear, cards that are
relevant to what you are doing
.
Now lab pixies use some of their
older apps.  Across the bottom
here you can see older apps to
test out some of these new ad
for me mats             formats
and different experiences.  Some
are tests, maybe not doing as
well as we saw on the Bingo
Blast side  .
We also if you look at this
performance side, you see the
match rate, not exactly the same
.  I wonder what's going on.
That's a little bit different.
CPMs are quite a bit different
than we saw on bg  Bingo Blast,
then over on the right we're
using mediation, and here's one
space where you can see all of
the different mediation we're
using, all in single place, how
they are each performing, again
all in one place  .
Right now let's go back to this
bottom left.  The top
performance, color grips and
flood it and also the selector
here.  So you know what, let's
take a look at our top and
bottom movers, see who has moved
a lot  .
This is one of the things I
heard over a   and over in my
discussions.  Have I all these
apps,                          I
have       .  I have all these
apps, data across all these
twoeshgs        networks.  Can
you tell me who is making more
a lot more and lot less so
I can pay attention?  You
should be able to detect that  .
We built the functionality.  We
see color drips kap 12,
something               kap
Color Drips.
They have done a good job.
Something flooded.  Something
not add     as good.  This
highlighting, really heard happy
we have this in the brawn  .
breakdown  .
We can invest sgat what is going
igate what is
going on there in a second.
Before we do that, let's go over
to the app selector.  I'm
looking at this left nav bar.
One thing we realized is that
wean      when you're working
and manage you     ing your apps
, sometimes you're very focused
on one app.  Sometimes you're
focused on all of your apps at
the same time, you want to do
something and just apply all the
way across the board  .   .  So
we    we split out the two
different works       work flows
to get them in here to match
exactly how you work  .
When we're thinking about the
one app side you can see all the
different apps, switch for the
apps you want.  Some of these
lists are thousands long.  You
can really imagine the scale.
So click and select  .
You see below if I skip down,
some       some account level
things like reports and
mediation.  We also heard things
like ad controls and payments,
I need really quick access to
that no matter where I am.  We
brought that right to the front
.
Then since we clicked on an app,
that section expanded right
below color drips
Color Drips and you see all
the relevant things you want to
do with the app right there.  On
top of that we're now in an app
pf specific             46
specific            -specific
dashboard.  Before we had the
account specific, now we're in
app specific thing showing
everything #457g       happening
with this specific app and
seeing everything at an a
glance  .
Here werg      we're seeing our
dashboard across the top, again
in gray.  What's nice about this
is you see an I          see
across all of the networks all
in one place what's happening.
You also see a total revenue
card, and you can see that
revenue over the last seven days
versus last week, .  We can
also expand out to 28 days, see
what's going on, and we see,
okay, interesting.  So we had a
really good week last week, not
sure what's happening in the two
weeks before that.  Think we
might have taken our ad unit
down.  We put it back up, maybe
re    we ran a promotion, et
cetera
.
We also see the network
performance down at the bottom
and we see how we're doing here.
We have match rate of about 95
percent, so not as good as the
last one at 99, but still pretty
good.  CPM, 33.  Probably
because we're showing a lot more
impressions  .
I'm also looking now at the
bottom right card.  This card
basically says, so there's a
network we're using there, but
we're seeing a lot of queries go
in but not a lot of impressions
.  So that's something we should
probably go investigate, and we
can take you right there  .
What's great about this, we
surfaced this insight to your ad
ops.  This is not something
engineering had to go do.  This
is something instantly available
.
Why don't we click on that
report and go right into
that.  So here we're looking,
let's see, let's go ahead and
take a look at the last seven
days and see what was going on
here  .
The last seven days, okay, this
is interesting.  We weren't
getting any impressions through.
That's not so good.  So let's
zoom back out to 28 or 30 days
and     and see what was going
on.  Yeah, last 30 days.  We had
some impressions going through,
still a little concerned here
it's not as high as I would have
expected.  That's not a good
fill rate.  Something is off  .
What's nice is when we clicked
that go see this report, it puts
some filters in place for us
automatically.  We didn't have
to type all the filters in, just
went straight in to say this is
color dripts  s           Color
Drips, this network, let's take
a look  .
I don't know if this is a color
drips           Color Drips
problem or total network problem
, so why don't we get rid of the
color drips           Color
Drips filter to see how this it
total network is doing  .
Okay, so here I'm seeing
thousands of impressions are
going through.  So the network
looks like it's performing okay.
What we have a problem then
that must be not in these other
apps but in this ap specifically
.  That's good Intel.  I can now
go find an engineer and say
okay, I know where the problem
is, something is wrong in this
app, with this           in the
configuration, go solve this
problem.  So that's a lot of
power that historically was
something hard to go surface  .
To summarize here, all across
this U
I (feedback)  .
All right, can we switch
over to the station  ?
To summarize here, we have got a
n app centered front-end actual
dashboard, intuitive navigation.
Ladies and gentlemen, sorry,
that was the emergency channel.
Continue with the presentation.
We will let you know with any
updates.
Okay, intuitive navigation and
richer insights.  These are a
lot of good features.  We are
very proud of this user
experience improvements  .
Now let's move to scale.  So you
have had some success, you have
grown let's say from one app
immensely successful.  You're
trying to specialize.  Or you
have sgroen thousands
grown thousands, and we
have seen this, smaller apps all
together and got to the same
place of success.  How do you
manage all that?  You need a
partner not just an ad network,
you need a platform you can grow
grow with.  And that's
what we are focused on right now
.
In the past some of on you
our bigger partners, I
talked to partners who are
had 30, 40 engineers working
just on things like extracting
data from websites, from
different networks, putting
them, transferring over county
ry by country, inputting,
coming back and hobble ing
together all these things.  We
looked and said gosh, do you
want that many engineers
spending that much time on that?
Their answer was of course we
don't, we'd really        rather
use those engineers to make
apps and make our apps better
and make the apps fit better and
improve and compete in the
market  .
We basically said, okay, we know
we can fix this.  This is a new
problem.  It's a scale problem
because of your success.  So
let's get right to work on that
.
The first thing we did is we
made it interest
enterprise scale.  So we knew we
had to handle thousand ngdz of
s of apps and went right
to work to do that and we still
maintain a reputation for
stability.  Something we hear
about often  .
Second thing, we said okay,
you're at scale, you're global,
you want lots of networks.  So
we provide support to over 40
mediated networks.  If that's
not enough, we have custom
network support  .
Third thing is we said with a
lot of those networks, why don't
we pull in the information so
you can get at    all of that
information in one place.  So we
have been supporting over 20
networks  .
Fourth thing we did is we
enabled campaigns.  What are
campaigns?  If you have got one
app and you grow ten and you
want to cross promote your apps,
the developers are saying yeah,
I want to use my own ads.  And
one thing that's really nice
about this campaign's capability
is you don't have to build out
your own ad serving
infrastructure or build in
specific ads into a release and
change into the next release.
Here you do an ad slot and you
can manage those from the server
side very sem     simply  .
But we knew there was more that
we could do, so again we took to
the spreadsheets
treets, asked the
questions and said, we know we
can manage, we have problems the
user said, we want to be able
to manage mediation more rapidly
, we want more reporting detail,
we want more of this inbound
aggregation so we don't have to
go site to site, and we want
we want some of us
launched on other platforms
before you had rewarded ads, can
you give us more DAPPers
adapters  .
Good news is we're solving each
and every one of these things.
And I want to talk about
mediation groups.  I'm going to
switch over to demo.  Mediation
groups, I'm really proud to
announce this.  This was a tough
one.  It's a powerful new
capability so you don't have to
manage hundreds or thousands of
mediation chags  ins.  Instead
the concept here is take one
unique combination of ad network
lists and countries and apply
all of your ad units to that one
thing.  You don't have to
create over and over and over.
When you make changes it's just
to that one  .
As you will see, this medation
groups, it really takes this
issue head on.  So first you'll
see we went ahead and clicked on
mediation over the left, and
that's how we got     go the to
this screen.  We're going to go
ahead and see this in action.
Let's create mediation
group  .
As I mentioned, some of these
developers are using this for
dozens or hundreds or thousands
of apps.  First you choose a
format.    and platform.  The
reason those two you choose
first, the mediation groups you
tend to make specific to the
format on the platform  .
Let's go ahead and create a
title now.  We'll call this one
android banners and high CPM
countries  .
We're going to choose which
countries, and we can include or
exclude, so we'll choose the
U.S. and high      how about the
U.K. maybe, Japan, high CPM
countries in general.  We're
going to go ahead, we have our
countries, let's add ad units to
the immediate ation
mediation chain  .
Here's what's great.  It can be
across all your apps, they can
attach to the same one.  Do your
home work on which ones you
want, attach these apps with
different ad units into here.
Now we have that group set up.
Now we need to say what's the
order of networks we want to
serve.  We already see ad  AdMob
is in there, and now we're
going to add another network.
So why don't we add, all right,
just shoes       choose one.
One for unity, sound good     s
good.  We can choose to optimize
, which is this automated
concept I was talking about
where we pump      pull the data
automatically and ordering is
done for you, which is awesome,
or we can go ahead and manually
specify this.  Sometimes we
manually specify at the front in
case the credential is not
working right  .
We continue and then we insert
our ad unit ID.  Unity is going
to see here's an ad unit for
this one, here's one for that ad
.  It's important these things
are kept separate so we optimize
for each one.  They are going
to give different performance.
We want to optimize for every
unit.  We save that and now we
have a mediation chain.  All
right, so that's it.  It's that
simple.  We did this across all
our apps for that chain  .
So we see we have four different
mediation groups.  We can dive
right in and see what's there.
We can also see how these guys
are doing across by just
clicking and dropping that down.
And we know, so we just did
that group to people that serve
U.K., U.S. fshths jap
, Japan.  There's other groups
serve different formats in
different countries.  If nobody
is caught we have AdMob to catch
everything at the end  .
We also have this, let's see,
consolidated view of what's
going on.  You see that bar
across the top, this gives you
queries, impressions and fill
rates.  That's across everything
.  We have done some really hard
tricky math to make sure when
we say queries, we mean queries.
We don't mean double and
triple counting.  That's really
confusing when you have a bunch
of network calls all happening
for the same impression, how to
add those up and not duplicate
or triple count  .
We have the network at the top,
a feature you asked for  .
Also the possibility that you
have got, you know, let's say
someone has come in and said hey
, I have a deal for you, $
$20CPMs, put me in there.  We
add that network.    pretty
easily to our mediation chain.
Or if the network is already in
there, yeah, let's go right in
there, let's modify the network,
let's put $   $20CPMs in, .
And yeah, let's go down and
change this unit, we change it
here and instantly that's done
.
That's powerful.  Again across
all the apps  .
Another thing let's say we want
to add another app with a new ad
unit and we have done the hard
work with the immediate ation
modation chain.
We take the ad unit and attach
to the same mediation unit we
already had.  Let's go ahead and
add an ad unit from tripero,
add that unit, add it, game I.D.
, again the placement I.D., and
we're done just like that.  So
we took all of the networks
across the globe, packed it into
that one change and we're done.
It's a really, really good way
to save hours and hours that we
have seen in the market  .
You just have seen this in
action.  Let's go ahead and flip
back to the deck.  We're
continuing to work on these
features, simplify ied
management.  We're also loeg you
to call these
allowing you to
allowing you to all
these other networks multiple
times.  We're up to 20    25
networks where we can pull in
data automatically  .
We have inbound adapters for
three networks, we just added
fiber  .
Let's move right over to
optimize.  This is something
where we have data, you have
data, let's put it together.
First thing we know is if you're
using mediation, we have this
real time ECPM capability, a
single click that lets 's us bid
into every option.  If we think
key with make you more money,
we'll give you more money.
That's been seen to really
improve performance  .
Second thing is we have these
optimize refresh banners.  If
you have banners, you probably
notice the speeds on the refrish
are changing.  Why should we
ask you to run all these A-B
tests.  We have a lot of data on
this.  We're automatically
changing this if you opt in.  We
see if we pick the right bans
ers and the right amount of
time, you get better performance
.
Third thing is the dynamic
allocation for your campaigns.
Maybe you want to show a million
impressions or ten percent.
But you don't want to lose out
on these really high value
options.  This dynamic
allocation let's you keep those
high value options that make
money and still serve the goals
you're trying to do  .
Here I want to, we're basically
again, we took to the streets,
these are some problems that we
found.  It's really around
complexity of revenue streams
across these different units.
So I want to introduce you to
this new two-way integration
with AdMob and Firebase we
announced yesterday.  We're
going to dive right in and see
this thing in action  .
First thing you see is this apps
dashboard.  This is a revenue
card.  Here's what's awesome.
You have AdMob revenue in blue,
you've got mediation revenue
from other networks in red, and
in yellow you have in-app
purchase revenue all    , all in
one place.  Okay, this is hard.
And it's really because of the
marriage of Firebase, which is
bringing in the in-app purchase,
and our network optimization
products, which are bringing in
the external, and we put it all
in one place  .
Also we have this other card
which is about user metrics.  So
we're pulling this data in from
Firebase.  You have some really
interesting new metrics like ad
exposure, how much are my users
actually seeing right now, ads
versus the app.  You see 11
percent in this case.  With
banks       banners sometimes
you see much higher.  You can
see when it's high or low and
notice might not
things might not be
functioning correctly.  You can
see experiments are they helping
or hurting, retention and
average sessions, all here on
your dashboard  .
So we're going to run a very
fast
demo.  We  This is an account,
a complicated account.  You have
got the flooded app, you have a
lot of advertising data, not a
lot of IAP  .
You see 46 percent ad exspoe
posure, which is pretty common
for banners.  And why don't we
flip right over to a different
kind of account.  This is a
different one, this is Bingo
Blast.  You see it's really
about IAP and interstitials only
.  A lot of IAP you see in red,
you see ad units exposure 0 pay
58 percent, that's
.58 percent.
That's an interesting number I
didn't know.  Maybe we can grow
higher because we also see if
you scroll down we're at 99
percent fill rate.  I bet we
could increase exposure, drop
fill rate, and clegsly watch
closely watch how
long the sessions are per user
and retention and see if that's
working or not  .
That's a pretty powerful way to
manage your business and this
automatically comes as soon as
you integrate Firebase, very
simple, link the accounts.  This
data automatically flows in.
You don't have to set anything
up  .
That's a powerful innovation
we're very proud to show you.
We flip back over, and we'll go
ahead and wrap up
.
A lot of things to show on the
AdMob and Firebase integration.
We have some great partners and
some tremendous results so far.
It's simplifying.  They had a
lot of engineers working on or
just not doing.  We're giving
you that power  .
Again, Monday        moig with
monetization with
this new beta re    we released,
mediation groups,
and Google Analytics for nier
base           Firebase.  We're
looking for new ideas.  If you
have things you want to tell us,
please reach out  .
This is what it's all about,
make developers like you as
successful as possible, give you
the best ad experiences
possible  .
Tomorrow morning 8:30-9:30 is a
session solely on Firebase and
AdMob integration.  Office hours
right now, and code lab
happening tomorrow morning 9:30-
12:30 with people onsight to
walk you                 -site
20 walk         to walk you
through native and rewarded.
Those range half hour to an hour
.  A Firebase analytics
presentation an is well  .
Thank you very much, really
appreciate you being here.  If
you have questions, I'll go
ahead and stay after.  Thank you
.
Thank you for joining this
session.  Brand ambassadors will
assist with directing you
through the designated exits.
We'll be making room for those
who have registered for the next
session.  If you have
registered for the next session
in this room, we ask that you
please clear the room and return
via registration line outside.
Thank you  .
(End of session)
.
5:30 session, getting your
assistants app
Getting
Your Assistants App discovered
Discovered
.
Assistant App
Is a
.
seats near the front of the room
.  Thank you
.
Welcome, thank you for joining.
Our session will begin soon
.
STAGE 4
GETTING YOUR ASSISTANT APP
DISCOVERED
T428DD
.
VALERIE NYGAARD:  Hello,
welcome.  For those that are
here live, it has been a long
day, and you are like the
endurance athletes of IO attende
es  .
I'm very impressed that you are
still here and still going, it's
like let's go, lets 's here it,
it's awesome  .
All right, so if you didn't
attend the earlier session that
is basically about building a
assistant apps or you vrn
experienced one, here is the 30-
second overview.  This is
something the developer
communities builds to extend the
assistant and basically connect
with users directly through the
assistant on the platforms
where the assistant exists  .
This is a representation of an
eyes flee one you
might                    free
when you might interact with on
Google home, and this is one you
might interact with on the
phone  .
That's Assistant Apps in 20
seconds.  If you haven't build
one or even if you have, have
if you haven't watch the
build an Assistant App talk it's
fantastic.  You will be
impressed to see building one
that's transactional even in
like ten minutes.  So go do that
.  If you are watching on a
stream, go do that now.  If you
are here, #125i       stay here.
We will keep going  .
So we have had a ton of fun
interacting with developer
community, building these first
Assistant Apps
assistant apps in the ecosystem.
It's been great to see how
creative people have been, how
they are trying to push the
boundaries of this early system.
We get some   ubmissions that
are funny and submissions that
are useful and submissions that
are a little note,   na
nauql #2shgs        hty, a
variety and it's great  .
This session is going to focus
on a particular aspect , and
that is discovery.  Specifically
that's a user thing.  You want
users to be able to discover the
hard work you have been doing.
So we're going to start today
from the user perspective  .
This is Jane.  She is our user.
While I'm introducings people,
I thought I would mention I'm
Valerie, one of your speakers.
I'm on the product team and this
is Rob, one of the engineering
leaders on the assistant  .
Back to Jane.  Jane wants to
know what she can do with the
Google assistant.  She wants to
know all the things Google did
help her with and very much
wants to know about all the
stuff that you can help her with
, right?  And we want that too.
We all want easy discovery for
Jane.  We are in this together
like you and us and Jane all
like swimming in the same, I
don't have a good analogy, but
all on the same page, going to
the same goal.  We're in it
together, we all want the same
thing  .
So let's help Jane discover you.
We're going to frame this in
three sections.  We're is going
to listen to what Jane is
explicitly asking for.  We're
going to infer a little bit
about what she wants when she
says what she wants to do,
expressions an intent.  And
sometimes we're going to do
something delightful for Jane.
And to talk about these first
two is Rob.
All right.  Thanks a lot,
Valerie  .
What I'm going to begin with is
the most basic form of discovery
.  We call this expression
plicit triggering.  It's
whenever a user invokes an app
directly through its name  .
So let me shift over to the
phone view and show you a
n example.  Talk to fit star
Fit Star.
Here is fifth star
kap                fifth
Starr             fit star
Fit Star.
This talk to app name pattern
is special.  We apply this to
every single ape automatically.
By default when the user uses
this particular pattern we
connect right to that particular
app.  So as a develop        er
developer, this is the
phrases you want to use in
advertisements when you are
instructing users how to start
up your app.  It's, however,
pretty basic.  Mostly whenever
users start up your app, they
want to jump right into an
activity.  So let me show you
another example of an explicit
trigger
.
Ask fit start         Fit Start
to start a workout.
Sure, here's fit start
Fit Start, let's start with a
seven-minute workout.  Up next.
Let's switch back to the
slides  .
What I should here was an action
phrases         phrase, start a
work joup.  You can add an
action
out.  You can add an
action phrase and it stream
lines the users       user's
actions.  They are able to start
up the app and jump right into
an activity  .
One thing to be careful about,
there can be many different
versions of this action phrase,
so you're not always guaranteed
the trigger on here.  When you
set up action phrases, be sure
to test them out and make sure
they do trigger all the way
through  .
I can show you how to set up an
action phrase now.  If our a
developer that works directly in
the action packages, what you
want to do is find the intent
that you want to connect the
particular action phrase to,
then go to the trigger stanza  .
In
Inside the twigger stanza query
patterns you can list out all
the different action phrases
that you want.  For instance you
see start a work joup is there
out is there.  If
you're a developer that works
with API.AI it's a very simple
two-step process to set up an
action phrase.  Similar to the
action package, you go to your
intent, the target intents page,
then you list out the action
phrase        phrases in the
user says examples  .
That is step one.  Then step two
you go to the actions on Google
integration page, and you add
your target intent as an
additional triggering intent.
This will set up the action
phrase for API.AI  .
Another thing to note about
setting up explicit triggers,
whether you are using action
packages or API.AI, your final
step will be to go to your
console page.  Then list out of
the five examples invocations
using your explicit triggering
patternsment be    be sure to
check all the pat earns
terns do trigger your
action.  This is really
important because we take these
five sample invocations, and we
actually put them on your app's
directory page.  So here I have
pictured the direct ty page for
fit star        Fit Star.  You
see toward the bottom there's
the ask your assistance  t
section.  This lists out all the
different sample invocations
that are provided, and it's
really important for discovery
for     because users are going
to be browse ing for apps inside
the directory.  They could
immediately try the app via the
try it button, but moreover we
want them to see how to invoke
this sometime in the future when
they are away from the
directory  .
That's all very nice whenever
the user remembers your app's
name or knows about your app.
But let's go back to a case
where Jane doesn't even know
about your
app or can't remember the name.
This is the portion of
discovery that we really want to
make well because we think this
can     will make all the
difference in the world as far
as getting exposure for apps  .
What we're doing is we're
building new algorithms so users
can use     just express their
intent.  They don't have to use
an app name.  They can express
what they want to do.  Partner
ing with you, I'll talk in a few
slides about ways you can help
this, partnering with you, we'll
be able to take their general
intent and match it to the most
relevant app  .   .  We call
this implicit triggering.  And
let's go ahead, actually let me
show you one example first here
still  .
Here's an example, Jane wants to
do a workout session and says
give me a workout.  We actually
do a little bit of implicit
triggering today.  It looks like
what I have pictured on the
screen here.  We'll look at that
intent and then we'll find a
matching app, and just ask Jane
if she wants to connect to that
app.  Here we said do you want
to talk to fit start         Fit
Start, and Jane can say yes or
no  .
Let's now go to the phone view.
I want to show you something
we're working
on.  Give me a workout
.
Okay, I have a couple of
options for that.  Fit start kap
12 and five-minute
And Five-minute,
which would you like to try?
Okay, a subtle difference here
.  What we're doing, we're
working on algorithms to find
the high quality matching apps
for a particular intent, then we
want to display them in a nice
visual manner that gives the
user some queues about what the
app does and allows the user to
sleshg        select it very
easily  .
I think we can really use this
to increase the exposure of apps
to the user and also satisfy
users' needs much better because
they are just able to start off
with a general intent  .
Can you go back to the slides?
Okay  .
Seeing this, probably a natural
question you have is how does my
app get into this list and how
is this list ordered  .
So what we have to do here is a
ranking problem, very system rar
to what                 imilar
to what we have done in web
search.  Many of the principles
apply, but this is a brand new
ecosystem and we still need to
figure out new ways to play
these principles, we need to
figure out what signals are
important, the ecosystem.  So
this is still very much a work
in progress  .
If I can give you a hint how we
think about this, we think about
our users, we think about what
has Jane done in this context in
the past.  We also think about
what do all of our assist tapt
ant users do in this type
of context.  We also take
advantage of Google's reach and
also look at what users in other
properties like Google search
or Google maps do in this
particular could be
context.  Together this gives us
a set of signals that we can
then we've       we've   ave
together into ranking algorithms
to find the most relevant apps
for the user's intent  .
How can you help us here?
Remember this action package
with the action phrases I showed
a couple of minutes ago?  It's
good to pay attention here.
Write out useful action phrases
that describe what happens in
your app.  If you think about
these, these are just natural
wlang expressions
language                language
expressions of your app's xap
capability.  We can use
these in our matching and
ranking algorithms  .
Another thing helpful to help
with your discovery is go ahead,
if you have an associated
website or soon an associated
Android app, go through the
brand verification step in your
app console.  This let's us
establish a link between your
assistant app and your web page,
and in the near future also any
any of your Android apps  .
As I mentioned, part of our rank
ing eight right
algorithms will look at some
of the other properties like
Google search and maps and
search,         such, and this
will allow you     us to
establish connection between the
signals.  Together working on
action phrases, giving us some
of this information about your
connected sites, this can all
help with your discovery  .
That's a quick overview of what
we're trying to do to make it
much easier for Jane to express
in a natural way that they want
to use a particular app or just
a particular intent.  We want to
go way beyond this, and we
actually are working on other
discovery means that will help
Jane even figure out things they
she didn't know could be
done on our platform
her platform  .
I'm going to hand back to value
rye         Valerie right now so
she can go over these.
VALERIE NYGAARD:  Thanks  .
Okay, so I'm a huge fan of the
implicit triggering that Rob was
talking about.  But what we
want to talk about next is some
kind of juice y like on the
front lines, ienlts        it's
coming and in development kind
of stuff.  Most of you     what
you will see next is
directional, but we really
wanted to share it so you have a
n idea how we are thinking about
things and what we expect to
come next  .
Center dip to us
going to talk about it in
dialogue when Jane is interact
ing through the assistant, and
talk about it over the
conversation stage
off the
covering stage  .
conversation stage  .
On the conversation stage first.
Let's say Jane has a request
in mind.  Let's say it's a very
typical request for someone to
ask Google about.  So for
example, Jane wants to know
about the red cat       Red Cat,
a restaurant in no,     New
York.  She says, tell me about
the red cat       Red Cat  .
We're going to give her the
information she's going to ask
for, of course the first thing
we want to do.  But she might
also be dwlieted
delighted if we give her some
other ways to continue the
conversation, especially some
ways to take action that's surp
relevant.                  super
relevant.  You see some
suggestions on the bottom about
booking a table, getting
pictures.  In another scenario
you might see menus, directions,
other similar restaurants,
things like that.  Actually you
may have seen this in production
today  .
This happens to be Google going
to Google, but we want this to
extend to developer created
features.  So if you are
watching the keynote and you
were really paying attention to
this really cool demo using
Google lens, so my colleague eb
Ebar pointed the camera via
assistant at an markuis and the
assistant under studz this is a
band and offered some nice
follow on actions about hearing
the mice      music or adding to
the calendar  .
Right in the middle there is
getting tickets from ticket
master             Ticket
Master, one of our partners on
actions on Google.  This is the
kind of thing we want to do,
right?  So again, Jane has
something in mind, right?  She's
trying to save this or hear the
music, whatever she's trying to
do.  We're saying okay, did you
want to buy tickets?  This is
not intrusive, this is not
invasive, this is not insistent.
It's just assistive and there
for Jane if she wants it.  Right
?  So we really want to be able
to understand what are the
actions that your assistant app
can do so that we can offer it
up in situations like these and
see how it goes
.
We even of course want to
combine this with what Rob was
talking about earlier, about
giving you a provider selection.
Right?  Let's get to the
beginning of the video and walk
through it  .
Let's say Jane wants pizza
delivery, again pretty common
query.  She chooses a restaurant
and decides to place order.
That was the first suggestion.
Then she has a couple of
providers.  So in Jane's mind
she is basically like, oh, I is
can actually place the order
.  Oh, I have a choice of
providers.  This is what we want
.  It's not forced discovery,
it's just contextual  .
All right, how do you get into
that?  Before I go on, how do
you get into that?  It's the
same basic stuff that Rob was
talking about.  Give us some
clues about what your app can do
, and we'll try to help take it
you   from there  .
That's in the conversation
station         stage  .
When Jane is elsewhere, for
example you may have seen the
new explore tab in the assistant
experience
Assistant
Experience  .
If we can go to the phone.  In
the upper right-hand corner on
the top there               I'm
going to tap there and get into
this experience.  This is a nice
browse experience that let's
lets our user see some
things they she can do.  There's
our fit star kap 12.   2
Fit Star.  She can
browse and see things that are
her fafrnts     vorites, things
that are recent.  If she goes
into fit star        Fit Star
again, one of the things you saw
Rob show, these guys in the
center of the screen, these
sample invocations that will
appear for her, of course this
is something our approvers do
des     test, so you want
to make sure these
work.  These are invoke ready
ily.  If I tap into this, this
will take us into the fit star
experience  .
I'm not going to do that this
second because I want to talk
about one more thing here.
Having an attractive and appeal
ing and concise picture and
especially the text explanation
here is not just for the
purposes necessarily of a user
browse ing on the surface.  This
is also a signal that is the
kind of signal that Google likes
to understand what your app
does.  Right?  So think about
what you're going to put here.
Think about something that's
going to make sense to users
right off the bat.  Think about
something that we might be able
to understand is something that
your app can fulfill.  Just have
a   it think about what goes in
a
think about what goes in here  .
Think we can go back to the
slides.
Great  .
Marketing!  .
Sometimes we show case you.  We
are looking for people to show
case.  We are looking for
experiences that we think our
yourself will be attracted to
and want to do.  And we want to
shout about them.  Again, we
want you discovered.  Right?  So
newsletters and blog posts and
tweets and all of the above the
line marketing that we have, we
want to be able to feature your
experiences.  So what I'm going
to tell you next is one of the
ways that we figure out like how
can we decide who to feature  .
It is absolutely true that
Google does all the things that
Google is known for, right?  We
are looking at all the user
signals we see in the wild.
Repeat usage, daily active
users, looking at if someone
goes into your experience, did
they appear to have a good
experience, did they appear to
leave early, all these things
are of course things we are
observing, but I wanted to let
you know that we are early in
this ecosystem and also making
somewhat call      qualitative
judgments about deciding this as
well  .
You all know that we have
approvers that are in our queue
and we have of course a lot of
product people and engineers,
the whole team thinking about
what are the fantastic
experiences here.  These are the
questions that we ask ourselves
.  When I go through an
experience, I think, I see all
those cameras going up, good.
So like these are the things
that I think about.  Did I smile
?  Did I laugh?  Did I learn
something?  Did I learn
something interesting?  Would I
tell someone?  Would I tell
someone right now, would I call
them, gosh, check this out.
Would I use it again?  Would I
use it everyday?  Did it get
better for me over time?  Can it
pick up why I left off?  Did it
do what I expected?  Did it act
as advertised?  Right  ?
All of these kind of things are
things we're thinking about, so
I'm not saying like we're
marking this down and feeding
into rfrng       ranking
directly.  What I'm talking
about is really about feature
ing.  But when you think about
your experience, and before you
hit submit, okay, you should be
asking yourself these questions.
If you have anyone that can
dog food for you, whether you
work at a big organization where
you have a big trial and
testing or dog food program or
you got a buddy that can try out
your app for you, ask these
questions to them and to
yourself.  If you went through
your entire experience and it
did not make you smile or did
not do something useful for you
or you did not learn anything,
you may have a little ways to go
before this is going to be like
taking the world by storm  .
What you say     see in gray or
black on the the bottom is also
some things we look at in terms
of conversational hygiene, right
?  So was I as a user just
confused at any point.
Especially when talking about a
voice driven product.  If you
don't know what to say, it's
really difficult to recovery.
Right?  So when you are building
for the phones, those
suggestion chips are really
critical.  Like help the user
out.  When you are talking about
the eyes free experience, get
them to a place where they kind
of know how they should be
responding  .
Did I have to repeat hiefs?
myself?  Did it feel slow
?  I'm not talking about system
slowness.  Of course everybody
wants everything to be faster.
But really did it feel like your
app responded slowly?  Really
think about that  .
Then final there are two pieces
of hygiene that if you went to
any of the Louie design talks
I'm positive you heard.  We
erred       refer to them as no
match and no input.  Okay, no
match is when the user says
something that your app didn't
expect.  What did you do?  Did
you like reframe the question so
that they felt like they had
another chance to answer nicely?
Or did you just repeat exactly
what you said before?  That has
a really big impang in how
ct in how your app feels
conversationally  .
When the user department respond
didn't re
sdvent respond fast
enough so there's a time ount,
out, or you didn't get an
input and no response, did you
have a conversationally
appropriate recovery from that.
Please think about those things
before you're thinking about
like how many action phrases can
I load into my action package
that I trigger all the time.
That's like not the right way to
think about it, right?  The
right way to think about it is
give us some things that you
think are really, really salient
.  We will notice if you give us
a bunch of things that are not
really salient.  Right?  And
make your app something that
people really want to come back
and use  .
There are a ton of design
resources.  Absolutely a ton.
Some great talks here that you
can find.  And there are also a
ton of resources on generally
building assistant apps.  So I
look forward to seeing what you
all do.  I'm going to leave you
with a basic checklist.  Four
items, four calls to action for
you to do  .
To be more discoverable.  Do
that branded verification.  I
know that kind of sounds like
we're checking on who you are,
but really we're talking about
connecting your other properties
if you have them so that we can
get some more information from
that.  Right?  Get some kig all
in from that  .
signal from
that  .
Two, create a nice informative
direct #24ri      ory listing.
Relevant, actionable    able
language.  These are actions  .
Number three, I know you're
going to add the action phrases.
I'm a hundred percent sure.
Do ad vel     relevant United
Nations with.  We observe things
like well, this triggered and
it flopped.  Or this triggered
and it was really successful.
Right?  And as the ecosystem
matures, we'll get better and
better at that as well.  So
please be thoughtful of these.
But really, really pay some
attention who are
attention here  .
Finally, make something awesome.
Make something people want to
use and that when you do that,
like qualitative evaluation for
yourself, you're like this was
hill      hilarious, or this was
essential, this is something I
need do every day.  Right?
Create something that you love
.
That's it, thank you  .
(Applause)
.
Q&A, Rob?
That sounds great.
VALERIE NYGAARD:  Great.  I
think they have mics  .
Yeah, right there
.
Guys, if you just want to go
have dinner, absolutely fine.
I'm going to give you like five
seconds  .
Thank you so much for being here
, really appreciate it.
Bye.
Rob:  Oh.
VALERIE NYGAARD:  Something I
let you go too soon.  Yeah.
Your question.
In the sort of delight section
of this where you were talking
about potentially servicing
these little slivers of sort of
like preview of what assistant
apps are available, right now
looks like two servicing  .
Do you have plans for how many
could service for a particular
query?  How many
VALERIE NYGAARD:  How many do
you think should service?
I don't know.  Depends on the
query.  I'm curious.  Because we
only saw one example.
VALERIE NYGAARD:  You saw one
example.  This is preproduction.
We'll be playing with that.
Sort of some obvious limitations
in both the phone screen and
also look human cognition.  So
you want to give them basically
their best options, and we think
of it as giving them only
things that are relevant.
Okay.  Can I have a follow-up
question?  Is there going to be
some sort of search function
within the app directory?  Or is
that just, okay.
.
VALERIE NYGAARD:  That seems
like a super good product idea.
Does that search function work
differently than the discovery
methods that you described for
within the assistant?
Rob:  I can handle that.  It
will work differently because of
the context.  You're using
things in a browse ing mode,
another one you may be out on
the go or something.
When you were talking about
discovery strategy, talking
about in the assistant app, not
the directory search context,
right?
We think about
VALERIE NYGAARD:  We think about
both of them.  Rob was saying
they won't be necessarily the
exact same eight       algorithm
.
But it would be a god practice
for target
good practice for targeting
both.
Yes.
Thank you so much.
Great talk, curious about
handoffs on especially the phone
surface to web-based UI  .
In the presentation you used
pizza.  You know, if you wanted
to customize Pisa    pris
pizza, for example, that can get
teed I don't us with suggestion
use with
tedious with
suggestion chips.  Do you have
thoughts, like web based UIs
embedded in the system
experience?
VALERIE NYGAARD:  We have a
ton of thoughts and are not
going to comment today, sorry.
But yes, we are very much
thinking about this problem and
how to address it.
My question was about in
vocation name policy.  So do you
have something that's available
for that now?  Like can you
have single word invocations or
common name invocations?  How do
you deal with that?
VALERIE NYGAARD:  We have a
written policy that's published,
so I feel, which I know pretty
well, I feel a little bit
nervous about quoting it.  But,
oh, do you want to
?
(Off microphone).
VALERIE NYGAARD:  Yeah, here's
, here's how we state it
.   .  If you can show us that
you can lay claim to the brand,
then one-word policy is within
the realm of possibility.  But
most of the time we're not
interested in big land grabs of
single words and common
phrases  .
Totally understand people are le
git cases and that's why we have
an appeal process.
Seems like for some of this
there's a chicken and egg
problem.  You will bring to
light great apps that do great
things, but only if those things
that they are doing are already
well understood.  So for
example, to use, if this existed
five years ago, if I said I'd
like take      a car, I'd like a
car to come pick me up, you
wouldn't think to highlight Uber
or Lyft, but now you do.  So a
hypothetical that I am develop
ing the thing everyone will be
talking about five years from
now, how do I become discovered?
How do I make it so that you
guys will discover me?
VALERIE NYGAARD:  Fantastic
question.  So we're not giving
you a menu to choose from, right
?  We're not restricting you to
only things that we know about
and think are important.  One
example that one of our leaders
likes to use is all right, guys,
if I have a yax k shaving
business to shave yaks, what are
you going to do for me  ?
The way we think about it, right
, that's      let's call it a
tale, if you told us in your
action phrases that I expect
users to say, I'm looking for ya
k shaving or I want to get my ya
k shaved, whatever you feel like
your users are is going to say,
you have a nice actionable
description in your directory
and other clues we'll talk about
another time, that's the kind
of thing we're looking for and
asking for from you.  So when a
user comes and says, okay, can
you shave Y yaks, we can help
that  .
It's a little bit harder, right,
in those tale cases to say they
just asked about farms, let's
throw the yak shaving chip and
see what happens.  But we do
know a lot about semantic
meaning and we're going to be
trying some things  .
Rob, anything to add?
I think that sounds good.
We'll be able to experiment with
things and gradually refine our
understanding of different
intents.
Okay, thank you.
Hi, I work for NBR and one of
the things we think about a lot
is filter bubbles.
VALERIE NYGAARD:  Is what?
Filter bubbles, .
Filter bubbles.
Making sure people are listing
stories from various avenues.
If you're suggesting apps or
even context based on their
prior history, how do you get
them to think outside of that or
present options outside of that
rather than just staying within
their comfort zone?
Arab:   .         Rob:  We can
go back to the selection list
that we're showing.  We want
that to be able to introduce
some diversity of the particular
apps someone can use.  Just as
long as they are high quality
and we have some interest
indication the users
will be interested in it, this
will be a way we think we can
get people exposed to other
things.
VALERIE NYGAARD:  Yeah.  One
thing to add to that, users'
previous history is a signal but
not the only signal.
Hello, is it upon to have an
icon for these apps?  Or do I
have to
create for that?
VALERIE NYGAARD:  Icon?
Short cut.
VALERIE NYGAARD:  Oh, okay.
Oh oh, a short cut.
Icon to open my application
directly.
VALERIE NYGAARD:  Yeah, we
have a couple of solutions.  One
solution halfway of what you
are are talking about, I think.
If you look in the directory,
we have something if you land on
anybody's directory listing
page, like fit start       star
Fit Star, these can add
a short cut.  We think of them
as verbal short cuts, voice
short cuts.  So if it was like,
oh, time to sweat, that's what
you want to say when you want
fit star to invoke, absolutely
you can hook that up  .
The exact thing I think you're
talking about is not something
we're offering right now, but
its interesting
it's interesting.
This is my last question.
More of a road map question.  I
know you can, like to make
really good apps it's helpful to
be able to request more
information from Google about
the user.
So I think maybe you have
location on actions now.  And I
think payment, at least in bite
beta.  Are there going to
be more things like context and
can we get richer information
about the user so we don't have
to ask them again?
VALERIE NYGAARD:  I think this
is going to be essential.  So
you'll see us building this out
over time.  The couple of
principles we have about this is
number one, the user is in
control.  Like absolutely.  But
we really want to offer you the
ability to ask things about the
user in terms of getting, as
long as you get permission from
them, we want to standardize as
men of these as we can that are
reasonable and fit within the
down      boundaries of what
makes sense within these kind of
interactions, because we don't
want you to have to rebuild this
and rebuild this and rebuild
this.  Of course if it's
something relatively common, we
want to offer it to you.  Honey
Honestly this feels like
a matter of time  .
Yes, I think of it as a high
priority, yes.  There's a lot of
high priorities, yes, I'll be
honest.  I can't push the
calendar.  But yeah  .
Last question.
I was wondering if you would
just talk about difference in
discovery between the     a lot
of the examples focused on the
screen and just talk a bit about
discovery on the Google home
norm      platform and headless
devices.
VALERIE NYGAARD:  Do you want
to take that?
Go ahead.
VALERIE NYGAARD:  All right, a
device like Google home or that
kind of interaction modality is
very linear in time.  An audio
signal just goes like this.  The
user doesn't just get to scan
it how they like  .
One of my design colleagues
likes to talk about it like
imagine you're viewing the world
through a straw.  You don't
have a lot of options and it
really takes your time to go
through any sort of center dip
to us           ser            s
version        erendipitous
discovery  .
The way we think about it, why
while these contexts are
not exactly the same, this is a
great play ground for
understanding what is the right
thing to offer to a user.  It's
pretty low cost to offer a set
of suggestions  can chips.  It's
very                    hips.
It's very high cost to say would
you also like to do this or
this or this  .
So we really minimize, we want
to be really conservative when
we do it in an audio only or
very nonscale     scannable
linear signal and be a little
more generous when we try it
here and see how it transfers  .
However, I will say you'll see
just little peaks coming in the
audio-only signal pretty soon,
which is something I'm really
excited about.
Yeah,
great.
I might have missed it, but
when is the new version of
assist        assist can't
Can't kap         can't
tant           ant
Assistant coming to
sfens     phones?  I checked for
updates.  Is it out yet?
VALERIE NYGAARD:  It's
possible you're a really lucky
holdback user.  I'm happy to
chat with you after.  If you're
not seeing it, perhaps you
should be.  Depends what we are
talking about  .
Yep.
We're about out of time.
VALERIE NYGAARD:  You're the
real endurance athletes.  You
stayed until the end of the
.  Very nice.
Thank you for staying to
for attending the
session.  Brand ambassadors will
assist you to the exits.  If
you are vej sterd for
registered for the next
session in this room, we ask
you leave the room and return
via the registration line.
Thank you  .
(Session end)
.
6:session        :30 session  .
In conversation there are
Conversation
There Are no errors         No
Errors
.
Human-to-computer
.  Our session will begin
soon  .
(Next session, in conversation
there are no errors
In
Conversation There Are no errors
No Errors  .
.        )
.
Uir
NANDINI STOCKER:  Hi,
everybody.  Hts talk about one
Let's talk
about one of the hardest parts
of speaking between a human and
computer.
Caused       .
LEON NICHOLS:  So-called
errors.
NANDINI STOCKER:  Any good
conversation starts by knowing
who is talking.
Leon is a developer relation
engineer for Google assistant
apps
.
LEON NICHOLS:  Nandini leads
design for actions on Google.
NANDINI STOCKER:  Our two
teams are responsible for most
of the resources you'll find on
the acts on Google public
website.    where we somehow
show develops
developers how they can design,
build and deploy apps with
the Google Assistant.
LEON NICHOLS:  You can
implement techniques using tools
like API AI with performance
logic in your code  .
(Chuckles)  .
Let's try again  .
You can implement the techniques
we'll show you today using
tools like API.AI through
performance logic in the code or
combination of those, by the
way, API.AI is a tool for
creating apps for the Google
Assistant  .
Now, we want to help developers
create great conversationsel
experiences.  The best way to do
that is by conversation the
design first.  And working in
high collaboration between
designers and dwof
developers, on trade on that
design within the capabilities
of the platform.
NANDINI STOCKER:  In human
human to human
conversations, hesitations and
corrections happen all the time.
We    We just did a little bit
of that.  We might do it again,
and we'll just blame it on the
talk.
LEON NICHOLS:  In
human-to-computer interactions
they do too, but in the form of
time-outs and recognition errors
.
NANDINI STOCKER:  The
differences  is that humans can
take queues from each other to
get back on track in real time.
LEON NICHOLS:  But with a
system ar           simulated
conversation, the corrections
need to be preplanned and that's
not an easy task.
NANDINI STOCKER:  The only way
the     to course correct in
advance and still maintain a
natural, comfortable dialogue is
to plan for them as if they
were any other turn in the
conversation.
LEON NICHOLS:  Now, here are
some of the terms we use when
talking about errors in voice
interfaces.
NANDINI STOCKER:  One of the
first thing to remember is that
there's a difference between the
technical conditions and events
that trigger and respond to
she's errors              these
errors, and all the user
scenarios happening at the same
time.  So any number of things
can go wrong from the users'
perspective for any number of
reasons.
LEON NICHOLS:  We'll show you
how keeping both of these
perspectives in mind will be
really key to your conversation
repair strategy.
NANDINI STOCKER:  Otherwise
it's pretty easy to become
either too simplistic or with a
basic strategy of just
apologizing and asking the same
question over and over again, or
being overly pre     pro
prescriptive and formulate
lay ic in your approach.
LEON NICHOLS:  For example,
here's a formula really common
and often brought into a lot of
built
into a lot of tools and defaults
.
NANDINI STOCKER:  This
unfortunately translates into a
user being asked for tech live
effectively for the
same piece of information with
very little variation, three,
five, even six times.
LEON NICHOLS:  That leads to a
very stiff experience and very
frustrating for users.
NANDINI STOCKER:  It's
important to note that user
impressions and how they are
formed when going through an
error is not just about the
interaction itself they are
going through.  It frames how
people feel as a whole about the
technology.  It's something
that we really care about
changing.
LEON NICHOLS:
.
So in fact we have asked people
how they feel when recognition
doesn't work and they have
negative visceral reactions and
can't always place why.  So one
of the reasons is because people
are using their voice.  Voice
is one of the primary marriagers
of our identity  fy
markers of
identity and it feels ent
extra personal when something
goes wrong  .
So let's dive in and see how we
can handle these with a new
paradigm.
LEON NICHOLS:  We're going to
show you how to so-called
show how errors
error efforts can be handled
and not treated as if cases.
NANDINI STOCKER:  We're going
to show on you
expectations about how nalt
natural conversations are
supposed to work and create
opportunities for more
meaningful interactions.
LEON NICHOLS:  That means for
any given prompt, you're a user,
you have to be thinking of all
the things that could go wrong
in that moment.
NANDINI STOCKER:  But you can
still break it down into two
paths to the problem.  Either
you didn't get any input and
usually that's because the user
didn't say anything or because
they were too quiet to be picked
up by the mic, or it could be
that you got input but you just
weren't prepared to handle it.
LEON NICHOLS:  In the
underlying system, these two
categories can be addressed as
either no inputs or no matches.
NANDINI STOCKER:  But as part
of this new paradigm we're not
going to start there.  It pays
to look at how you can eliminate
the bulk of your errors right
off the top with some preventive
strategies  .
First of all you want to use the
power of spoken language to
your advantage by using well
crafted intuitive language in
your prompt structure and
prevent errors in the first
place.  So there's a great talk
tomorrow about this by the god
father of voice user interfaces,
James j   Jongola, must not
miss.
LEON NICHOLS:  Otherwise look
at how to prevent errors by
being prepared to answer
specific type of requests but
more of strategies.
NANDINI STOCKER:  So your
first preventive strategy, be
ready to provide help in the
moment.  This usually means
being ready to handle if someone
asks to hear something again or
express their confusion maybe
more explicitly by saying
something like I'm not sure, why
do you want to know  .
Let's look at how we implement
that.
LEON NICHOLS:  We need to be
able to first categorize these
responses and then add logic to
handle them  .
Some of the main concepts in ape
.AI    ape     API         API.
AI include's, natural
understanding for apps.  Agents
consist of intents which respond
to particular user inputs, and
con Kent which are the
tents which are the
ways to prioritize during a
conversation.
NANDINI STOCKER:  During the
many back and forth turns in a
conversation, each of the user
responses will map to an intents
.  Like you see here, a few key
ones are repeat, help and quit.
LEON NICHOLS:  Here's a help
intent we created in API with AI
.
NANDINI STOCKER:  Notice it's
not just a global command help.
That's not the only thing we're
handling.  All the things the
user might say to ask for help.
How you respond to those of
course will depend on your
strategy, and we'll show you a
little bit about that.  Perhaps
you give them a hint or might
ask them a follow-up question to
make sure they are ready to
continue.
LEON NICHOLS:  To make that
work we have to add additional
intent for the users additional
responses to that help prompt
like you see here.
NANDINI STOCKER:  Next
immediately I want to jump in
and find out how do I make it
even more relevant in 245 moment
that moment, maybe
by playing dynamic data, like if
I want to include a variable,
for example.
LEON NICHOLS:  Sure, you can
do that using informant.
NANDINI STOCKER:  You can see
some dynamic info about the game
length and the question whether
the user wants to continue.
They are listening for a yes-no
answer to the help question
itself.
LEON NICHOLS:  Yes, and we can
dynamically set a context to
ensure the user's response is
handed  led by the yes-no help
intent.
NANDINI STOCKER:  But if the
user got the help they needed
when they heard that and didn't
say yes or no but just answered
the original question before
they asked for help.  So we
wouldn't want that to trigger an
error, otherwise we sort of
defeated the purpose to begin
with.
LEON NICHOLS:  Right, so we
don't have is to worry about
that since the other game ing
things are still available and
will handle that if that happens
.
NANDINI STOCKER:  So that's
help.  Some of the questions
that come up in the moment like
repeat.  It's a pretty big
prevention strategy out of the
way  .
Another very basic strategy is
to prevent frustrating back and
forth, is to simply make it easy
for users to leave.  They might
need to stop for a variety of
reasons.  So be    being
prepared for that is not only
key to preventing errors but
it's the right thing to do.
LEON NICHOLS:  Also it can be
an opportunity for reengagement,
for example, perhaps let them
know how to come back or pick up
where they left off.  If that's
an option.  But without being
annoying.
NANDINI STOCKER:  So we need
for this to create another
intent for quit, right?
LEON NICHOLS:  Yes.  So start
by anticipate ing all the ways
the user might want to leave.
Just like help, which phrases
you might choose depend on the
context.
NANDINI STOCKER:  For this
game example here, you can is is
see we add the cuss
ed custom phrases
appropriate for a game, like
stop the game or stop playing.
Just like help, we want to make
the response to user more
feng      meaningful.  Since it
is a game, I want to give them
the satisfaction of knowing
their skoesh        score, where
they left off.
LEON NICHOLS:  Like we showed
you with help, if you want to
include a variable, that's where
performer comes in.  You can
see our quit intent.  We're
giving the yurgs the score
before
user the score before saying
good-bye.
NANDINI STOCKER:  To give an
idea how these prevention
strategies are so critical to
catching things in context and
why that matters is to much
so much, take a couple
users responses that mean
something different depending on
the situation.  Take frank
for example I don't know
and I give up  .
In most contexts, I don't know
means it's just another way of
saying help, you know, but if
you are playing a game, that my
may or may not hold true
.  For example on the one hand
you could have a game where the
user maybe wants to know a
little more about the rules and
they are not familiar with it.
So in that case, sure, I don't
know means help like any other
context  .
But if it's a familiar mental
mold like guess
model like guessing game or
trivia where the user says I
don't know or I give up, they
might just mean they want the
answer so they can move on, in
which case it's literally the
opposite of quit.  It means
let's keep playing.
LEON NICHOLS:  This might mean
breaking up I don't remember
help                       your
help for I don't know phrases
into different contexts.  Take
two games in our number guessing
game nn    Number Genie on the
left, I give up is part of the
quit inat the time
tent.  But with the trivia
game on the right, I give up is
part of the I don't know intent.
This let's the user skip
giving an answer to the question
.
NANDINI STOCKER:  On the way
Another way that
to prevent errors is to
use the built pf in cape
-in capability ies of the
platform.  We just announced
several of these at IO.
LEON NICHOLS:  Two is common
support called conversation
helpers.  These have been
crafted to follow business
design practices and also to
best design practices
and also to handle errors.  We
recommend you use these so you
don't have to create for
yourself.
NANDINI STOCKER:  That's a lot
of deceptively simple but often
overlooked prevention
strategies.  Shows should help
Those should
help user feel more in control
of the interaction.
LEON NICHOLS:  Even in
conversations between humans,
hesitations and repair happen.
And as we know, speech
recognition isn't perfect.  So
when it doesn't work, let's call
those errors for now.
NANDINI STOCKER:  We have a
couple of great strategies
coming up where we make them
feel a little less like errors
per se and more like new turns
in the dialogue like we have
been promise ing.  Before     ut
before we show that, we think
it is important to see what it
looks like when you do start
from
scratch.
LEON NICHOLS:  We'll look at
our basic errors, the no inputs
and no matches
.  If you create a new agent in
API.AI you get two default
intents as a starting point.
The agent will start by greeting
you with the default welcome
intent, and if you don't say
anything, it will hit a couple
ofny in      new inputs and give
up  .
If you do respond you hit a no
match.
NANDINI STOCKER:  So you're
saying starting from scratch, we
have a clean slate of only
errors.
LEON NICHOLS:  Yeah.  So let's
take a look at how the default
agent handles no inputs.  We're
going to play a video of me
invoke ing the agent on Google
home,  and not saying anything.
Default action.
LEON NICHOLS:  Hmm.
I didn't hear what you just
said.  Hmm.  I couldn't hear
what you just said.  Hmm
.
Sorry, I can't help.
NANDINI STOCKER:  And for no
matches?
LEON NICHOLS:  For no matches,
that will invoke the default
calc lback intent which has a
set of static responses selected
randomly to respond to the user
.
NANDINI STOCKER:  Anything the
user says will go to the de
fault fallback intent.  So let's
take a look at that.
LEON NICHOLS:  Let's do that.
We have another video, .
Default action.
Here is the test version of
default action.  Hello.
LEON NICHOLS:  Hi.
I missed what you said.  Say
it again.
LEON NICHOLS:  I said hi.
Sorry, can you say that again
?
LEON NICHOLS:  (Roar).
I didn't get that.
LEON NICHOLS:  I tried to
greet you.
Can you say that again  ?
.
(Dog barking)  .
What was that?
LEON NICHOLS:  Hmm, I said hi.
I didn't get that.  Can you
say it again?
(CAT meow).
What was that?
LEON NICHOLS:  Why do I have
to repeat myself?
Sorry, what was that?
LEON NICHOLS:  Okay, good-bye
.
Okay, you see the conversation
never ends.  And if you want to
change that, you have to add a
custom intent to handle the
first user response.
NANDINI STOCKER:  Obviously
that's no wra     way to hold a
conversation, and we do have a
lot of built-ins that you can
add.  But it's important to
start from that just to see how
it works in you were to start
from scratch so that all the
things that we show you next
will start       make sense and
connect.
LEON NICHOLS:  Otherwise API.
AI does provide some sample data
and agents for common use cases
that you could start with
instead.  We're always looking
at ways to improve the tools
better by default.
NANDINI STOCKER:  Meantime
we'll use that as a baseline and
explore some more targeted
solutions
.
LEON NICHOLS:  Okay.  Now,
let's take the case of when no
input is triggered.
NANDINI STOCKER:  Here
remember the user either
actually es    didn't say
anything or perhaps they got
distracted or didn't hear the
question.  Maybe they were
listening, didn't understand and
were just waiting to whaer
hear what it would do
next.  But it could also be they
started talking during the
prompt and stopped right when
the mic started listening.
LEON NICHOLS:  So how do we
design for that?
NANDINI STOCKER:  For no
inputs you probably need to
consider first if you even need
the answer to get to the next
step.  So how you react should
really consider why the user
didn't respond, all those
reasons I talked about.  So it's
a new turn in the dialogue,
therefore an opportunity.
LEON NICHOLS:  Now we have
something examples that show the
difference it makes to your
wording
depending how hard you want to
try and how much help you assume
the user needs.
NANDINI STOCKER:  So when you
write reprompts for in input,
you should keep them contextual,
but that doesn't necessarily
mean repeating the exact same
question verbatim.  So maybe you
just need to reframe it or
reword it just slightly.  Or
maybe you could use it as an
opportunity to answer an unasked
question  .
As far as
how many times you want to try,
maybe you don't want to belabor
it and maybe you want to
gracefully exit.  Or  But for
most cases you could make use of
some sort of default pattern.
Right now the default is three,
but maybe it might change.  And
find out just     , just specify
what you want it to say for
each of the three.  That's a
design traj for new in
strategy for new
inputs.  Let's take a look how
to implement.
LEON NICHOLS:  As I mentioned
earlier, the did fault
Dei fault,                de
by get     default API.AI
handles with a standard list of
prompts.  To change these to be
domain specific, you need to
implement your own logic.  As
part of the SPK for develop, ing
actions we provide a no judge
client library that makes it
really easy to do that  .
The client library API let's you
specify the no           s
lets you specify the
prompts.
NANDINI STOCKER:  The
conversation automatically ends
a   after the third final prompt
.  For example, we can stop here
, let's play again soon.  That's
how we're ending it  .
Now, let's look at the biggest
opportunity for creative error
handling, no matches.
LEON NICHOLS:  Just like with
no inputs, deciding whether to
use default fallback for I don't
matches or something
your
matches should being    targeted
or for what you are designing
for.
NANDINI STOCKER:  You need to
consider if the answer is even
needed.  If it is you have to
consider the users' situation
and even the sequence of
questions.  And if you don't
need it, that's where you also
might decide to just move on,
pivot or gracefully end.
LEON NICHOLS:  That seems like
a lot to consider, so where do
we start?
NANDINI STOCKER:  During and
conversation it's important to
stop and look at what's
happening in each turn.  So
usually in one turn in the
dialogue, one participant is
usually the owner of the
information the other person is
seeing        seeking.
Depending on the context of the
question and which side of the
conversation has that
information, the strategy will
vary.  So let me show you three
examples of why this matters
.
In this question the app knows
the answer and the your
user is guessing.  But they do
have a good mend      mental
mold of what's
model of what's expected so
potentially errors are at a low
cost.  If if he     they don't
know or need help, it may be
they don't know how the game is
played or how many guest they
guesses they have,
or like earlier, maybe they want
to give up and have you tell
them  .
But take this question for
reservation exchange.
Here only the user knows the
actual answer.  But you can make
some logic assumptions like
expecting a certain range, and
most of the time the answer will
probably be something like 20
or fewer people.  So if the user
needs help or says I don't know
, the strategy you can use
depends again on how critical
that answer is to continue to
the next step  .
Take a third example where both
sides are trying to match on
shared knowledge.  Both sides
are supposed to know the answer,
anyway.  But especially in this
type of scenario where it's
likely some sort of gate keeping
mechanism, the user may or may
not know what it is, or they
want to know why do you need
this information, why are you
even asking me this.  So for
those types of situations, they
are much more likely to need in
context help to continue.
LEON NICHOLS:  So good
strategy here is to consider
context by context and offer up
what might be more useful in
that moment?
NANDINI STOCKER:  Exactly.
Whatever is most likely to keep
the conversation moving forward
is what you would use to decide
on how to reprompt.
LEON NICHOLS:  How do we
decide on the wording?
NANDINI STOCKER:  I'm glad you
asked, Leon  .
First of all there's nothing
wrong with having a few generic
fallback messages.  So we call
these rapid reprompts.  Users
often just need some sort of
quick signal to indicate you
didn't pick up examplely what
exactly what
they said the first time.
However, this strategy only
works if you are listening for
the right things to begin with.
So if you aren't catching what
they said the first time and you
don't catch it when they repeat
, you can imagine how that gets
pretty tiresome pretty quickly.
LEON NICHOLS:  So you need to
consider the user's situational
context for each and every
question carefully 1234.
NANDINI STOCKER:
?
NANDINI STOCKER:  Of course.
It often means maybe asking
another way.  Sometimes it even
means breaking down the question
into parts.  Maybe even you're
listening for both but you might
ask for one just to move the
conversation forward  .
Now depending how important,
again, the information is that
you're asking for, you can also
make use of escalating detail to
let users in on what is it you
need from them and why are you
asking.  Again, to keep the
conversation moving and answer
that unasked question  .
Finally, depending on your app's
persona and how assertive it
is, you might also decide to be
progive and take control
active and take
control of the situation.
LEON NICHOLS:  Let's look at
how you go about implementing
some of
these more robust strategies.
First of all it will require
implementing performance for the
default fallback intent.  The
performance logic will create
these responses dynamically in
code.
NANDINI STOCKER:  The core
implementation strategy we
recommend is to track user
progress, lay out your reprompts
, and like they say when you
love something, you have to know
when to let it go  .
For the apps we have built
together, our code logic uses
counters and various session
variables to keep track of the
users       user's progress.
LEON NICHOLS:  For example
here is the performance logic
for Number Genie where we use a
counter to check how many times
the user provided a response
handled by the default fallback
intent.  Now our client library
for the performance logic
provides a way to store data
within a user session.
NANDINI STOCKER:  You'll then
use those counters to build a
dynamic reprompt strategy, using
both a combination of generic
fallbacks sometimes and context
sensitive approaches like we
talked about earlier.
LEON NICHOLS:  In API.AI the
default fallback intent can be a
starting point with a minimum
set of basic reprompts.  Here we
have a set of default rapid
reprompts that provide a catch
all anywhere and will reprompt
the user to say their response
again.
NANDINI STOCKER:  From there
you can change those defaults to
suit your app.  You might just
want to add more to that list,
add a few different rapid
reprompts.
LEON NICHOLS:  The agent will
then randomly select from your
prompts whenever a no match is
triggered.
NANDINI STOCKER:  So like we
said, sometimes you might want
to pivot and ask the question a
little differently, though.  So
a rapid reprompt might not be
enough.
LEON NICHOLS:  In this
instance, for example, we
created again and we wanted to
use the default handler to ask a
yes-no question, whether the
user was done playing
.  It saw     saw gen rein Rick
and catch ol
generic and catch ol
all but we customized for
the strategy of the game.
NANDINI STOCKER:  To get the
users back on track you might
want your reprompt to not be
generic, so you might want more
context like some of the
examples we showed.
LEON NICHOLS:  To plan for the
logic needed to implement
context sensitive reprompt, it
really helps to see them mapped
out ahead of time.  In some user
journeys and sample dialogs
first.  For example when I walk
through the journeys Nandini
wrote for Number Genie they
drove what variables and states
needs       needed to be trapped
cked in the app's
performance logic.
NANDINI STOCKER:  Each time
you repromd pt look for
opportunities to add variability
or re#23r5i78 the
frame the question.  This will
lend more naturalness to the
dialogue and help users
sometimes not even realize
they are experiencing an error
per se.
LEON NICHOLS:  So to reframe
the question you asked, we can
use a feature in API.AI that
allows you to tag with labels
for context.  Here's one tagged
with the get time context.
NANDINI STOCKER:  This is the
fulfillment logic with a default
fallback intent for the get
time context, what it looks like
.
LEON NICHOLS:  These can also
be statically assigned in API.AI
web GUI for each intent, for
example, a list of intents we
designed for a trivia game.
Notice all the expected user
responses we handle using many
different intents, including
help, quit and restart.
NANDINI STOCKER:  Now let's
say you wanted to combine both
strategies.  We can show you how
to implement both together in a
more escalating reprompt
strategy.
LEON NICHOLS:  From experience
we know that rapid reproms work
but we also know depending on
the user scenario, we might want
to pivot after another error.
NANDINI STOCKER:  To do that
you'll need to keep a counter
and increase it every time that
the user response is handled by
that fault       fallback intent
.
LEON NICHOLS:  Here is the
#30er78         performance
logic for the default fallback
intent for our trivia game.
Notice how we user a counter
that is stored?    in decision
data.
NANDINI STOCKER:  For the
first time the intent is invoked
we provide a rap it re      id
reprompt by using the client
library ask function.  For the
second time we respond with a
fullback
response.
LEON NICHOLS:  Now obviously
that kes     es    escalation
shouldn't go on never
forever.
NANDINI STOCKER:  When it
comes to no matches, know when
to give up.
LEON NICHOLS:  After you have
tried a couple of times, once
the counter goes above a
threshold, they are out of the
conversation
bough out
bow out of the
conversation gracefully.
NANDINI STOCKER:  How you word
that precisely depends on your
persona.
LEON NICHOLS:  Back to the
default fallback handler, when
the user response triggers
intent for the third time, we
provide a fallback prompt and
then end the conversation by
using the client library tell
function.
NANDINI STOCKER:  However, of
course if the conversation with
the user recovers and another en
intent is invoked like we
talked about earlier, if they
actually angst the question
answer the
question, it's not a default
fallback, then we reset that
counter value.
LEON NICHOLS:  Those were just
the basics.
NANDINI STOCKER:  Just the
basics.
LEON NICHOLS:  Yep.  So from
here you can find lots of ways
to step up your conversation
repair game even more.
NANDINI STOCKER:  But wait
there's more  .
So one way is to inherently
disguise errors.  So by adding
fat recallness and variability
to make                y
naturalness
and variability to make the
entire process more err gauging.
e           engaging
venlth not just                .
Not just      just error proms
but everywhere else.
LEON NICHOLS:  This is where
design be   ing with a
particular persona apps      app
koums in hand je.
NANDINI STOCKER:
y.
NANDINI STOCKER:  We'll show
you one example of what we mean.
For example the trivial
game, we use a team
teacher persona.  His name is
Mr. Montgomery.  He is the type
of character super encharge ing
e     ourage ing, you got
this.  He's a teacher,
replication?
LEON NICHOLS:  To give you an
idea, out teacher has over 50
ways of saying you got the
answer right.
NANDINI STOCKER:  Over 30 ways
to proper you up
prop you up if you got it wrong
.
Also, again, this is stepping up
your game.  Use threading
techniques.  So in spoken
dialogue between humans,
elements of a conversation are
woven together in a coherent
thread.  And that includes both
context and the way the
conversation evolves over time.
So this type of thread
ing helps us keep track of that
conversational flow.
LEON NICHOLS:  You would have
to write the prompts that thread
together well but programmatic
ally speaking you need to
support the flow in some
underlying framework.  That will
use tracking, context and
countsers just like we talked
about before.
NANDINI STOCKER:  To support
variability and threading, you
could build a robust list of
projects and         mpts and
randomize them.
LEON NICHOLS:  You can scale
without changing the code.
NANDINI STOCKER:  If you can
randomize 3 , it    you can do
103.  They can be cat Nate ing
for a large number of
permutations.
LEON NICHOLS:  Can     You a
can add dynamic variables to
replace at run time.
NANDINI STOCKER:  20    To
prevent the user from hearing
same prompts in sequence, you
can remember which prompts you
played and avoid them when
random lib    ly picking next
from the list.
LEON NICHOLS:  You can also
track the number of errors and
in what skens they occur
October                 equence
42 October            they occur
1999     .
NANDINI STOCKER:  Finally,
after you deploy the app, the
error handling approach doesn't
stop.  You should check in with
what users are doing and adjust
strategy if needed.
LEON NICHOLS:  API.AI provides
a training feature which allows
you to track which users
responses are not mapped
being mapped by intent.  This
feedback could be used to expand
support for user kroers
queries and can also give
hints on what new intents might
need to be added to your app.
NANDINI STOCKER:  One powerful
notion to remember is that
users who are not encountring
counter
countering errors should
feel the benefit of progressing
through so that when an error
is encountered they don't feel
derailed.  Also it's proven that
reminding them how far they
have gotten or that they don't
have far to go will help them
get back on track  .
That's enough strategy for
ies for now.  Let's look at
these in action.
LEON NICHOLS:  Okay.  So we
are going to show you a demo of
Number Genie which we designed
together.  It's available as a
sample on our site.
NANDINI STOCKER:  We chose a
number guessing game because we
felt like you guys as developers
can mentally map a number
guessing game and sort of
picture some of the concepts we
have been talking about.  We
have built there a hidden
developer mode.  This game is
public.  You're welcome to try
this out.  I'm going to pray to
the demo guys they don't smiet
smite me here  .
There's a lidden developer
hidden developer
mode we can set the number the
gene is thinking of and guess
around it so you can hear the
strategies we talked about  .
All right?  Okay.  Hey Google,
let's talk to Number Genie about
.
Sure, here is Number Genie  .
I'm thinking of a number from on
zero to 100.  What's your
first guess?
DUKE DUKELLIS:  50
.
NANDINI STOCKER:  50.
Lower.  Have another guess?
NANDINI STOCKER:  Zero.
I see what you did there.  But
no, it's higher than zero.
NANDINI STOCKER:  30.
I didn't hear a number.
You're getting warm.  It's
lower than 30.  Have another
guess?
NANDINI STOCKER:  17.
It's so close but not quite.
NANDINI STOCKER:  19.
It's higher than 19.  What's
your next guess
?
NANDINI STOCKER:  20.
Are you done playing number
Number Genie?
DUKE DUKELLIS:  No
NANDINI STOCKER:
No.
Great, what's your next guess?
NANDINI STOCKER:  21.
(Blink     Bling)  .
Well done, it is indeed 121  .
21.  Want to hey     play
again?
NANDINI STOCKER:  No thanks.
LEON NICHOLS:  It's really
interesting to see the
interaction, but a number
guessing game is deceptively
simple.  If you just think about
it as compare ing a number and
a guess.  But it can be designed
to be delightful by adding
layers of tracking in the game
logic.
NANDINI STOCKER:  Let's look
real quick under the hood at the
full fit     fillment logic of
Number Genie je we      .
LEON NICHOLS:  We check a lot
of things in the conversation.
Notice we use countel fallbacks.
NANDINI STOCKER:  We track the
number of guesses, valt
value of previous guess, and how
many times the user gives the
same answer.
LEON NICHOLS:  We also
consider how far away the user
guess is from the answer.
NANDINI STOCKER:  As the user
gets closer to the answer, which
the demo didn't work, we
provide rapid reprompts and
encouraging sounds.  So try it
out yourself and you'll see
there's a few hidden gems in
there in the way it reprompts
and it throws in a few sounds
when you're closing   er or far
t further           further away
.
LEON NICHOLS:  We remember if
we give a   the user a hint in
what direction the answer is.
NANDINI STOCKER:  We change
the prompts and track when the
user followed or ignore hints.
Ing sure and try
Be sure and try that out too.
LEON NICHOLS:  You can see
some of the prompts we dynamic
ally provide values for the
characters in the prompts wade
on urs        based on user
based on user
input and game state.
NANDINI STOCKER:  I hope we
showed you a foundation of
building conversation repair
strategy.  We talked a bit about
the types of errors
error events to plan for, how to
use built-ins and other
existing tool features to
implement in your design and
prevent the bulk of errors by
anticipate ing and tracking user
progress and context.
LEON NICHOLS:  But the key to
any strategy for creating a
conversational experience,
especially for when things go
wrong, is to step back and look
at the user situation.
NANDINI STOCKER:  Don't create
dead ends when something didn't
work.  Remember it doesn't have
to be treated as an error.
LEON NICHOLS:  Now there are
more docs and resources
available on our site, including
white papers and a design
checklist.
NANDINI STOCKER:  Which
includes an entire list of
conversation repair check items.
Also take a look at the sample
apps that we have open sourced
in github.
LEON NICHOLS:  There's also a
lot more talks about
conversation design tomorrow as
well as office hours, so you can
talk to some of our teams  .
Because we think some of the
best strategies will come from
you, we want to hear all about
what you come up with.
NANDINI STOCKER:  So as you
saw yesterday, we announced the
actions on Google developer
challenge.  We had a little
a little part in that
.
Remember when you're creating
yours that any winning app
probably will have a killer
conversational repair strategy
at its core, right?
LEON NICHOLS:  And we can't
wait to see what you create.
NANDINI STOCKER:  Thank you.
VALERIE NYGAARD:  Thanks  .
(Applause)          Applause
.
LEON NICHOLS:  Thanks.
Thank you for joining the
session.  Brand aim
ambassador will assist with
directing you through the
designated exits  .
(Session end)  .
.